Momma Max, der heißeste Scheiß. Auf jeden Fall einer der Wärmeren.
Nicht so übertreiben.
Professor Dr. Felix von Kube spricht zum Thema besiege deinen Nächsten wie dich selbst. Aggression im Alltag.
Meine Damen und Herren, es gibt ja auch verbale Aggression. Man kann ja jemanden beleidigen, beschimpfen, anschreien, erniedrigen.
Du kannst doch nicht lachen!
Wenn wir beim Erniedrigen sind, das ist ja zweifellos ein aggressiver Akt, dann muss man ja auch logischerweise sagen, dass das sich selbst erhöhen auch Aggression ist.
Du willst hier wirklich ein Apple Display kaufen auch? Also es gibt auch von anderen Firmen tatsächlich echt brauchbare Displays, die nur die Hälfte kosten.
Aggression reicht noch weiter. Es ist nicht nur das Imponieren. Es muss jemand da sein, der herausfordert. Aggression ist durchaus auch spontan.
Ja, wollen wir dann mal wieder mehr über Max reden?
Jetzt sagt er, der immer nur Microsoft und Nokia hat.
Ich hab nichts von Microsoft oder Nokia gesagt.
Ach, schon wieder habt ihr gehört?
Wenn man also Aggression als etwas Natürliches anzieht, als etwas Nicht-Schuldhaftes, dann kommt man mit den Menschen besser aus. Man versteht sie besser.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zag Return.
Ja, haben wir unsere Aggressionen im Griff?
Warum machen wir denn die Sendung hier?
Naja, um uns abzureagieren.
Und die anderen brauchen sich dann nicht mehr aufregen, sondern die hören einfach bei uns zu.
Zwei Wochen ist eigentlich bisher ganz optimal gewesen, aber wenn das so weitergeht, meinst du, du musst das so öfter machen? Wenn das so weitergeht, dann muss ich hier mal richtig, müssen wir jede Woche was machen.
Also mein Arzt hat mir gesagt, alle zwei Wochen wäre okay.
Ein konzentres Building und Feier.
Genau, was sagt dein Bewegungshelfer?
Ja, willkommen bei der Aggressionspotential-Abbaurunde Mobile-Max Ausgabe Nummer 82. Ja auch. Das ist ja ein Universal-Podcast. Also den kann man sowohl zum Aufregen als auch zum Abregen benutzen und das gleichzeitig.
Ach, das sind diese Enhanced-Podcasts.
Genau.
Aggressionsaufbau Ost.
In HD.
Mobile-Max HD finde ich gut. Übrigens, du musst jetzt, jetzt wo ich es gerade wieder gehört habe, mit dem Boom-Zack-Return, du musst jetzt einfach auch in den nächsten Sendungen regelmäßig da bist, immer mal so ein Boom oder so ein Zack oder so ein Return-Drop, damit dann irgendwann mal eine neue Version kommen kann. Und also, ne? So, jetzt können wir gleich zum nächsten festen Programmpunkt übergehen. Audio Setup.
Du kannst ja auch nochmal alle vorstellen.
Kannst du meinen Kopfhörer vorher noch ein bisschen...
Noch leiser?
Er will uns nicht mehr hören.
Nee, doch, das ist aber noch total laut.
Dein Gehör möchte ich mal haben.
Ja, ich pass drauf auf, genau deswegen.
Ist gut.
Ja, so, ich glaub jetzt.
Du kannst noch noch leiser machen. Dann kann ich dich richtig anschreien, du bist mir noch nicht mal böse.
So war es eigentlich ganz angenehm, ehrlich gesagt.
Sonst waren welche Bemängelungen oder so? Der Rest war ausreichend Technopartys, um mit dem Pegel leben zu können.
Ich bin Gitarrist in einer Band. Und wie heißt das so schön? Die größte Lüge eines Gitarristen? Ich hör mich nicht.
Aber wird schon lustig gewesen sein.
Wir werden jetzt auch hier dem gemeinen Nerdwitz noch eine Chance geben. Ansonsten sind wir uns ja einig, über wen es hier zu richten gilt. Apple, eine Firma im Abstieg, die ihren Höhepunkt gesehen hat. Und wie sich vor vielen Jahren... Wie sich vor vielen Jahren andeutete, dass alles bergauf geht, sehe ich langsam den Stern ja ein bisschen sinken.
Und, wer kommt danach?
Das ist eine gute Frage, die können wir wahrscheinlich dann erst so gegen Ende der Sendung klären.
Achso. Es ist auch nicht, dass hier Tim irgendwie verzerrt klingt, weil er ein schlechtes Mikrofon oder so benutzt. Das ist alles schon sozusagen... Klingt verzerrt? Das ist Apple, das Lion quasi.
Wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich hätte es auch gerne ein bisschen leiser.
Ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht. Warte mal, was meckern denn hier immer alle?
Also für mich bist du auch nicht verzerrt. Wenn ich das höre, was aufgenommen wird, dann ist super.
Ja, also wir hören das, was rausgeht, sagen wir es mal so. Ich habe jetzt mal so ein bisschen die Lautstärke rausgenommen.
Tim wird halt auch ein bisschen älter. Der hat nicht mehr die sanfte Engelsstimme von früher.
Sanfte Engelsstimme?
Jetzt hast du dir Mühe gegeben gerade, ne?
Ich gebe mir immer Mühe beim Podcasting. Na gut, also Apple versucht dem Niedergang nochmal etwas entgegenzuhalten.
Ja, ne, ist so richtig.
Und recycelt dabei, greift jetzt sozusagen, kopiert sich selbst, das finde ich sehr interessant. Das ist mal was ganz Neues. Also ihnen fallen jetzt noch nicht mal mehr.
Von anderen können sie ja nichts kopieren, das ist ja das Traurige dabei.
Na gut, aber bei Namen, ich meine, bei Namen, denn ist du wederst.
Und das am Anfang der Sendung. Was ist denn los, Leute? Ein 3 km von seinem Gesicht entfernt.
Also als direkte Reaktion auf unsere letzte Sendung hat Apple sich dann entschlossen, vorzeitig ein neues Betriebssystem anzukündigen. Wahrscheinlich in dem Versuch, noch irgendwie nicht so viele Updates machen zu müssen. Ja, hier einen guten Eindruck zu machen. Ich meine, wir haben uns beklagt, dass einfach nichts Neues kommt. Irgendwie die ganze Situation. Dennis, ich drehe mal hier deinen Expander ein bisschen hoch. Das geht ja so gar nicht.
Deinen Expander hochtreten? Voll Energie auf die Deflektor-Schilder.
So, naja, auf jeden Fall, da hab ich mich schon so ein bisschen gewundert und sage, warum nennen sie das jetzt Mountainline? Also erstens hab ich gesagt, das soll Snowline heißen, ja, das scheint auch mal wieder überhaupt keiner mitbekommen zu haben. Zweitens, hießen die ja schon mal so.
Pfäfest du gerade?
Mountainline? Wie macht man das?
Naja, so sich komplett überdimensional sehen und die Piraten vollschimpfen, weil sie nicht das machen, was man ihnen vorgeschrieben hat.
Piraten.
Ja, Apple dann meinetwegen.
Da warte ich dann noch mal auf ein ordentliches OS-Release von den Piraten. Bis dahin halte ich mich an Apple. Naja, aber ich meine Mountainline, schlag das mal nach, das ist ein Puma.
Ja.
Und Puma hieß es aber schon mal. MacOS 10.1 hieß Puma.
Und du bestehst auf sozio-logisch korrekte Codenamen, weil...
Naja, sie könnten ja so wie jetzt beim iPhone, wo sie 4 und 4S und 3 und 3G und 3GS und so, dann machen sie jetzt halt bei den MacOS-Releases immer in Snow noch davor. Also, die nächste Katze, die jetzt dran gewesen wäre, wäre ja eh der Liga gewesen.
Hier steht aber, dass Mountainline ist kein Puma, sondern ein Kuga. Und Kuga wollten sie wahrscheinlich nicht nehmen, weil das habe ich vergessen.
Das ist das Gleiche, Puma, Kuga, Mountainline.
Same difference.
Hier steht nix von Puma, hier steht was von Panther.
Aber es stimmt schon, Kuga klingt so nach Cigar und dann denkt man gleich in einen alten US-Resident.
Da, erst, Puma, Concholor, also known as Puma, Mountainline, Mountaincat, Catamount oder Panther.
Also Panther und Puma waren auch schon das gleiche.
Das dreht sich einfach im Kreis. Die sollen jetzt einfach durchnummerieren, Katze 1, Katze 2, Katze 3.
Also ich wär auch für Snowline erstmal gewesen und dann Liga und dann Snowliga.
Und dann Garfield und Snowgarfield.
Snowliga, das klingt auch ganz schön, so phonetisch finde ich.
Also ich glaube Liga wird es nie heißen, weil kein Mensch weiß, was ein Liga ist und ob es überhaupt noch welche gibt oder jemals gab.
Doch, es gibt sogar Bilder auf Wikipedia.
Ja ich glaube auch, dass die Liga sich nicht vermehren können, ist glaube ich, was das hält Apple doch eher davon an.
Na die Kreuzung aus Löwe und Tiger.
Die können sich nicht vermehren?
Das ist wie ein Maultier, das ist ja auch eine Mischung aus Pferd und Esel und ist nicht mehr in der Lage, sich weiter zu vermehren. Aber Ligas sind mit Abstand die größten Katzen, die man irgendwie züchten kann, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die ich auch nicht so genau weiß.
Wenn sie so richtig behebe ich, wenn sie so richtig genug Trägheitsmoment dann mitschleifen.
Naja es gibt sicherlich noch ein paar andere Katzen und so. Ich meine, wenn ich mir die Releases so anschaue, sollten sie sich jetzt auch eher mal im Haus-Katzen-Bereich umschauen, weil irgendwie dieser Anspruch hier, wir sind die dicke Katze, das geht ja wohl auch gar nicht mehr. Ihr merkt, ich bin schon ein bisschen angefressen, dieses Leid macht mich einfach wahnsinnig.
Ja, lasst es alle drüben. Fangen wir gleich damit an, am besten haben wir es hinter uns.
Wie heißt diese Schleichkatze, die diesem Kaffee ausscheißt?
Wo hat das Betriebssystem dir wehgetan?
Äh, hab ich jetzt vergessen?
Würde es sich ja bei das Betriebssystem-Name gut machen. Ich mein, so Kaffee ausscheißen, das fehlt eigentlich noch.
Die Kaffee-scheißende Katzensau, nee. Also die Begeisterung hält sich in Grenzen auf jeden Fall.
Hält sich in Grenzen, so. Ihr hattet sicherlich alle schon mal ein bisschen die Gelegenheit, ein bisschen in den Berglöwen rumzustochen.
Schon dreimal installiert und deinstalliert. Aber ein bisschen gestöbert.
Schauen wir doch mal auf die Versprechen, die sie uns machen hier.
iCloud ist dabei.
Na hurra!
Das war doch vorher schon.
Diesmal funktioniert es.
Du kannst am Finder direkt in der iCloud speichern. Das hast du vorher nicht gehabt.
Zeig mal. Glocken dich doch mal ein bei iCloud.
Wie im Finder.
Na, wenn du save machst, dann kriegst du dann als...
Save im Finder?
Naja, das ist schon diesen Finder-Dialog da. Diesen Open...
Das war ich ja nicht im Finder. Wahrscheinlich musste ich vorher erst mal bei iCloud anmelden, oder?
Das ist nicht der Finder. Du redest jetzt generell von...
Es könnte sein, dass man sich vorher bei iCloud anmelden muss.
Um iCloud zu nutzen, muss man iCloud anmelden.
Als kleiner Einschub am Rande, Kopi Luwak heißt die Katze.
Das geht total gut von der Zunge.
Auf jeden Fall besser als M-M-M-Mountainline.
M-M-M-M-Mountainline.
M-M-M-M-Mountainline. Klingt für mich wie so ein Schokoriegel.
Oder so wie beim Flippern hier, Multi-Ball, M-M-M-M-Multi-Ball.
Aber auch, wenn man es mit Momo vorne sagt.
Also wenn ich versuche mich bei iCloud anzumelden, dann sagt er, sie können sich momentan nicht anmelden, versuchen sie die Signierung erneut, was auch immer das dann bedeutet.
Aber das ist doch Beta-Version.
Auf jeden Fall sollst du halt auch defaultmäßig jetzt alles in die Cloud speichern, wenn du Applesafe drückst hier. Oder machst du ja auch nicht mehr. Wird ja alles automatisch einfach alles auf die Cloud geschoben.
Na gut, sagen wir doch vielleicht ein bisschen technischer. Also was wir jetzt diesem Open-Safe-Dialog untergeschoben haben, ist die iCloud, beziehungsweise den Dokumententeil davon. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt deine Documents da auch ablegen und dann sind sie da wahrscheinlich wieder schön brav sortiert nach Programmen. Und wenn du mal irgendwie mit deinem Dokument mit zwei verschiedenen Programmen arbeiten willst, dann stehst du schon wieder da und verstehst die Welt nicht.
Was bist du denn für ein Power-User?
Ja, echt mal.
So eine Probleme gibt es da?
Du hast noch nie ein Dokument mit zwei Programmen bearbeitet?
Mit VI unten die EMAX?
Es gibt eine neue Version von VI, die kann auch EMAX-Dateien lesen.
Also echt, aber das Programm zur Ordnungsgeschichte, was du gerade beschrieben hast, das ist jetzt schon so oder wo kommt das her, diese Anekdote?
Na ich habe jetzt mit Mountain Lion noch nicht gearbeitet. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwas anderes ist, aber bisher war das ja immer so, dass du da so deine eigene Dokumenten-Sandbox hast.
Ich habe halt iCloud bisher ausgesessen, deswegen...
Ja, na ich partiell ja.
Ja, da gibt es nicht viel zu sitzen.
Ja bisher macht es ja eigentlich nur Sinn mit dem iPad und mit dem iPad kann ich nicht arbeiten. Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber...
Ich spiele damit hauptsächlich, ja.
Ich akzeptiere, dass Leute damit arbeiten. Max, hast du mal ein iPad auf dem Schoß?
Ich mag mal ein iPad.
Hast du da auch schon mal Dokumente abgespeichert?
Selbstverständlich.
Was für welche?
Also Texte zum Beispiel. Oder Bücher.
Über Dropbox gesynkt.
Ja, Texte per Dropbox und so Artikel schreiben.
Und auch mit iCloud?
Mit iCloud habe ich glaube ich exakt noch... Es gibt nichts, was man mit iCloud von dir nutzen kann im Augenblick.
Ich habe mit Numbers schon Tabellen gemacht auf dem iPad, die ich mir hinterher auf dem iPhone angeguckt habe. Aber da muss man schon sehr viel, wie soll ich sagen, Willen mitbringen.
Kann man doch bei Google machen.
Aber ich meine, es funktioniert noch nicht auf Mac. Das ist halt das, was geben muss. Also ich meine, wenn das ginge, wär's toll.
Na, ich befürchte, das kommt halt jetzt.
Ich hoffe, dass es kommt.
Mir wird langsam schwummerig bei diesen OS-Releases. Es wird einfach nur schlimmer.
Wie ist denn das eigentlich bei iCloud? Kriegt man da so unlimited space oder muss man dann ab irgendwas bezahlen?
Wenn du unlimited money draufwürfst, ja.
Warte mal, 5 GB sind dabei?
Fünf.
Fünf und dann kostet irgendwie Upgrade auf?
Ja, es kommt so speicher an.
Das ist doch der Trick von Apple. Die sorgen dafür, dass alle möglichen Apps immer mehr iCloud benutzen oder sogar benutzen müssen, wie auch immer, damit die Leute halt iCloud benutzen, damit die Leute irgendwann Storage nachkaufen. Also es geht doch darum, den Leuten das Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen und zwar direkt zu Apple.
Das heißt, echt? Dafür ist der Storage aber zu billig. Also 10 Gigabyte kosten 16 Euro im Jahr.
Ja, das ist nix, aber das kann man ja auch dann anpassen. Aber erst müssen die Leute ja alle dahin ziehen. Und vor allem, wenn du deine Daten erstmal da hast, bist du ja auch am Arsch. Also ich meine...
Denk mal drüber nach.
Genau. Du bist ja nicht mehr Herr deiner Daten. Ändern die irgendwas und du kommst da nicht mehr ran.
Oder dann schlägt der Blitz im Data Center ein, wie bei Amazon.
Ja oder du twitterst irgendwas über Wikileaks und zack, bist du raus aus dem Geschäft. Zum Beispiel.
Also jenseits der ganzen Paranoia seh ich das Problem einfach in der schweren Benutzbarkeit.
Also ich...
Also die sind... Ja man ist da, die haben nicht mehr Herr seiner Daten. Nicht mehr so komplett.
Aber diesen neuen öffnen, sicheren Dialog, ich glaub das halte ich auch nicht für eine gute Idee. Muss ich sagen.
Könntest du das mal hier kurz demonstrieren? Achso du hast ja jetzt iCloud, durftest ja nicht signieren.
Nee, da hat er mir ja jetzt nicht gegönnt.
Hier leben so...
Vielleicht passiert trotzdem irgendwas.
Wir arbeiten hier am zuckenden Leib.
Ich mach hier mal so einen Screenshot. Ich hab hier so einen Screenshot, das sieht dann ungefähr so aus. So wie so auf so einem iPad mit so diesem Line-Hintergrund und ja.
Naja, was auch noch dazukommt bei iCloud und MountainLine ist, dass du dann quasi deinen Mac auch aus der iCloud so heraus neu aufsetzen kannst. Also dass du verschiedenste Dinge, die da bisher so nicht waren, also deine ganzen Settings gleich bei der Installation aktivieren kannst. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wann dieses Fensterchen, was sie hier auf ihrer Webseite haben, kommt, ob das so während der Installation.
Was ist passiert, als du es da ausgefüllt hast?
Dann bootstrappt er dann halt irgendwie dein ganzes Kram auf der Installation. Ich mein, das macht alles total Sinn für so the average User.
Aber wir wollen Power Mac OS.
Ja, ich auch.
Mac OS X Pro wollen wir.
Genau, das ist ein guter Punkt. Ich will OS X Pro. Genau so, wie ich schon immer iTunes Pro haben wollte. Überhaupt hätte ich gerne mal alles in Pro.
Mit VI und Emacs.
Das funktioniert bei Business Edition. Funktioniert bei Windows ja so hervorragend mit diesen ganzen Pro Versionen.
Ich bin echt, mich macht das wirklich fertig. Also es ist echt nicht fein.
Ist ja auch schon so beim neuen Xcode, das 4-4er ist ja dabei. Wenn du das nutzt, dann gibt es keine Command Line Tools mehr.
Den musst du extra installieren, aber das ist schon bei 4.3 so.
Bei dem neuen da.
Was gab es denn vorher für Command Line Tools?
Ja, aber der Vorteil ist, du kannst die jetzt installieren, ohne Xcode zu installieren.
Das kannst du tun, allerdings brauchst du trotzdem den Account, den Entwickler-Account, den musst du ja vorher machen. Also es ist nicht so, dass du irgendwo das einfach runterlädst, sondern du brauchst vorher den Entwickler-Account. Du kannst aber einen Umsonst-Entwickler-Account dazu nutzen, so weit ich weiß.
Ich dachte, man könnte sich einfach Xcode im App-Store runterladen.
Ja, kann man, aber es ist natürlich ein fettes Paket.
Und Homebrew, da musst du dein Entwickler-Passwort eingeben und so?
Nein, du kannst die Xcode einfach aus dem Store installieren und dann hast du bei Xcode irgendwie so ein Menü.
In Preferences und da ist ja der Downloads-Abteilung für die Boku auch.
Und da kann man sich auch die Command Line Tools installieren.
Open Developer Tool, More Developer Tools.
Also kannst du die jetzt halt auf der Homebrew installieren.
Ja genau, und da jetzt unter Outroads.
Du musst ja alle externen Tools jetzt nachinstallieren.
Geh mal auf den anderen Bildschirm.
Components, ah.
Und da kannst du Command Line Tools, dann drückst du auf Install und installiert Dosh.
Na dann.
Und weil man auch die ganzen anderen wie hier Quartz Debug und OpenGL Debugging, USB und Bluetooth Debugging und Metzgiffen wird alles nicht mehr installiert und wenn man das alles weglässt, ich glaub ich hab 10 GB mehr Platz jetzt auf meiner Platte. Weil ich ne Menge halt eben, also ich hab davon nichts installiert außer die Command Line Tools.
Ja, das ist durchaus sinnvoll. Und du brauchst doch diese ganzen, ich meine, ich zum Beispiel entwickel nicht für den Mac, aber ich brauch trotzdem halt die Command Line Tools und es ist schon mal gut, wenn man das separat hat.
Naja, die Art und Weise, wie die Tools zusammengesetzt sind, ist ein bisschen blöd. Also wenn du zum Beispiel viel dieses Pixi benutzt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst, das ist so ein Teil, wo du einfach nur den Bildschirm zoomen kannst in einem bestimmten Bereich. Also da, wo die Maus ist, der folgt immer der Maus und zeigt dir das größer an. Wenn du das haben willst, musst du die gesamten Graphic Tools installieren.
Aber es gibt ja jetzt eben auch von diesen Installer, denen du über Homebrew dir die Xcode Command Line Tools ohne alles installieren kannst. Hat da ja hier irgendwie so erst rumgehackt und jetzt hat Apple ja gesagt, okay, helf mal dir und machen dir mal die passenden Pakete klar und jetzt kannst du dir das hier halt mit Homebrew und so installieren. Gibt es hier auch so einen Blogpost, ich pack dir mal einen Chat, wo er dann irgendwie erzählt, was da Apple zugesagt hat. Moment, Achtung, Ping.
Na, ich dachte, das wären diese Command Line Tools.
Also da muss man zwei Sachen unterscheiden. Also das aktuelle Xcode hat jetzt eben auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass man aus seinen Prefs heraus einzelne Module, die man so gezielt installieren kann. Und es wird bei Mountain Line anders.
Ne, man muss andersrum anfangen. Bei Xcode 4.3 hat Apple angefangen, Xcode nicht mehr als Installer auszuliefern, sondern als Applikation. Das heißt, wenn du die Xcode 4.3 installierst, aus dem App Store, dann bekommst du halt eine Applikation in deinem Applications-Folder und das ist Xcode. Und in diesem Xcode sind einige Sachen mit drin, unter anderem die gesamten Command-Line-Tools. Das ist ein riesen Bundle, wo alles drin liegt. Und wenn du aber die Command-Line-Tools nochmal extra an den normalen Orten, wo ein Unix das erwarten würde, haben willst, musst du dieses Zusatzpaket installieren.
Ich lese übrigens gerade, dass du wahrscheinlich doch diese Apple-ID brauchst. Also es gibt jetzt auch dieses Package bei Apple, so direkt dieses Command-Line-Tools-Package, weil halt für Homebrew und so, für deine anderen Unix-Tools, genau das war der Aufhänger, brauchst du halt sonst, musst du dir immer dieses Gigabyteweise Xcode installieren und er wollte halt nur die Command-Line-Tools und deswegen haben sie es dann gesplittet.
Naja, sie haben halt auch, dass du Xcode ganz normal über den App Store installieren kannst, als eine Applikation, deswegen schmeißt er nicht mehr sonst wohin Sachen auf die Platte.
Vorher kam der Installer aus dem App Store, da musstest du noch mal starten und jetzt kommt direkt die App aus dem App Store.
Genau, da hast du den Applikations, hast du den Install Xcode-Applikation, die hast du dann angeworfen und dann hat er Xcode installiert und dann hättest du theoretisch hinterher diese Applikation wieder wegschmeißen können. Aber das hat er nicht von alleine gemacht.
Ja, sie fegen sich da auf jeden Fall selber hinterher. Das ist ja auch alles sehr zu begrüßen. Aber ich denke, wir werden auch auf diese ganze Developer-ID und wie das jetzt so ist, dann nochmal mit Gatekeeper drauf kommen. Bleiben wir doch mal hier in der von Apple vorgegebenen Diskussionsrunde Reihenfolge.
Einhellige Expertenmeinung.
Das ist noch ein bisschen wirr, weil irgendwie ist es noch nicht so klar, wenn du mit einem chattest irgendwie, also ich zum Beispiel chatte mit Huckel. Huckel chatte mit seinem Laptop. Ich auch. Und da war aber unsere, ja wie sagt man, Accounts benutzen, die auch auf dem iPhone funktionieren. Vibriert parallel auch immer mein iPhone und das Display geht an, das heißt, wenn ich so eine halbe Stunde mit Huckel chatte, ist danach mein iPhone leer, obwohl es irgendwie gar nicht benutzt wurde. Weil es immer mit vibriert, weil es die Nachrichten ja auch kriegt und immer meldet. Das ist noch ein bisschen blöd. Da müsste man sich mal was einfallen lassen, dass er erkennen, wenn ich an meinem Rechner sitze und hier antworte, dass du von mir aus, die aus iPhone, sünken, aber dass es nicht halt immer vibriert und das Display angeht, sondern dass du es ganz silent irgendwie mit aufnimmst.
Also das ist generell noch etwas verwirrend, weil du hast jetzt mehrere IDs, über die das Ganze halt alles laufen kann. Und zwar deine Apple-ID, dann hast du vorher irgendwie über Java kommuniziert und machst das vielleicht auch immer noch.
Das geht ja dann aber auch nicht über...
Was?
Geht ja dann nicht aufs Phone.
Aber es geht auch über deine...
Ja, aber...
Das Java ist noch das alte iChat, das hat mit dem neuen iMessages sozusagen ja nichts zu tun.
Also die Messages-Applikation sieht erst mal so aus wie die iChat. Also sieht nicht so aus, aber das ist erst mal die iChat-Applikation und sämtliche Accounts, die du vorher in iChat hattest, hast du dann auch in Messages. Aber zusätzlich dazu hast du halt diese iMessage-Funktionalität auch mit drin.
Ja, sobald hab ich das schon verstanden.
Der Punkt ist nur, du hast ja auch über deine... Ich weiß ja, unter Mountain Lion geht jetzt Facetime nicht mehr.
Jetzt nicht vom Thema abkommen. Deine Apple-ID, früher hieß das ja mal at mac.com, dann hieß es at me.com, jetzt ist es wahrscheinlich alles at icloud.com.
Nee, sie sind bei me.com geblieben, so was ich weiß. Aber egal.
Werden sie es schon auch noch irgendwie ändern, wenn die Leute ausreichend verwirrt sind, was das mit diesem me jetzt noch soll, weil sie das nie gesehen haben und so. Ja, und die Umstellung zwischen mac und me war schon nicht so ganz unproblematisch. Darüber kannst du aber auch Java machen.
Das kommt ja aber alles auf dem iPhone nicht an. Das ist erstmal alles nur auf iChat eigenständig.
Jaja, natürlich kommt das nicht auf dem iPhone an. Ich sag nur, diese ID ist aber jetzt auch etwas, über das du iMessage machen kannst. Es handelt sich da aber um dieselbe Adresse sozusagen, deine Apple ID, über die du dann halt auch deinen iMessage brokers, mit dem du dann aber auch deinen Facetime machst. Und dann hast du auf deinem Telefon das dann aber auch, aber eben auch mit der Telefonnummer. Und irgendwann, also ich blicke jetzt schon nicht mehr so richtig durch, wann ich wo, was, wie, unter welcher ID, mit welchem Protokoll empfange.
Auf dem iPhone kommt eigentlich nur, also über deine Nummer kannst du halt iMessages benutzen, auf dem iPhone und über die Apple ID. Aber nicht über diese ganzen anderen Accounts, die du aufgelistet hast.
Angeblich kannst du bei iMessage auch.
Aber auf Mac sehr wohl. Ja. Aber du musst dann auch erstmal wissen, mit wem du da jetzt auch gerade redest. Und wenn du dann in diesem iMessage dann jetzt irgendwie mal aufmachst, guck mal, wenn ich hier dich hier anklicke...
Keine Namen jetzt, sonst hab ich da alles voll.
Zwei Telefonnummern sind hier eingetragen, über die ich dich angeblich über iMessage erreichen kann. Anschließend einer Festnetz-Nummer.
Zwei.
Zeigt er mir so an. Da bist du zwar grad nicht online, aber er ist der Meinung, du müsst ja auch anbegehen.
Ja, die kommt aus meinem Adressbuch, ne?
Ja, natürlich kommt die aus meinem Adressbuch. Das kommt alles aus meinem Adressbuch. So, und natürlich auch noch dein Jobber-Account. Aber es könnte halt auch sein, dass ich auch dich schon mal über die Apple-ID per Jobber angesprochen habe. Also in deinem Fall jetzt grad mal nicht, aber das wäre halt durchaus denkbar. Ich hab jetzt bei manchen Leuten da wirklich zehn verschiedene Optionen, wie ich irgendjemand ansprechen kann. Und...
Ja, da müssen die noch mal ein bisschen aufräumen. Da sollten die so Symbole hinmachen. Das hier, das ist vom Phone. Das hier ist auf seinem Rechner. Und das hier ist irgendwie sonst wo.
Ja, und dann ist Facetime halt auch nochmal drin hier über dieses Kamera-Icon.
Ja, das wird ja wahrscheinlich noch fest mit reingehen.
Aber was macht er denn dann, wenn ich das jetzt mache? Startet er dann Facetime oder macht er das jetzt auch in Messages?
Wahrscheinlich wird er mal auf Facetime starten, oder?
Und klingelt dann auch wieder mein Desktop und mein Telefon gleichzeitig?
Ich kann dich ja mal an Facetime. Jetzt startet er Facetime, genau.
Also... Tja.
Das wird schon noch alles ganz schön kompliziert werden.
Was ich viel spannender finde, ist, wenn ich Messages hier aufmache, dann steht da oben neue E-Mail.
Das ist sozusagen die deutsche Übersetzung von New Message dann.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist auch super. Das heißt, nicht nur iMessage und Java und alle anderen Protokolle werden jetzt irgendwie eins.
Apples Google Wave.
Sondern über die Übersetzung wird es dann auch noch E-Mail und dann weißt du irgendwann überhaupt nicht mehr, was du überträgst.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Übersetzungsfehler.
Ja, das ist definitiv ein Übersetzungsfehler, aber der wird wahrscheinlich dann auch bleiben. Oh man, das kannst du keinem mehr erklären. Also spätestens, wenn du es selber nicht mehr verstehst, ist es nicht mehr vermittelbar.
Müssen wir uns den aufräumen. Was ich auch gemerkt habe, zum Beispiel, dass hier, also ich hab ja meine ganzen, ich hab ja kein iChat benutzt, ich hab das alles in Ardium und irgendwie scheint das iMessages nicht richtig mitzukriegen.
Messages.
Jedenfalls ist das alles nicht ordentlich gesyncht und ich musste erstmal dem Huckel irgendwie ordentlich seinen Namen eintragen, damit das dann irgendwie im Adressbuch gefunden wird. Oder bei Ardium musste, genau, ich musste von Huckel seinen richtigen Namen in Ardium eintragen unter seinem Account, damit es dann ordentlich im Telefonbuch landet, damit das dann bei iMessage wieder ankommt, sonst kann er das nicht irgendwie ordentlich matchen und findet die Leute nicht.
Das hättest du, glaube ich, auch direkt im Adressbuch tun können. Das hättest du jetzt nicht durch Ardium durchgehen können.
Nee, du bist ja schon im Adressbuch, da warst du ja schon. Aber der hat halt sozusagen deine Ardiumadressen alle nicht ordentlich zugewiesen im Adressbuch.
Ich klick mir mal, guck schon mal, wie das bei Microsoft jetzt eigentlich so ist mit dieser Business Edition und so, dass man da auch schon mal einen Überblick hat.
Also solange sie nicht anfangen, einem auch noch Twitter-Messages in Messages zu geben, finde ich, geht das alles noch. Aber du hast recht, es hat ein gewisses Potenzial für Verwirrungen.
Ja, also mit ihrem I-Chat, Facetime, Messages, wird noch alles nicht da.
Entschuldigt mal bitte, haben wir nicht hier vor ungefähr, ich weiß nicht, wann gesessen, vor nicht allzu langer Zeit und über diese Problematik diskutiert und ihr wart euch alle einig, dass es in I-Chat reingehört? Ja, jetzt haben wir es eingebaut.
Aber sie haben, ich hab nicht gesagt, sie sollen es so einbauen, dass man keine Ahnung mehr hat, wem man wann, wie was wo schicken kann. Sondern das baut man so ein, dass man, dass es klar ist.
Ich muss mir mal kurz hier den Pullover ausziehen.
Ich finde das super.
Das ist eine hitzige Debatte hier, ich sehe das schon kommen.
Ich will vorbereitet sein.
Was habt ihr denn alle gegen einen? Ich finde das echt gut.
Das ist ja auch gut.
Ja, nur lass es mal.
Ich hab nur gesagt, ich hab jetzt schon mehrfach den Effekt gehabt, dass ich dann halt jemanden eine Nachricht geschickt hab, um dann festzustellen, dass das eben nicht wie sonst dann auf dem Computer rauskam, sondern halt nur auf dem Telefon. Weil ich halt rein zufällig, ohne dass er mir das ja anzeigt, weil das ja alles verborgen ist unter einem Namen, hab ich es halt gerade an das iMessage mit der Telefonnummer.
Aber das steht doch immer da, wo man es hinschickt, bevor man es hinschickt.
Bevor man es hinschickt.
Also erst mal steht hier ganz deutlich, wer per iMessage erreichbar ist, nämlich an diesem kleinen Dingel da. Und dann steht hier unten entweder iMessage drinnen, wenn ich jetzt hier über iMessage erreiche, wenn ich jetzt hier sage...
Das ist ja nicht das Problem, sondern von den sechs da oben. Welcher von denen würde jetzt auch auf dem Telefon landen?
Na der hier, der mit der kleinen Sprechblase, der mit dem iMessage reichen.
Das ist der, von wo er dich irgendwann mal angechattet hat.
Das ist unübersichtlich. Da sehe ich doch sofort, hallo, das ist die Telefone mal von dem.
Naja, ich denke, das wird irgendwann, wird Tim dann mal zu den Entwicklern gehen und sagen, Entschuldigung, ich hab da mal so eine kleine Frage.
Und dann kündigen die.
Genau. Steve hätte gesagt, und tschüss.
Steve hat es auch nicht gemerkt, als sie sich hier mit Facetime und iChat schon da so irgendwie auf komische Pfade begeben haben.
Aber ist ja auch noch alles beta.
Was ist an einem Messages schlimm?
Dass es unübersichtlich ist.
Es ist überhaupt nicht unübersichtlich.
Das eigentliche, was an Messages schlimm ist, ist das gleiche, was bei Ardium auch schlimm ist. Es gibt einfach zu viele Standards für Chatten. Und die meisten sind scheiße. Und es gibt aber so viele Leute, die irgendwie immer noch auf scheiß Standards sitzen, statt alle irgendwie Japper zu machen.
Wie benutzt du nicht Facebook-Messages?
Weil ich glaube, ich hab mit Huckel gechattet. Und weil er mich anders anchattet, als ich ihn, weil das auch nicht in Sönkes, haben wir zwei Verschiebungen. Und ich glaube, das ist auch nicht so, dass ich verschiedene Chats, das heißt, ich chat ihm was, und seine Antwort kommt bei mir in einem anderen Chat-Fenster auf dem iPhone. Weil er nicht weiß, dass die zusammengehören.
Zum Kongress sehen wir die erste Chat-Problem.
Das ist alles super, aber noch nicht so in Sönk. Da müssen wir einfach ein bisschen aufräumen, und dann ist alles super.
Er bietet mir vor allem jede eingetragene E-Mail-Adresse als iMessage-Adresse an. Jede. Ich hab von dir irgendwie so eine Herrscher von E-Mail-Adressen, und überall steht iMessage dahinter. Das ist aber keine iMessage. Das ist eine E-Mail-Adresse. Und es ist überhaupt nicht gesagt, dass dahinter in irgendeiner Form ein Gerät ist, was da jetzt was mit anfangen kann. Okay, da ist jetzt keine blaue Sprechblase dabei. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall mindestens verwirrend. Mindestens ist es verwirrend.
Also bisher die Grundlage, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, ist halt die Telefonnummer von sie weiß, das funktioniert immer. Und halt die Apple-ID, die man bei Apple einträgt.
Aber es ist auch jede Telefonnummer, wird auch angezeigt.
Diese Data-Software ist nicht perfekt. Das hätte Apple mal dazu sagen sollen beim Download.
Ich befürchte, das wird so bleiben.
Wieso soll das so bleiben?
Weil es bei den anderen auch so geblieben ist. Also bei Facetime hat sich auch nichts mehr getan.
Also ich meine, du musst natürlich zugeben, iChat ist auch so ein bisschen glacial, was die Entwicklung anbelangt. Ich meine, das hat doch mindestens vier Versionen gebraucht. Bis sie erkannt haben, dass es schlau ist, alle Kontakte in einem Fenster zu haben. Also irgendwie, ich hab irgendwie drei Kreuze gemacht, als ich nicht mehr sechs verschiedene Kontaktfenster auf dem Desktop hatte, die noch dazu, sich iChat immer nicht gemerkt hat, wo die sind, wenn du irgendwie den externen Monitor abgestöpselt hast.
Also ja, das ist wahrscheinlich deswegen, weil das niemand benutzt hat, weil sowieso alle die N-Te geklickt haben.
Oh nee, jetzt nicht Adium. Ja klar.
Immer?
Also ich benutze Messages.
Na jetzt, aber vorher? Also nee, ich hab immer noch die N-Te, weil...
Ich hab das bestimmt schon... Adium ist bei mir wirklich...
Nicht diskutieren, wetten.
Also hat echt nichts gebracht.
Doch.
Ich benutze auch Adium immer noch. Vor allen Dingen wegen OTR.
Zum Beispiel. Ob bei iChat einfach irgendwie zu schlecht war.
Na gut, wir begraben mal das Thema und gehen mal zum nächsten Thema über.
Zum nächsten Tiefpunkt.
Apple, genau, was ist der nächste Tiefpunkt hier?
Apples Katzen gehen den Berg hoch, wir gehen ihn runter.
Ich glaube, das müssen wir nicht lange diskutieren hier. Es gibt jetzt auch diese Reminders. Was ich ja ganz gut finde daran, ist, dass sie generell To-Do und Kalender mal auseinandergefallen waren.
Und aus dem E-Mail-Programm auch raus. Da gab es auch die To-Do's dann.
Und die Notes, ja.
Das ist eine sehr gute Maßnahme.
Das ist auch, sagen wir mal, schön einfach.
Es hat auch vor allem die IMAP-Folder zersaut, diese scheiß To-Do- und Notes-Geschichte in Apple-Mail. Da habe ich jedes Mal einen Hussie gekriegt.
Ja, das ist grauenhaft. Oh, über IMAP-Folder müssen wir sowieso nochmal reden.
Wir kratzen ja alle aus den Ecken raus.
Na ja gut, zumindest bietet Apple damit jetzt das erste Mal oder wird es dann anbieten, eine To-Do-Anwendung, die eben theoretisch über alles Sünd. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie schnell das dann mal wieder geht und vor allem wie zuverlässig das...
Sie ist positiv.
Sie geben dir Stoff für die nächsten 80 Sendungen, wo du dich über das schlechte Syncing in zuerst Reminders aufreden kannst, dann im Kalender, dann in Mehl, dann... Der Reihe nach kannst du jedes Syncing-Protokoll zerlegen.
Ich würde auch ganz gerne mal wieder so einen Praise einschieben. Hätte ich auch mal wieder Bock drauf, aber ist gerade nicht so viel zu holen.
Woran? Hier an diesem Mountainline.
Mountainline? Naja, wahrscheinlich wird sich nichts verbessern gegenüber Lines. Also nicht da, wo es wirklich schmerzt. Das ist so meine Befürchtung. Aber ist egal. Ich hab ja eben auch gesagt, das ist gut. Ich finde es gut, dass sie jetzt endlich im Jahre 2012 To-Do-Apps eingeführt haben und dass es von vornherein synkt. Ich gucke mir das dann mal an, wie das dann funktioniert.
Also das Einzige, was mich an der Reminders-Applikation stört, ist, dass sie genauso scheiße aussieht, auf dem iPhone und auf dem iPad. Aber ansonsten, ich meine, es war auch zu erwarten, dass sie genauso aussieht.
Wahrscheinlich kann man mit diesem Kalender da unten nicht ordentlich durchscrollen. Aber da red ich jetzt gar nicht mal von.
Notes, Notes, Notes, Notes.
Du drückst auf den Pfeil und hast es.
Wie soll man Tim jetzt jemals wieder einfangen?
Notes.
Sieht auch genauso aus wie auf dem...
Ah, mach mal iCal auf. Hast du iCal schon aufgemacht?
Das heißt nicht mehr iCal, das heißt jetzt Kalender.
Ah ja, mach mal Kalender auf.
Das finde ich übrigens gut, dass sie diese ganzen iScheiß jetzt mal einstanzen. Die Programme heißen jetzt mal so wie das, was da auch wirklich drin ist.
Du meinst, das neue iTunes, was demnächst rauskommt, heißt einfach Music.
Music and iPad phone backup and Movie, Sound und Audio.
Okay, Kalender sieht immer noch aus wie Kalender.
Ja, klar ist der aus wie Kalender.
Na, er ist ein bisschen weniger schlimm. Sie haben jetzt irgendwie dieses komische Stitching da rausgenommen. Allerdings haben sie immer noch diese Kalender- abrisskanten Scheiß-Simulation da immer noch mit drin gelassen und du kannst natürlich immer noch nicht ordentlich scrollen. In der Wochenansicht haben sie glaube ich ein bisschen was.
Das geht sogar bei das Fenster hinaus, habe ich das gerade richtig gesehen.
Die sind doch total...
Die geht schon allein, aber es ist die gleiche Animation wie bei Line.
Na, ich habe sie noch nie offen wahrscheinlich.
Du kannst jetzt tatsächlich horizontal scrollen in der Woche. Was natürlich wieder...
Hast du nicht zugehört, Mann? Außerdem, wenn du genau hinguckst, dann geht das immer nur eine ganze Woche. Es scrollt zwar smooth, aber er scrollt nur eine ganze Woche.
Ja, aber eine Woche ist super.
Der Sonntag bleibt rechts.
Ja, eine Woche ist super.
Der Montag bleibt links, das war jetzt nicht politisch.
Es ist keine Verbesserung, die ein Jahr Entwicklungsarbeit rechtfertigen würde.
Ja, die haben sie wahrscheinlich auch nicht reingesteckt an der Stelle.
Da ist alles, was auch immer sie reingesteckt haben, das ist das, was bei rausgekommen ist.
Also, wenn sie das getan hätten, dann hätte es recht.
Den Faden aufzutrennen hat bestimmt eine Weile gedauert da oben.
Ja, es ist ein Trauerspiel. Also, ich hab da kein Verständnis.
Das ist sehr bunt.
Es ist wirklich furchtbar.
Machst du gerade das erste Mal iCall auf?
Nee, zumindest das erste Mal die Jahresansicht.
Ja gut, Notes, Kalender jetzt.
Applaus.
Heatmap ist weg oder ist optional. Gut, kommen wir zum nächsten.
Meilenstein der Betriebssystemtechnologie.
Es wird ein Notification Center geben. Hurra.
Der ganze Bildschirm scrollt nach links und rechts geht so eine Spalte auf, wo Notifications drin wären, wenn wir hier drin wären.
Mach doch mal mich hier rein. Soll ich dir meine Mail schreiben?
Ich hab hier, glaube ich, Mail nicht konfiguriert.
Er konnte sich ja nicht in der iCloud anmelden.
Aber du kannst mir eine Nachricht per Bonjour Chat schicken.
Das muss ich erst mal einschalten.
Wie funktioniert denn das? Was ist denn da rechts oben für ein Notification Center?
Der runde Böppel. Wenn man da drauf drückt, kriegt man hier die...
Ein runder Böppel, das heißt das Suchen, was immer ganz außen war, das ist jetzt sozusagen ein nach links gerutscht.
Ja, alles ist nicht mehr First Class Citizen.
Das heißt, du kannst mit der Maus jetzt nicht einfach oben rechts in die Ecke ballern und einfach blind drücken, sondern...
Du klickst mit der Maus auf das Spotlight-Icon?
Natürlich nicht, aber die anfängt ja schon. Diese Hot Corner User, ich bin ja da auch getrennt von.
Was ist da der passende Keyboard-Shortcut für die Benachrichtigung?
Dafür musst du den richtigen Mac kaufen mit dem richtigen Funktionstasten.
Ich glaub, das ist irgendeine Geste.
Funktionstasten, da können wir auf jeden Fall noch mal eine richtig viel Zeit verspenden auf dem Thema. Das ist auch wirklich schlimm.
Ohne!
Es hat noch keinen in der Mitte.
Achso, warum auch? Wahrscheinlich kann man da...
Mach mal, Abfüll Spaces weiter in den Spotlight.
Es geht eh von der Reine auf.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich eine Geste dafür, wahrscheinlich mit sechs Fingern irgendwie so im Kreis drehen.
Oder sowas. Pentagramm malen.
Hey, Notification, sieht doch gut aus.
Spotlight ist nachher vor Jahr.
Außer dass... Oh, die sie ignoriert, aber...
Schreib mehr, schreib mehr.
Die schiebt sich so rein und schiebt sich so aus.
Schreib halt nochmal Map.
Bist du Administrator?
Sieht auf Anhieb deutlich besser aus als Growl. Aber ist ja auch nicht weiter schwer, muss man ja auch sagen.
Wie, sieht besser aus als Growl? Sieht genauso aus wie Growl.
Die Animation kommt vernünftig reingefallen, so von unten und fährt so zur Seite raus in das Notification Center rein.
Schon ganz gut. Aber warum blinkt das da so?
Weil die ganze Zeit neue Nachrichten kommen.
Und vor allen Dingen, warum kriege ich den ganzen Scheiß auch aufs iPhone?
Sag ich ja.
Das ist das, was voll blöd ist.
In der Chat ist nur eine halbe Stunde, ist der Telefon leer.
Du kriegst jetzt die Bonjour-Nachrichten auf deinem mobilen Angelehrte.
Nee, das ist ein Message. Ich hab ja ihn über ein Message.
Nee, aber... An die Telefonnummer.
Nee, ich hab ihn an seine iMessage-Adresse, die ich da gesehen habe, in dem Fenster.
Ach so, ich hab's aber über Bonjour.
Ja, das ist die hier.
Die E-Mail-Adresse sozusagen.
Ah, okay, aber meine Bonjour-Nachrichten kommen nicht an, sehr schön.
mi.com. Ja, das ist... Das ist... Also, das wird alle Leute, glaube ich, unglaublich zur Raserei bringen.
Nee, die werden da demnächst irgendwie, glaube ich, Device-Symbolen rankleben, damit man weiß, wo man was, wen, wie erreicht. Vielleicht kann man sich dann sogar aussuchen, ja, das soll nur auf ein Device kommen und auf ein Telefon nicht, weil ich will ja nicht stören oder irgendwie so.
Ich hätte gern Notificationsyncing, wenn ich die eine Notification zur Kenntnis nehme, dann muss die auch auf allen anderen.
Zur Kenntnis genommen sein.
Ja, das ist auch genauso wie mit diesem, du trägst einen Alarm ein für einen Kalender-Item. Und dann macht's auf allen deinen Computern, kommt dann auch wie Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing, Bing.
Du machst auf einmal aus und auf den anderen klingelt's weiter.
Überall muss er irgendwie das Mist machen.
Ist geil bei uns in der Firma, im Büro. Da sind ja immer so Meetings so für das ganze Team und so. Und dann alle haben jetzt seit Weihnachten IOS-Geräte, ne, und ein Mac und so weiter. Und dann, wenn ein Meeting anschließt, zehn Minuten vorher einmal so eine Welle durchs ganze Office, weil die alle noch so in so einer Millisekunde off sind. Sieht so an einem vorüber.
Das ist doch wie bei irgendeinem Film, wo die so ein Security-Meeting haben von dem Präsident oder was auch immer und auf einmal alle, die da so, keine Ahnung, 50 Leute, die da so sind, fängt überall der Beeper an zu beepen, weil irgendwie so eine Katastrophe reinkommt und alle so, und klingelt überall gleichzeitig. Das ist dann genau so was. Nur, dass bei Apple natürlich ein SYNC ist.
Ich werd noch den Tag bereuen, wo ich nach Syncing überall geschrien habe.
Ja, da wird man ja kreuzigen. Du hast nicht dazu gesagt, dass du Syncing überall inordentlich haben möchtest.
Doch, ich glaube, das hat er.
Wobei das überall piept, das ist ja gut. Woher soll das Ding denn wissen, an welchem Gerät man gerade sitzt? Umarmst du deinen IMAC bei der Arbeit? Achso, dann sollst du mich die ganze Zeit überwachen, ob ich jetzt gerade mit den Augen auf den Bildschirm schaue. Das wird bestimmt überhaupt keinen Shitstorm geben.
Also es sind auf jeden Fall alles riskante Änderungen.
Was ich ja geil fände wäre, wenn sie so einen Strip-Down-Mac OS anbieten würden. So wie die Developer-Version von diesem ZFS-Ding, wo du halt wirklich nur baremichelst. Und dann kannst du als Pro-User dir auch wirklich nur die Features anklicken, die du haben willst.
OS X Pro.
OS X Pro. Alles so in diesem schwarzen, auch alles ein bisschen.
So, dann gibt es wieder so einen User-Interface-Klimb hier mit Share Sheets. Das finde ich ja jetzt erstmal keinen Fehler, weil das war schon alles überhaupt nicht mehr zu finden. Also sie haben ja überall so in ihrer App so ein Share-Menü-Item reingebaut. Und auf dem iPhone ist es halt überall dieser komische Pfeil, der aus dem Kasten rausguckt. Und den haben sie jetzt irgendwie hier auch eingebaut. Das ist ja soweit ganz okay. Nur die Politik, was da jetzt drin erscheinen darf, erscheint mir jetzt wieder etwas schwammig zu sein. Es geht ja die Aussage, dass sie jetzt für ihren Video-Export tatsächlich YouTube rausgeschmissen haben.
Und da nur Vimeo dran ist, ne? Ja, du hast dich bei nichts angemeldet, darum hast du auch No Service.
Ach so, stimmt.
Wie schaffst du das eigentlich im Betriebssystem?
Du bist gedetost.
Ich hab das nur schnell installiert. Einmessert schaffst du doch. Ich hab's nicht im Betrieb genommen.
Du kannst keinen PDF übereinmessert.
Das ist hier auf der externen Platte, weil ich's einfach mal sehen wollte. Ich bin nicht darauf umgezogen, Alter.
Alter! Disziplin.
Aber so ein Mehlklein, Richard.
Was haltet ihr von diesem kleinen Knopf? Aber wer sagt jetzt, was da drin ist? Nur das Programm selbst. Also das ist nicht so, dass es jetzt irgendwie so Plugins gibt zu aller Services, wo man sich überall einklinken kann oder so?
Hab nichts in der entsprechenden Developer-Doku gesehen, dass man da irgendwas verbauen könnte. Aber es kann auch sein, dass ich nicht an der richtigen Stelle geguckt hab. Dass es mir nicht aufgefallen ist.
Vielleicht ist es ja auch einfach noch nicht fertig. Oder sie bauen es erstmal ein und machen es dann in der nächsten Version vollwertig. Kennt man noch von Apple.
Als ich das erste Mal das Wort Share Sheets gelesen hatte und mir dachte so, oh, ein OS X Konzept, um irgendwie Sharing zu ermöglichen. Ja, so für so einen Moment das Gefühl, dass sie sich ja vielleicht irgendwas Tolles haben einfallen lassen. Aber mehr als jetzt so ein Knopfmenü ist es ja eigentlich nicht, oder? Steckt da jetzt noch irgendein Voodoo dahinter, den ich nicht verstanden hab?
Es gibt noch diese Twitter-Cheats dazu. Diese kleinen, diese Aussehen wie unter. Mach mal so einen Twitter-Cheat auf.
Ja, Roddy ist ja hier schon am Einsignen in alles, was nicht bei Drei auf der Bäume ist.
Sehr gut.
Ein Twitter-Cheat?
Ja, so ein Tweet-Cheat, dass du was twitteren kannst.
Jetzt müsste ich doch hier...
Naja, das PDF kannst du wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht twitteren.
Warum denn nicht?
Guck mal, er compressed es schon auf 140 Zeichen.
Mach doch mal was in Safari.
Ja, machen wir mal in Safari noch mal.
Die Google-Leiste in Safari ist ja auch verschwunden, ne?
Ja, das ist jetzt nur noch eine.
Ah, das ist gut. Das hab ich gewollt.
Dafür ist aber auch die Suchhistory verschwunden, ne?
Eines dieser Features, was es in Chrome schon ewig gab, aber was?
Scheint auch nur so mittel zu gehen.
Vielleicht muss ich wahrscheinlich noch mal neu starten oder so ein Scheiß.
Nee, das geht wahrscheinlich auch über die iCloud und hat er ja nicht, deswegen. Ja, aber es ist wirklich so ein Safari, da ist jetzt also die Location Bar, ist gleichzeitig auch die Sucheingabe, was er dann erkennt, aber man hat dadurch keine Suchhistorie mehr. Und er lässt das HTTP vorne weg. Wenn du es nicht hinschreibst, dann zeigt er es auch wirklich nicht an. Also bisher beim Safari ist ja, wenn du du spiegel.de schreibst, dann macht er das www und das http:// vorne dran. Das macht er jetzt nicht mehr. Und alles hinter der eigentlichen Domain wird auch in so einem Dunkelgrau angezeigt, weil das ist ja gar nicht mehr wichtig, sondern nur die Hauptdomain ist wichtig. Alles danach ist ja irgendwie für den normalen User nicht so entscheidend.
Natürlich großzügig bei Chrome bedient.
Leute, ich kann so nicht arbeiten.
Du meinst der Cook ist noch viel schlimmer als der Steve.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wer jetzt hier überhaupt noch, wenn man jetzt überhaupt mit Scheiße bewerfen soll dafür.
Ich kann gar nicht so viel scheißen, wie ich werfen möchte.
Und wenn es HTTPS ist, was ist es dann?
Dann steht da HTTPS davor. Das funktioniert alles ganz hervorragend und regt dich wieder ab.
Wenn man es hinschreibt, bleibt es auch stehen, aber wenn man es nicht hinschreibt, dann nicht.
Oh mein Gott, er findet es nicht stimmt, dass ich so kein HTTPS mehr davor schreibe.
Warum soll das denn ausgegraut sein?
Weil da nur die Domain wichtig ist für die meisten Leute.
Dem würde ich ja sogar noch zustimmen. Also das ist so ein bisschen gräulich, ich finde das ja okay, als ob die das HTTPS vorne weg machen.
Es verschwierigt natürlich das Phishing auch, wenn die Domain, die eigentlich interessant ist, auch als solche dargestellt wird und irgendwie nicht plötzlich zufällig in irgendeinem Link trotzdem da noch was anderes drinsteht und eine andere Frage.
Die Frage ist halt, mach mal bitte spiegel.de und so, dass es, also so wie jetzt, da ist ja vorne fehlt das HTTPS schon, wenn du jetzt eine Kopie davon machst, fehlt dann das HTTPS dann oder macht das, wenn du ein Copy machst von der Adresse, macht das irgendwie mit? Mach mal jetzt eine Kopie von der Zeile da oben. So, Copy und dann pastest du jetzt mal irgendwo hin. Nee, aber natürlich nicht da rein, sondern irgendwie so ein Textding. Also er zeigt wirklich nur nicht an, wenn du ein Copy machst, dann ist es noch da. Ja, ich denke mal, da könnte man sich mit abgeben. Aber trotzdem, zeig mir mal die Suchhistory. Wenn es noch geht. Also mich, ich benutze die öfter mal, die Suchhistory. Und...
Wo ist die denn verlaufen oder was?
Nennt er von der Suche aber, nicht von deinen Locations, sondern von der Suche. Du suchst irgendwie was und willst dann irgendwie noch mal suchen und das Gleiche, willst nicht wieder alles eintippen. Und wie machst du das? Das geht nämlich nicht mehr, glaube ich.
Also hier gibt es doch was bei den, bei den...
Also Menü gibt es das noch, ja.
Na quasi, wo du es vorher eingegeben hast, oder? Gab es da eine so separate Searchhistory?
Na klar, hier, kannst du doch hier klicken und dann...
Achso, habe ich nie benutzt.
Doch, ich benutze ja andauernd.
Also ich finde, dieses, ich nutze ja, ich bin ja, aber ich bin ja eh schon raus, weil ich ja sowieso Chrome schon mal genutzt habe oder beziehungsweise Chrome gut finde und die haben ja auch diese eine Leiste und das ist echt super, das will man haben und wenn man sich da einmal halbwächst...
Das haben ja auch ganz viele Browser, oder?
Ja, die eine Leiste ist super, da habe ich ja auch nichts gegen.
Soll ich dir was sagen, Max? Auf meinem anderen Mac bin ich jetzt auf Chrome umgestiegen, weil es einfach gar nicht mehr geht mit Safari. Das Safari ist auf meinem alten Mac...
So, es geht ab.
Es ist unbenutzbar.
Jetzt search auf DuckDuckGo.
Das ist wirklich kaputt. Es hängt.
Gute Frage.
Die ganze Zeit muss man es killen.
Es ist langsam wie nichts.
Das ist mein Webkit, mein Nightly-Bild-Rock.
Ich hab auch das Gefühl, dass die aktuelle Safari Beta, die sie jetzt auch zum Download angeboten haben, die macht einen ganz guten Eindruck, so auf den ersten Blick.
Aber...
Wie aktuelle Safari Beta zum Download?
Na ja, diese hier...
Nightly-Bilds.
Mountain-Lion-Version für Lion. Nein, die haben doch auf diese... Das neue Safari haben die auf ihre Webseite gepackt, damit es dir runterladen kannst. Und dann installieren. Na bei apple.com.
Hier warte, da bei developerapple.com-downloads gibt's so ein Video.
Achso, das ist nur bei der developers. Ja, leider nicht für dich.
Da gibt's einen Safari 5.2-Lion. Das ist der aktuelle Safari.
Das ist der. Also das ist diese Beta-Version, die auch bei Mountain-Lion dabei sein soll.
Hm, tatsächlich. Echt cool, gleich mal installieren.
Und die macht bei mir hier einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Man kann einen Safari 52-R für Lion installieren?
Also was mich ja so ein bisschen stört an diesem kombinierten Such und URL-Bar ist, dass ich natürlich dann, was auch immer ich da eingebe, automatisch so beim Google landet.
Wieso?
Kannst du auch taktak...
Na, wenn du ein bisschen vertippst und der Meinung ist, dass wir jetzt keine richtige URL, dann macht er gleich eine Suche da draus.
Da gibt's ja übrigens...
Kann passieren.
Ja und der macht ja sogar...
Kannst du aber Bemeinstellen, wenn du Google nicht magst.
Oder Yahoo.
Du kannst natürlich sagen, es ist besser, Safari macht das, als Alice macht das.
Ja, schlimmer geht immer.
Wobei, wer weiß, wie Safari das macht. Wahrscheinlich gucken die nach, ob die Domain registriert ist. Und wenn die Domain da ist, dann lesen die sich auch brav weiter zur entsprechenden Alice-Seite. Da hab ich nämlich mal was gehört. Und zwar, es gibt nämlich so ein Mysterium, dass Chrome beim Starten erst mal drei nicht existierende Domains aufruft.
Um zu gucken, was passiert.
Um zu gucken, was passiert. Und wenn die auflöst auf einem bestimmten Server, dann wissen sie, da hat mal wieder so ein Provider so eine Scheiße hingestellt. Und lösen halt einfach auf diese IP nicht auf. Und gehen da so aus, als ob die Domain nicht existieren würde.
Also verwenden dann nicht ihren eigenen DNS Server oder so.
Ich kann ja nicht einfach in deinem DNS rumschrauben, ohne dich zu fragen.
Guck dir, ich mach doch alles mögliche, ohne mich zu fragen.
Aber jetzt mal so als...
Du gehst ja auch mal in meine Cookie-Settings, ohne mich zu fragen.
Aber jetzt mal so als kleiner Tipp vielleicht für zwischendurch, ne? Also bei Safari kann man jetzt ja nicht ne Custom-Suche einstellen, aber... Nee, kannst du nicht so richtig machen.
Du kannst doch den Suchdings umstellen.
Ja, du kannst zwischen Dreien auswählen.
Du kannst zwischen Dreien auswählen, aber du kannst nicht deinen eigenen Suchs drängen. Aber ich wollte jetzt mal DuckDuckGo ausprobieren, ne? Und dann hab ich mich gefragt, wie macht man das? Und das Coole ist, DuckDuckGo hat so ne... Für Yahoo, Google und Bing so ne kompatible API. Und dann muss man nur in seiner etc-host, in Anführungsstrich, man muss nur in seiner etc-host, ja, sozusagen yahoo.com search irgendwie, oder wie auch immer, die am Domain ist. Genau, auf die DuckDuckGo IP zeigen.
Jetzt musst du uns erstmal aufklären.
Ne, diese Suchmaschine.
Eine Suchmaschine, die halt nicht so Tracking und Bubble-Searching macht. Na ja, dass du in deiner eigenen Search-Bubble bist. Das heißt, wenn du einmal nach Calvin Klein-Unterwäsche gesucht hast, du dann, äh...
Das tut man dann auch, wenn man nach, äh...
nach Ethernet-Kabel sucht. Dann kriegst du Ethernet-Unterwäsche, äh, gestrickt aus Ethernet-Kabeln. Und, äh, auf jeden Fall, äh... ist das aber schon ganz cool, so von DuckDuckGo, dann gleich so irgendwie diese Kompatibilitätsmodus-Geschichte zu fahren. Hab ich auch ausprobiert, funktioniert super. Steht halt dann zwar trotzdem... Also, müsste man mal gucken, ob das jetzt da auch dann so wunderbar funktioniert, aber warum sollte es nicht, ne? Steht halt irgendwie dann immer... Im alten Safari zwar trotzdem, ja, Huda, aber du landest dann halt bei DuckDuckGo.
Ich find das Logo niedlich.
Ja.
Ich fand aber die Suchergebnisse nicht so toll, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber es wird immer besser tatsächlich auch, ja.
Obwohl, die ihre Ergebnisse her, die haben doch keine eigenen Spiders, oder wie? Die nutzen dann auch wieder Google?
Doch, ich glaube, die nutzen eigentlich tatsächlich eigenes alles.
Wie viele Milliarden Spider sind denn da schon unterwegs inzwischen?
Fünf.
Ja, der meiste Web-Traffic wird nur von Spider gemacht, natürlich.
Nicht mehr von Mega-Upload?
Nee, aber das ist jetzt nur mal so als Tipp am Rande, falls man mal nicht in seiner, äh, und so weiter, ne? Wenn man mal eine andere Suchmaschine, Safari benutzen will.
Gut, zurück zum Berglöwen. Weitere totale Überraschungen.
Zum Bergstinker.
Twitter wird jetzt hier als bevorzugter Dienst überall eingestanzt.
Ist nur konsequent.
Ja, ja, vielleicht. Also, ich hab ja derzeit nichts gegen Twitter, aber ich fänd's ja eigentlich besser, wenn man sich jeden beliebigen Dienst reinstanzen könnte in dieses OS. Und so richtig geil, also ich hab so nicht das Gefühl, ich weiß, was ich da twittere, wenn ich irgendwie dieses Interface benutze.
Ich hab so das Gefühl, dieser Teil, wo du sagst, jedes beliebige, das gibt's irgendwie seit einer Weile und in der Zukunft nicht mehr.
Jetzt muss ich restarten für den Safari.
Ich glaub, das wird noch mal kommen. Ich geh davon aus, dass wir das wieder einbauen.
Das klingt so ein bisschen nach Sherlock.
So Optionen. Ich glaub, alles wird immer auf irgendwelche einzelnen Dienste festgenagelt, weil außer Riesenmonopol hat ja auch gar nichts anderes mehr eine Chance.
Die API dafür für dieses ganze Twitter-Zeug, das ist ja schon die, wie heißt das, Account Center, Services, bla bla bla, das heißt ja nicht direkt Twitter, sondern das heißt ja immer alles, das sind ja schon vorgesehen, dass man da diverse Account-Typen reinpappen kann.
Was heißt das, das ist vorgesehen?
Na die API, die Apple dafür anbietet, die musst du explizit fragen, gib mir mal alle deine Twitter-Accounts. Also da könntest du, das ist eine konstante definierte Hand, da könntest du auch reinschmeißen, gib mir mal alle deine Facebook-Accounts, sobald sie das definieren. Das ist im Augenblick nicht der Fall.
Ja, aber Apple muss das definieren und nicht ich.
Im Augenblick schon, ja. Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es deswegen nicht kommt.
Ja, aber wozu gibt es denn dann so eine Payn, wo ich meine Accounts eintragen kann?
Deine Twitter-Accounts?
Nein, überhaupt die Accounts.
Aber da gibt es ja jetzt auch ein Präferenz-Ding.
Ja, es gibt ja jetzt schon Accounts. Wie heißt das Ding? Ich komm jedes Mal durcheinander. Das ändert sich ja auch wirklich von Release zu Release. Mail, Contacts und Kalender.
Da richtest du deine Mail, Contact und Kalender-Accounts?
Ja, aber auch deine Jumper-Accounts und sonstige Accounts und mein iCloud-Account und dieses und jenes. Und warum kann ich da nicht alle meine Accounts machen?
Ich habe gebootet.
Und dieser Zeug, der da bei Modern Life dazu kommt.
Ja, jetzt hab ich da irgendwelche chinesischen. Also es ist alles nur so von Apples Gnaden. Also wenn Apple jetzt der Meinung ist, auch in diesem Release finden wir jetzt mal Vimeo gut. Und im nächsten Release mögen wir dann, keine Ahnung, dann haben wir dann einen eigenen Videodienst, dann gibt's nur noch Apple Video, dann ist Vimeo wieder draußen und YouTube darf jetzt eh nicht mehr mitspielen, weil die sind jetzt irgendwie böse und wer das so bisher benutzt hat, dann muss ich halt was anderes einfach, das ist einfach nicht meine Vorstellung von einem Betriebssystem, ja? Also das geht mir einfach zu weit. Ich bin dagegen. Ich finde das nicht gut.
Ja, aber das ist so typisch Apple für die Dienste, für die sie eine gute Experience anbieten können. Das dann fest einzubauen und alle anderen einfach zu ignorieren.
Ja, das wirklich typisch.
Sie können da auch ein Interface in ihr Betriebssystem machen, wo dann der jeweilige Hersteller sich zu bemühen hat, dass er diese selbe Experience auch bereit stellt. Ich meine Video Upload. How complicated can that be? Da Plug-In zu fordern, so ein kleines Medülchen, was du da reinschmeißt und dann hast du an all diesen ganzen Outlets, wo du Vimeo Upload hast, hast du dann eben auch Upload zu welchem Ding auch immer.
Na ja, sie müssen es halt machen, dass es...
Netzneutralität.
Sie müssen es halt so machen, dass es auf allen Geräten funktioniert. Und es muss halt über den App-Store funktionieren und ich glaube, das ist nicht so trivial.
Wie, es muss über den App-Store funktionieren?
Wie willst du denn so was installieren? Meinst du, sollen die Leute jetzt anfangen?
Und der iOS, er redet jetzt wieder von iOS.
Ich rede auch auf Mac natürlich. Also ich meine, irgendwie musste ja diese Dienste dann installieren, die dann...
Ja, ich gehe auf meinen Lieblings-Video-Hochladedienstpunkt kommen und dann steht da, und hier ist das Mac OS X Plugin.
Und das schiebt man sich dann in Library-Service?
So, wie installierst du deine Safari-Extension? Genauso. Dickste drauf, sagst du install, sag Return, fertig.
Wie gesagt, muss auf allen Plattformen funktionieren.
Ja und? Wo ist das Problem? Welche Plattform meinst du denn jetzt?
Na iOS.
Wieso muss das... Ich rede vom Mac. Wir sind hier bei OS X.
Ja, die denken jetzt aber... Ich glaube, die denken jetzt gerade schon ein bisschen weiter, dass sie wenn sie sowas machen, dass sie dann für beide einführen.
Egal, wo die dahin denken. Ich habe einen Mac, ich will, dass es funktioniert. Das ist der Computer, wo ich Content erzeuge. Das mache ich nicht auf meinem iPad.
Ich sage mal so, deine Herangehensweise ist eher die alte Next-Herangehensweise, die aber Apple irgendwie schon seit diversen Versionen nicht mehr so sehr pflegt.
Ja, aber ich nehme mir die Freiheit heraus, das trotzdem scheiße zu finden.
Genau, wie bei Star Trek zur Kenntnis genommen.
Make it so.
Ich prangere das an.
Ja, ich mache mit. Aber ich habe jetzt den neuen Safari installiert. Ich musste nur neu starten dafür und schon schau ich gleich in einen Browser.
Kannst du denn mal Air-Dropen?
Wieso dat denn? Installier doch selber, Mann.
Ja, Air-Dropen.
Installierst du ja doch selbst.
Dazu brauch ich den ja.
Ja, Moment.
Software-Masturbation. Game Center.
Ah, wollte ich immer schon haben.
Hurra, das kommt wie ein Schock. Jetzt kannst du auch... Was spielt man dann da?
Keine Ahnung, aber wenn man auf eins dieser Programme da klickt, dann kommt man zum App-Store, oder? Dann kommt man zum iTunes-Store.
Was?
Ja, er zeigt da iTunes-Programme an.
Ja, dann machen wir auch ein Telefon da rumzufummeln, Dennis. So, klick mal auf was drauf hier. Sensor gibt's da.
Deswegen hab ich vorhin so lachen müssen, als ich die...
iTunes-Store? Und dann?
Ja, dann kannst du die iPhone- oder iPad-App... Ja, gut, das ist halt alles noch Beta, aber ich meine...
Na gut, aber das wird dann wohl nicht so sein, ne?
Nee, nee, das bleibt jetzt alles bis zur finalen Version so. Die anderen haben nix mehr. Die nennen das nur Beta.
Noch lachste.
Das bis Sommer machen wir gar nichts mehr.
Genau.
Na gut, ich meine, wo sollten sie jetzt schon hinlinken, ne? Klar.
Dein App-Store.
Ja, da gibt's aber jetzt noch keine Game-Center-Mac-Anwendungen. Also von daher können sie jetzt nicht wirklich irgendwo hinlinken.
Aber die Spiele, die sie da anzeigen, die müssten ja schon irgendwo hinführen, oder? Oder zeig dir einfach... Oder sind das jetzt einfach deine Game-Center-tauglichen Sachen?
Nein, ich hab da ja jetzt nichts drauf auf dieser Installation.
Naja, aber du bist doch mit... Ach, du bist gar nicht mit deinem...
Ich denke mal, das sind jetzt einfach so Platzhalter. Und da haben sie jetzt mal dafür entschieden, irgendwelche blöden iPad-Apps zu nehmen.
Nee, das ist alles final.
Naja, da werkelt halt im Hintergrund der iPad-Code. Also das ist jetzt irgendwie...
Also ich denke, da müssen wir nicht sehr viel zu sagen. Jetzt kommen wir zu einem viel interessanteren Punkt, nämlich... Play Mirroring! Und da hat mich allein schon wieder der Titel etwas verstört.
Das heißt, genauso wie auf dem iPad.
Ist mir egal. Ey, also echt. iPad meint wegen iPhone geschenkt. Ist toll. Gerne. Ich liebe mein iPhone. Ich hab ein iPad, ich kann wenig damit anfangen, aber es ist okay, weil ich weiß, dass es Milliarden Leute gibt, die das ganz großartig finden und ganz toll finden.
Dein iPad macht uns doch da die Uhr hier an der Wand.
Ja, genau. Das sind zum Beispiel so...
Teuerste Wand-Uhr ever wahrscheinlich.
Wenn du das Original von dieser Uhr kaufst, ist die teurer als ein iPad. Diese Radio-Uhr, die kriegst du so irgendwie ab 1000 irgendwas.
Alter, die baue ich der Hucke. Die machen wir doch für einen Fofi, oder?
Für einen Apple und ein Aia.
Ich war mal beim Uni-Radio, da hatten sie auch so eine Uhr. Und das Gemeine an der Uhr ist, dass sie sich nicht stellen konnte. Also die, die die damals da hatten, sondern die hat nur das Zeit-Signal verwendet, um synchron zu bleiben. Und wenn da der Strom weg war, dann musste man diese Uhr umständlich wieder neu stellen. Also wenn sie dann mal in Sync war, dann blieb sie in Sync. Aber wenn sie es nicht war, war sie nicht in der Lage, sich von alleine zu stellen.
Was ist das für eine Beklemmung?
Na gut, die stellt sich von alleine.
Das ist halt so ihr Mit-Tanzerwart.
Hey, wir machen eine Funk-Uhr, die sich nicht selber stellen kann.
Das Ding hab ich glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt. Das ist quasi so eine Replika von dieser Gorgi-Timing-Uhr.
Hier zum Thema Airplay Mirroring. Wird hier aber als Audiogerät in dem Audio-Midi-Setup angezeigt.
Das ist ja lustig.
Da hast du wahrscheinlich einen Audio-Ausgang, ne?
Ist also möglicherweise wirklich ein Audio-Ausgang.
Oh, da ist das schon mal ein gutes Zeichen. Die Frage ist, ist es auch ein Video-Ausgang?
Keine Ahnung, der Displayport ist ja auch nur ein Audio-Ausgang.
Auch da vermute ich mal, dass man wiederum...
Das Programm heißt ja auch Audio-Midi-Setup und nicht Video-Midi-Setup.
Auch da vermute ich mal, dass es relativ ähnlich sein wird, wie wir es schon vom iPad kennen mit dem AirPlay-Mirroring. Nämlich, dass man entweder ein Screen Duplication, also dass man echtes Mirroring hat, selber Bildschirme auf beiden Geräten oder halt, dass man als App sagen kann, ok, ich möchte jetzt gern auf dem AirPlay gemirrohrten Device das und das anzeigen.
Ja, aber warum Mirroring? Ich möchte unter Umständen ja ein Programm haben, was da nicht mirrohrt, sondern was mir auf meinem Computer etwas anzeigt und dann auf diesem AirPlay-Device was anderes.
Das geht, also die API, die unter iOS da ist, um Video als AirPlay auf die Apple-Dingstar-TV zu schicken. Diese API haben sie für Mountain Lion auch auf den Mac zurückgebaut.
Das geht nicht nur für Videos, das geht auch für alles.
Wie auch immer, also es gibt diese API jetzt.
Sie nennen es hier nur Mirroring, aber eigentlich heißt es, es gibt jetzt da ein Device. Aber kann man das dann auch als zweiten Bildschirm konfigurieren?
Ich vermute stark das nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Weil das wäre ja eigentlich auch ganz interessant, dass ich so ein Secondary, also ich fand beides interessant.
Dafür gibt es was, das habe ich am Wochenende mal ausprobiert. Airparad heißt das, also wie der Papagei. Installiert man sich unter Line und das macht dann exakt das. Das macht einen zweiten Bildschirm mit 720p Auflösung. Und da kann man entweder den internen Bildschirm doppeln oder man nutzt es halt als externen Bildschirm. Funktioniert relativ okay. Ist leider ein bisschen instabil, die Software. Und ich habe das Gefühl, die hatten jetzt eine Version, die verhindert hat, dass mein Rechner vernünftig aufgewacht ist. Und dann haben sie irgendwie ein Update hinterhergeschoben. Ah, der Rechner ist immerhin nicht mehr richtig aufgewacht. Und jetzt das Problem zwar weniger, aber nicht weg. Also so richtig toll ist es nicht. Aber das könnte doch mal richtig schick werden.
Also ich nehme mal an, das Mirroring machen, die ja im Betriebssystem irgendwie. Und dann muss man das ja auch reverse-ingenieren können. Und dann muss man es irgendwie auch so machen.
Ich bin da nur so ein bisschen... Gut finde ich ja, ich freu mich, warum das überhaupt so lange dauert. Aber explizit sagen sie ja hier, Keynote kann das und iMovie kann das. Zeigen hier allerdings auch wirklich nur so ein Mirroring an.
Ja, das wird schon so funktionieren wie auf iPhone und iPad.
Kann ich nicht genauer sagen, ich hab's mir nicht so genau angeguckt.
Ich hab's mir genau angeguckt.
Ich hab nur gesehen, dass die ganzen APIs, die auch unter iOS existieren, um mal schnell ein Video auf eine Apple TV zu machen, dass die jetzt auch unter Mountain Line da sind, ob die dann auch so funktionieren, weiß ich nicht. Aber vorher gab's die überhaupt nicht. Da musste man selber hacken, wenn man irgendwas anzeigen wollte.
Aber wenn jetzt zwei Programme gleichzeitig da was zeigen wollen, dann ist es schon wie...
Schmeißt das zweite wahrscheinlich das erste raus.
Wahrscheinlich.
Schmeißt das raus.
Na ja. So wie ich die Sache sehe, hast du halt das als Ausgabegerät für irgendwas. Und wenn ein Programm was ausgibt, dann kann das andere Programm nicht ausgeben. Dann ist es busy. Dann ist es entweder busy oder es bekommt das Gerät und das andere verliert das Gerät. Oder irgendwie sowas. Keine Ahnung. Also ich denke nicht, dass da jetzt irgendwie, dass das eine weitere Grafikkarte in deinem Rechner ist, sondern das ist irgendwie...
Wahrscheinlich einfach das, was gerade im Vordergrund ist, wird angezeigt.
Also ich meine so die logischen Anwendungen, wie ich für da eine Präsentation aus Keynote raus auf, das ist ja irgendwie...
Sehr naheliegend.
Das ist naheliegend.
Jaja, das ist naheliegend.
Aber du willst natürlich über deine Keynote-Präsentation nicht deinen Twitter kleinlegen oder so. Gut, vielleicht willst du das. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so ein Anwendungsfall, den Apple jetzt so vor Augen schwebt.
Also vermutlich, wenn ich das jetzt so höre, dann würde ich sagen, okay, es gibt Programme, die sind explizit Airplay-aware und können dann sagen, ah, hier gibt's Airplay, dann nutze ich das mal. Und heißt das, dass ich dann schon vorher ein Device festgelegt habe, als wenn jemand Airplay macht, dann ist es das? Ich meine, was ist, wenn ich zwei Apple TV habe?
Du wählst das aus, das ist das Gerät, was du auswählst. Du hast deine Auswahl mit hier diese Airplay-tauglichen Geräte. Hast du in den Einstellungen.
Ja, aber kann ich auch zu zwei oder drei oder zehn oder zwanzig schicken?
Nein, du kannst es immer nur zu einem schicken. Warum?
Ich nehme mal an.
Weißt du das oder denkst du das?
Ich weiß es.
Das Menü kann halt immer nur einen Punkt gleichzeitig.
Aber bei Audio kann man ja mehrere aufwählen.
Ja, nein, aber du kannst auch nur ein Audio-Device aufmachen und auf ein Audio-Device schicken.
Wie kannst du mehrere Airplay-Ziele gleichzeitig aufmachen?
Klar, kannst du auch anwählen.
Du kannst mehrere Player starten für jede Senke ein.
Also wir sprechen jetzt hier von diesem Airplay-Button hier unten.
Ne, sprechen wir nicht. Wir sprechen hier von dem Airplay-Button. Wir sind nicht auf dem iPad. Vergiss es, klapp's wieder zu.
Ja, aber wir haben hier gerade kein Apple-TV, also können wir es nicht ausprobieren, außer du holst mal rasch dein Apple-TV her. Und insofern wäre es doch ganz schön, das jetzt mal zu gucken auf einem Gerät, auf dem wir es da haben.
Ist da überhaupt irgendeine Software drauf?
Nein.
Ein User-Interface sichtbar, wo ich jetzt, ich meine, Mirroring heißt, dass das nur Programme selbst entscheiden können, dass sie ihren Kram mirroren. Die haben doch da oben auch schon einen Screenshot von. Oder kann ich einfach mein Betriebssystem sagen, du mirrorst jetzt alles, was hier ist, auf diesem Device. Und wo stelle ich das dann an?
Da gab es so Tests, jede Dame.
Guck doch mal, klick doch mal da auf Desktop, da ist ein Screenshot davon. Da hast du doch gerade offen gehabt.
Ich habe auch schon ein Video gesehen, wo wir den gesamten Desktop gemirroert haben.
Da ist oben das Airplay-Menü sichtbar. Das ist doch nicht so kompliziert, Leute.
Da ist ein Airplay-Menü.
Aber hier ist jetzt keins.
Hier ist ja auch kein Airplay-Gerät.
Das taucht dann erst auf, wenn dann Airplay-Devices da sind.
Was natürlich auch ein Spaß wird, wenn dann die ganze Musik darüber streamt. Weil das wird dann sicherlich auch gehen. Das sind ja iTunes und so.
Die Musik kommt ja mit. Das Video, was da irgendwie bei irgendeinem Apple News-Seite gemacht haben, da haben die auch ein Video abgespielt. Und das war mit Audio.
Das geht bei diesem Airplay-Ride übrigens auch sehr gut.
Vielleicht gibt's die ganze GUI dazu noch nicht. Oder nur, wenn du halt ein Airplay-Gerät in der Nähe hast, zeigt der dir überhaupt irgendetwas an. Also es ist ja so, dass es über Bonjour gefunden wird. Und dann weißt du, da ist ein Airplay-Gerät in der Nähe.
Also was ich ja, wo ich so ein bisschen scharf drauf bin, ist, dass man endlich mal andere Bildschirm-Outlets nutzen kann, ohne dass sie gleich Teil des Desktops sind. Dass man einfach einem das Programm sagen kann, oh, da ist ein Bildschirm im Netz und den benutze ich jetzt, um irgendwas darauf aufzugeben, was vollkommen unter meiner Kontrolle ist.
Ich denke, sowas wird funktionieren.
Na das ist doch gerade.
Also vor allem, also zumindest für Videos.
Aber jetzt noch, es ist ein Mirroring. Du willst was Eigenständiges.
Genau, was Eigenständiges. Was weiß ich, ich hab da so ein Beamer und da soll halt irgendwas laufen. Aber ich will trotzdem noch mit meinem Computer weiterarbeiten können.
Ja, ich denke, das wird früher oder später gehen.
Früher oder später. Aber wieso?
Also das geht doch mit dem iPad jetzt schon.
Ich rede nicht von dem fucking iPad.
Guck mal, die haben das vom iPad genommen. Das iPad wird von einer Firma namens Apple hergestellt.
Arsch!
Und wir brauchen jetzt hier nicht irgendwie rumzudiskutieren in irgendwelchen hypothetischen Welten, sondern wir können einfach das nehmen, was wir haben und können uns angucken, wie das ist und können davon ausgehen, dass sie es vermutlich eins zu eins so auf dem Mac portiert haben. Und wir wissen, wie es auf dem iPad funktioniert oder auf dem iPhone und dann wissen wir jetzt, weil das ist der ganze Sinn dieses Betriebssystems, den Mac ein bisschen mehr so zu machen wie diese anderen iOS-Devices.
Nein!
Doch, das ist Apple's Definition von diesem Betriebssystem.
Schmerzen!
Ja, dir verursacht das Schmerzen, ist schön. Aber darum wissen wir, wie es funktioniert.
Airplay gibt es länger als dein iPad.
Aber es gibt Airplay Mirroring nicht länger als mein iPad.
Ich will das alles nicht hören. Ich will ausgewachsenen...
Eigentlich gibt es das schon länger, weil das ging ja mit dem Audio Streaming los. Das war doch das Audio Stream von iTunes.
Airplay Mirroring ist dieses Feature, was den... Airplay Mirroring ist das Feature, das heißt so, dass dein iPad auf dem Fernseher anzeigt. Das ist der Name dafür.
Ja, aber das ist doch genau das Gleiche für Video, was es vorher schon in iTunes gab, um Audio zu streamen. Das ist doch der gleiche Scheiß.
Nee, das ist nicht ein Video.
Das ist nicht ganz das gleiche Protokoll.
Aber sei es auch nicht. Natürlich ist es nicht das gleiche Protokoll, aber...
Das ist was komplett Neues, das gab es vorher nicht.
Ist ja egal.
Das hat auch nichts mit Video zu tun.
Mir ist es trotzdem egal, was das iPad da macht oder nicht macht, dass es irgendwie weniger macht, aber ich will ja einen Erwachsenencomputer haben. Ich will ja jetzt nicht so einen auf iPad-Fähigkeiten reduzierten Mac haben, sondern ich will einen Mac haben. Einen Computer, der alles kann.
NextCube, das wollen wir.
Ich wollte überhaupt in meinem Leben immer nur einen einzigen Computer, den besten. Alle anderen interessieren mich gar nicht. Ich will nur den besten Computer haben, der alles kann. Den will ich haben. Und wenn Apple der Meinung ist, sie müssen den jetzt nicht mehr bauen, dann ergibt sich da ne Opportunity für andere Menschen mit klarem Kopf.
Aber was genau ist hier an dem ganzen Zeug schlecht?
Ich hab Angst.
Du hast Angst vor Airplay-Mavering?
Nein, ich hab einfach vor diesen ganzen Scheißangst. Line ist so eine furchtbare Scheiße. Ich hab noch nie in so einem schlechten Computer gearbeitet, wie alles, was unter Line läuft. Das ist furchtbar. Und ich hab einfach Angst, dass dieser Puma, der schon mal da war, mich wieder in diese 10-1-Welt zurückbringt. Alles wird langsam und nichts funktioniert mehr.
Eins war nicht langsam unter Puma. 10-1. Das Aufwachen. Aber dafür hat er auch nicht wirklich geschlafen.
Okay, kommen wir zu einem nicht weniger strittigen Thema. Gatekeeper.
Moment, ich mach's mal hier an.
Das Finanzamt Kreuzberg, ja.
Genau, das Finanzamt Kreuzberg.
Ja, das finde ich ja ganz interessant. Und mir sind die Implikationen noch nicht so 100%ig klar. Also, was ist Gatekeeper? Gatekeeper ist so eine Art Verklick dich nicht User Interface.
Das ist die Vorausschau auf Desktop Jailbreaking.
Naja, so wie sie es gemacht haben, gibt es keinen Bedarf dafür.
Das Jailbreaking ist die unterste Option. Die klickst du an, dann hast du jailgebroken.
Naja, noch nicht. Das kommt aber irgendwann, die Option verschwindet. Und dann denken sie alle, ist ja gar kein Problem. Ich hab ja die Platte, kommt man ja überall ran. Ist aber auch nicht, weil demnächst gibt es keine Platte mehr. Und dann ist das Flash irgendwie hart gelötet, so wie im iPhone halt. Und dann will ich mal sehen, wie es aussieht. Wir werden uns dran erinnern.
Also ich finde, wir sprechen uns noch.
Da, so also, man muss jetzt mal an dem messen, was sie getan haben. So oder was sich hier abzeichnet, was sie tun werden, um mal genau zu sein. Und das, was sie da jetzt zeigen, was sie tun wollen, da finde ich jetzt so erstmal nichts falsch dran. Es sei denn, wir kommen auf irgendeinen Aspekt, den ich noch nicht bedacht habe.
Grundsätzlich ist es erstmal okay.
Also was ist Gatekeeper? Gatekeeper erlaubt dir einzuschränken, welche Programme sich ohne weiteres starten lassen auf deinem Computer. Du hast eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, nur Programme, die aus dem Mac App Store kommen, dürfen hier laufen. Beziehungsweise lassen sich einfach starten.
Allow applications downloaded from. Steht da.
Richtig. Wobei, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist es ja auch so, dass das sich nur auf den Doppelklick im Finder bezieht. Und du die Möglichkeit hast, das zu umgehen, indem du da so Kontextklicks öffnen machst. Ja, also das ist nicht so...
Also hoffentlich nur für Administratorenaccounts.
Nein, nein.
Also nicht für jeden Account.
Das kann ich dir nicht beantworten.
Also entweder machst du ordentliches Codesigning, dann hast du es wie beim i...
Moment, lass uns erst mal kurz beschreiben, was da ist. Also es gibt drei Optionen. Mac App Store, Mac App Store and Identified Developers. Das heißt, in dem Fall bezieht sich das auf Programme, die signiert sind und zwar mit einem Zertifikat, was selber von Apple signiert ist. Wenn also irgendein Developer mir jetzt was weiß ich, sagen wir mal hier, Adium, möchte gerne auch in diesem Modus laufen, dann gehen sie zu Apple und sagen, hallo, wir sind die Adium-Developer, gib mir doch mal ein Zertifikat, mit dem wir selber signieren. Und dann ein Programm starten. Verstann ich mal bitte mitten rein. Ich halte auch gleich Small wieder, aber das Adium-Team könnte sich so ein Zertifikat holen und Adium signieren und ausliefern, so wie sie das heute auch machen, per Download über die Webseite. Und in diesem Default-Setting wäre alles gut. Niemand würde meckern, wenn man das Programm nimmt, doppelklickt und startet. Angenommen, man hätte aber auf... Angenommen, es gäbe dieses Zertifikat nicht, also so wie Adium heute kommt, dann könntest du es in diesem Modus aber trotzdem starten. Habe ich gehört. Das können wir jetzt gerne mal ausprobieren.
Im mittleren Modus. Im mittleren Modus, genau. Ich hab nur Apple-Programme da drauf.
Lad dir doch mal eine runter.
Wie lange hast du jetzt deinen Mac schon?
Los hier, Evil Wireshark oder irgendwie so.
Adium.
Oh Gott, nicht Adium. Nicht von allen Apps, nicht Adium. Jedes Mal wieder an den Torenten.
Da kenn ich aber wirklich eine Menge schlechteres Software als Adium.
Jetzt haben wir hier Adium. Ach so, jetzt muss ich. Doch, das hab ich angemacht. Bestimmte Entwickler hab ich angeschaltet.
Ich kopier's auch mal ordentlich in Applikationchen.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal das Disk Image öffnen.
Einfach pippsch noch einmal.
Die Spannung steigt.
Ja, da haben wir.
Das ist auch eines des schönsten.
So.
So, Dille.
Er kopiert das brav. Und dann schauen wir doch mal unter Applications. Müsste es doch jetzt hier unter Adium angekommen sein.
Klicken Sie doppelt.
Hab ich gemacht.
Die Ente hüpft und der sagt.
Adium kommt von einem unidentifizierten Entwickler. Safari hat die Datei heute um 21 Uhr von Adium IM geladen.
So, so, so.
Dann gucken wir das noch mit so einem roten Stopp. Okay, ja, dann passiert nichts.
Und jetzt machst du mal hier Kontextmenü auf Adium.
Kontextmenü auf Adium? Nicht mit dieser Maus. Und dann?
Öffnen. Öffnen.
Das wird ja genau das Gleiche.
Dann kommt es gleich an. Ah, jetzt könnte ich öffnen drücken.
Aber ich würde es nicht machen. Das ist ein zu gehorenes Sicherheitsrisiko.
Starten.
Jetzt muss er deinen Adress ins Hardware-Poster nehmen.
Core Services UI Agent is trying to permanently modify System-wide security settings. Aha, also du musst jetzt sozusagen auch noch mal verewigen, dass das gestattet ist.
Gucken wir mal, ob jetzt checkt, was ich gesagt hab. Jetzt hüpft die Ente.
Oh mein Gott, sie ist gestartet!
So, jetzt beende mal die Ente.
Und starte nochmal.
Mach nochmal Doppelklick.
Wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt für alle Ewigkeiten immer so.
Jetzt kommt sie, jetzt ist es für alle Ewigkeiten so. Jetzt hast du einmal gesagt, ich will das trotzdem, und alles ist prima.
Aber auch nur als Admin. Dann musst du ja nochmal...
Ja, aber es ist sozusagen, du hast deinen Wunsch explizit...
Aber hier steht es immer noch für bestimmte...
Geht auch nochmal raus und wieder rein.
Du hast nur dieses Programm trotzdem zugelassen.
Geht das dann nur für dieses Programm? Das geht jetzt erstmal nur für dieses Programm.
Das heißt, man kann seinen Rechner voll dicht machen und kann alles erlauben von Hand, was man trotzdem machen möchte. Und das ist okay.
Großartig.
Genau, das ist okay. Das würde ich nämlich auch sagen. Was ich mich allerdings jetzt frage, ist, wie ist es mit selbst kompilten Kommandozeilen, Brusachen und so weiter?
Also, ich installiere jetzt ja halt irgendeinen Command Line Tool. Was macht er dann?
Du hast ja selber gebaut.
Nee, muss ja nicht.
Ja, du musst das Co-Signen. Also, das ist der Punkt. Das funktioniert alles über Co-Signing und du brauchst das entsprechende Co-Signing-Zertifikat und das kriegst du nur von Apple, wenn du angemeldeter Entwickler bist. Du musst aber keinen bezahlten Entwickler-Account haben, sondern es geht auch um freie Entwickler-Account. Der Grund an der ganzen Sache ist, dass sich Apple vorbehält, wenn du Scheiße baust mit diesen signierten Dingern.
Dein Ding zurückzuziehen und dann geht's nicht. Das heißt, die machen auch einen Online-Check.
Genau.
Jedes Mal.
Remote Kill-Switch.
Sonst könnten sie es ja nicht zurückziehen, weil wenn mein Programm erst mal eingetragen ist, würde es ja ewig laufen.
Sie haben wahrscheinlich eine Revocation-List oder so.
Wie soll das ja sonst gehen? Die müssen ja immer mal wieder checken, ob was passiert ist.
Das ist bestimmt nicht so, dass sie jetzt online voraussetzen.
Das nicht, aber vielleicht bei jedem Rechnerstart oder immer mal wieder an Abständen.
Du kannst die entsprechenden Zertifikate auch schon erzeugen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt einen Postgres bauen will oder so, aus dem Homebrew, muss ich den dann auch authorisen?
Ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass Brew dahingehend erweitert wird, dass sie eben immer, wenn du dir selber was übersetzt, dein eigenes Zertifikat, was dann auch von Apple gesignt ist, mitverwendet wird.
Oder sie machen es einfach so, dass es freigegeben wird über diese Einstellung, die wir gerade gesehen haben. Dass das dann quasi nicht das User-Interface-Element, sondern das Command-Design-Element für diese Freischaltung... Dafür brauchst du das Super... Es ist doch eigentlich die letzten Jahre immer so gewesen, dass wir dann irgendwo ein Tool dafür mitgeliefert haben.
Was ich jetzt mal interessant fände, du könntest ja vielleicht mal irgendwas anderes aus dem Internet, aus diesem Gefährdigten herunterladen. Ja, ich wollte jetzt mal so ein normaler... Was darf's denn sein? Was gibt's denn noch?
Aber mit Homebrew mal schnell ein komisches Command reintun.
Was weiß ich hier, so U-Torrent oder so was?
U-Torrent.
Transmission.
Oder Transmission, genau.
Ah, Transmission, was ordentliches.
Ordentliches Software. Und dann könntest du ja mal den gleichen Spaß, wie eben noch mal machen, aber in dem wir direkt von der Kommandozeile starten. Also mit Open aus der Kommandozeile.
Ja, mit Open aus der Kommandozeile machst du ja nur wieder das Gleiche, als ob das einen Top-Effekt aufgemacht hätte.
Warte, stopp, stopp. Mit Curl runterladen.
Also wenn, dann musst du schon direkt den Kommandozahlenbefehl aufrufen.
Also, weil mit Curl, dann kriegst du ja auch nicht diese Meldung, ist aus dem Internet runtergeladen wahrscheinlich, ne?
Wer dann weiß halt nur nicht, woher du das hast, aber...
Kopier das aber auch mal in Applikationen.
Die Signatur fehlt ja trotzdem.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wie schnell der Robby sein...
Der Robby.
Der Robby seinen Rechner bedienen kann. Robbys Render...
Rechner. Rechter.
Was machst du jetzt? Ach so. Was machst du jetzt?
Ich starte das.
Das wirst du nicht starten können. Jetzt musst du da auf genau, Contents...
Musste man nicht erst bei Verzeichnis rein?
Musst du das nicht angeben, den Fahrt?
Ja, aber Open ist doch sowieso was anderes.
Und was kommt? Jetzt startet er das direkt. Was steht da? Direkt.
Transmission ist ein Blar Willkommen bei Transmission. Also er hat es gestartet.
Kann das sein, dass er vielleicht doch deine Einstellung...
Jetzt mal nochmal Doppelklick.
Jetzt mach ich nochmal ein Doppelklick.
Mit was hast du jetzt gestartet? Mit Open oder was?
Nee, direkt die... Kannst du es aber auch nochmal mit Open machen. Mit Open auf dem Folder. Wer uns jetzt nicht mehr folgen kann, wir fassen das gleich zusammen. Aber jetzt sind wir alle ganz aufgeregt und...
Jetzt haltet mal kurz inne.
Aber Open ist doch so wie Doppelklick.
Das können wir jetzt gleich sehen, wie es ist. Spannung steigt.
Dauert schon länger. Noch hüpft er.
Hüpft er noch oder läuft er schon?
Wieso dauert das so lange?
Weil es keine SSD ist.
Vielleicht ist da schon irgendein Dialog.
Oder du hast es gerade zerschossen.
Guck mal hier diesen Settings-Dialog an. Der sieht nicht so richtig koscher aus.
Ja, die sind alle noch nicht fertig übersetzt. Das hätte man vielleicht auch einfach. Wird geblockt.
Also das ist jetzt... Mit Open ist es wie Doppelklick. Mit Open ist es wie Doppelklick, ja.
Aber Open ist schon immer wie Doppelklick.
Aber direkt Kommandozeile? Meckert da gar nicht?
Wir können es auch nochmal mit Doppelklick, da geht es ein bisschen schneller.
Das ist interessant. Also es gibt drei Abstufungen. Wenn du Doppelklick machst oder Open, das Open-Kommando auf der Kommandozeile benutzt, dann passt hier gar nicht rein, geh weg.
Das Open-Tool verwendet auch die Launch-Services, wie die heißen. Also das ist das, was der Finder auch benutzt, ist die gleiche Technik.
Ich wollte es mal kurz zusammenfassen. Wenn du Open auf der Kommandozeile benutzt oder Doppelklickst, dann sagt er, nee, weg. Wenn du im Finder-Kontext-Menü öffnen sagst, dann kriegst du auch eine Meldung, aber du kannst es dann erstens öffnen und zweitens auch gleich durch Eingabe deines Admin-Passworts das so in Stein gießen, nein, nicht in Stein, was sagt man? Wie auch immer, festzuchen, dass er ab sofort das erlaubt. Und wenn du aber direkt das Binary startest auf der Kommandozeile, dann zuckt da gar nichts. Weil dann kommt hier einfach Unix Execution. Das würde mir wiederum sagen, wenn du jetzt auf dieses System, in diesen Settings irgendwelche Unix-Kommandozeilen-Utilities installierst und startest, dann meckert da gar keiner. Das heißt, da schützt dich überhaupt nicht vor Kommandozeilen-Viren.
Kommandozeilen-Viren?
Das heißt, dumme User fühlen sich sicher und sie sind es aber eigentlich gar nicht.
Na doch, sie sind schon deutlich sicher.
Na ja, nicht dumm, aber so... Also, da ist nichts sicher, weil wenn Virus da rauf will...
Dann installiert er sich in User-Bentralala.
Aber der muss ja erstmal raufkommen, ne?
Ja gut, aber ein Skript, was sich so in Auto-Execution reinhackt und dann einfach gestartet wird...
Das ist eigentlich nur ein Warnsystem, aber kein Verhinderungssystem.
Also ich meine, wenn ein Skript, in dem sich ein Skript irgendwo hin kopieren kann und Admin-Rechte hat, kann es sich auch die Rechte geben zu starten. Also das ist ja nun...
Aber wenn jetzt einfach nur aus dem Browser... Moins!...
braucht keine Admin-Rechte, um sich irgendwo hin zu kopieren.
Na, wenn es aber in ein entsprechendes Verzeichnis, wo es dann laufen kann, also, meinst du, dass es sich direkt als Executable runterlädt?
Ja, als mein User, das reicht ja schon, dann kannst du ja schon alles löschen.
Mach mal Transmission jetzt, das ist ja noch nicht authorized, ne?
Genau.
Dann können wir jetzt ja mal in die Launch-Services hier mit eintragen. Na, in die Login-Items halt.
Und jetzt logst du ihn aus und... Dass das nicht geht nach all den Jahren, dass man einfach dieses Transmission, dieses Eigen da...
Also das unautorisierte Transmission trägst du jetzt in die Login-Items ein.
Ich jetzt log sie noch mal aus und schade ist...
Jetzt noch mal Abwischrift Q.
Wir loggen uns aus und loggen uns wieder ein.
Genau. Dann wollen wir mal sehen.
Hier wird dem Puma auf dem Zahn gefühlt.
Ja, live und in Farbe. Naja, also zumindest für uns.
Spannung steigt, wir loggen uns wieder ein. Hat so ein bisschen was von Text-Adventure, so ein Podcast. Du stehst in einem Wald.
Musst du mal Passwort für Gonzales nehmen?
Das ist die eingebaute Platte.
Da kommt er jetzt hochgehüpft, die Spannung steigt.
Das passiert wahrscheinlich exakt.
Naja, immerhin.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es auf der Kommando-Zeile da auch noch irgendwie, dass man das Executable Bit explizit sitzen kann. Und dann ist das schon eine schöne Sache.
Ja, also so richtig viel verhindern tut dieser Gatekeeper jetzt nicht.
Na doch, nur verhindern.
Was?
Ah nee, ist nur zum Informieren, so war es. Genau, Informieren, aber nicht zum Verhindern. Nicht so wirklich.
Ja, also das ist so ein bisschen so ein Dauerschutz.
Wie du am Anfang schon sagtest, so Verklickmeinnicht.
Aber kann man nicht mal gucken, ob er jetzt... Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn du jetzt eine noch nicht geladene App starten würdest? Wie? Also gerade haben wir ja direkt vorher hast du ja dein Passwort eingegeben, dein Admin-Passwort, dass er es starten soll. Kann das sein, dass er darum sich noch vernünftig starten konnte? Auch über die Kommandozeile? Weil er noch im Sudo-Modus war quasi und sein Passwort nicht dringend wieder haben wollte?
Das galt ja nur für Adium.
Also es war nur für Adium.
Ja, aber dafür war doch das Passwort noch gesetzt. Das ist doch so, dass man sein Passwort nur alle paar Minuten neu eingeben muss. Ja, aber für Transmission, wenn du jetzt Transmission über die Shell nochmal startest.
Du meinst hier...
Aber hat der da kein Sudo benutzt?
Das ist schon krass. Was ist krass? Dass er erstens so schnell startet, wenn man ihn einfach so aufruft.
Vorher dauert es ewig, ne?
Ja, vorher hüppelt er dreimal rum, bevor da was passiert. Wahrscheinlich haben sie es da noch nicht aktiviert.
Ja, der fragt erst mal den Koch, ob er starten darf.
Aber man kann dann auch mit Ctrl-C wieder beenden. So muss es sein.
Ich glaube, das ist genau der richtige Name für den Mann. Ja, ich weiß nicht, Tim kann ich jetzt irgendwie nicht sagen.
Und...
Haben wir uns auch dran gewöhnt. Tim zu sagen.
Okay, also Gatekeeper haben wir zerrissen. Was kommt als nächstes?
Ich weiß nicht, ich finde das jetzt auf jeden Fall schadet erstmal nicht. Wir haben jetzt auch nicht den App Store-Modus getestet. Der wird sich aber wahrscheinlich genauso verhalten. Auch wenn du im App Store-Modus bist, kannst du dann genauso alles noch freiklicken drum herum. Wobei ich diesen Modus jetzt auch irgendwie ein bisschen bräsig finde, weil im App Store ok, was bedeutet das? Na gut, das könnte vielleicht irgendwann mal bedeuten, dass das dann eben nur noch Sandbox-Applikationen sind.
Aber wenn du deinen Kindern Zugriff auf deinen Rechner gibst, dann können die da Spiele sich runterladen oder sowas und können dann mit ihrer iTunes-Karte sich selber was kaufen, aber kann nicht den Rechner kaputt machen.
Also für so Lab- und Schulumgebungen ist es vielleicht auch ganz ok, wenn du dann einfach irgendwie den mittleren oder den Make-App-Store-Modus anschaltest und die Leute, die da tagsüber in dem Rechner sitzen, können zwar irgendwas runterladen, aber sie können es nicht ausführen.
Ja gut, für Lab-Umgebungen hätte ich ehrlich gesagt sogar noch eine härtere Einstellung. Also da würde ich wirklich explizit sagen, ja auch so mit Kontextmenü geht auch nichts. Wobei ok, dann musst du deinen...
Das Kontextmenü geht wahrscheinlich nur bei Admin.
Da musst du das Admin-Passwort eingeben. Aber direkt auf der Kommandozahl, ich meine das Terminal ist da. Der Trick wird sich schnell rumsprechen.
Ich frage mich, ob das nicht einfach nur, dass die das jetzt schnell in die Launch-Services eingebaut haben, dass sie was zum zeigen haben und die richtige Implementierung kommt noch. Weil ich meine, sinnvoll ist das nur, wenn du wirklich im Kernel checkst, ob du ein Executable ausführen kannst, weil es ordentlich gecode-signed ist. Ansonsten ist es irgendwie immer umgehbar.
Ja, also die Kommandozeile scheint derzeit von diesem Ding überhaupt nicht auch nur im Ansatz betroffen zu sein.
Aber man könnte doch mal ausprobieren, wie es ist, wenn man keine anderen Rechte hat.
Unter iOS machen sie es ja so, dass sie das Code-Signing im Kernel checken und deswegen musst du ja beim Jail-Breaken dann auch tatsächlich das Code-Sign-Checken im Kernel ausschalten. Sonst kannst du keine nicht-gesignten Programme starten. Also das ist quasi das, was Jail-Breaking eigentlich ist, Teil des Kernels austauschen, um nicht-gesignete Applikationen überhaupt starten zu können. Und wenn das so auch kommt, naja, obwohl es gibt ja immer noch den Schalter.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall, Datekeeper ist so Program Security Lite.
Bis jetzt, schauen wir mal. Vielleicht fixen sie es noch bis Juli, oder? Juli soll es doch rauskommen.
Die größte Lüge ist noch beta, es wird schneller, wenn es fertig ist.
Also ich würde sagen, probier doch mal einfach aus, was passiert, wenn du es mit einem nicht-Admin-User ausfährst.
Muss ich überhaupt erst anlegen, ja?
Also das müssen wir jetzt auch nicht machen, jetzt sofort.
Du musst dann halt trotzdem einen Admin-Account eingeben, um das dauerhaft zu verankern.
Vielleicht nicht nur dauerhaft, sondern auch ausnahmsweise. Und dass das dann vielleicht auch für die Commander-Zeile genauso geht. Also alles andere, dann wär's tatsächlich keine Sicherheit. Dann wär's albern. Aber wenn du jetzt einfach so mit einem nicht-Admin-User das nicht mehr machen kannst, dann ist doch alles gut.
Aber wird er machen können, bin ich mir fast sicher.
Vielleicht ist ja jetzt auch die richtige Gelegenheit, nochmal diese Sandbox-Problematik anzusprechen, weil die China-Features, die können wir glaube ich mal mit auf die Seite lassen.
Die haben echt All-New-Features-for-China auf der Liste? Das hab ich ja noch gar nicht gesehen.
Demnächst ihr größter Markt, ne?
Na die müssen ja so ein bisschen pleasen jetzt, sonst kriegen sie ihre iPhones nicht zugelassen.
Oder den iPad-Namen und so.
Die haben die beiden Eiern.
Ja, Sandbox, na gut, wurde nochmal verlängert. Witzigerweise scheint der Termin zwischen Sandbox-Verlängerung und Erscheinen von Mountain-Line irgendwie auf den gleichen Tag zu fallen, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab.
Juni. Gibt es für Mountain-Line einen Tag?
Ja, aber es gibt für Mountain-Line noch keine Ankündigung. Es gibt Summer. Und Summer kann ganz schön lange sein.
Also gut, sie haben es 3-4 Monate nach hinten verschoben. Und sie haben etwas gesagt, was ich auch sehr interessant fand. Man kann bei bestehenden Apps noch Updates, Feature, also Bug-Fix-Updates, wo keine neuen Features drin sind, machen, ohne dass man sie Sandboxen muss. Da sind sie jetzt also auch noch einen Millimeter vom Hardline zurückgewichen.
Millimeter? Das ist schon ganz schön weit weg.
Für reine Bug-Fix-Releases? Ja, naja, gut.
Also so oder so. Sie haben mal den Traum gehabt, dass alles, was im App Store ist, in der Sandbox liegt. Und irgendwie scheint sich das nicht durchsetzen zu lassen. Und die Gründe dafür sind vielfältig. Viele Programme gehen irgendwie davon aus, um einfach das, was sie tun, tun zu können, dass sie eben, so wie das immer war, auf alles zugreifen können. Und in dem Moment, wo sie im Sandkasten sitzen, können sie einfach die eigentliche Funktion nicht mehr so anbieten, wie das bisher immer war.
Na ja, die Herangehensweise, die Apple hatte, war ja, der User löst aus durch eine bestimmte Aktion, dass ein bestimmtes Pfeil geöffnet wird über einen Open-Dialog oder über einen Drag-and-Drop. Und dann haben sie sich gedacht, na prima, da schalten wir was dazwischen, was der Applikation dann zu dem Zeitpunkt das Recht gibt, genau auf diese Datei, die da gedragged und dropped oder geopendialogt wurde, zuzugreifen. Jetzt ist es natürlich so, dass sich, so stellte es sich zumindest noch vor einiger Zeit dar, dass das Programm dann dieses Zugriffsrecht wieder verliert. Aber, und ich hatte ja vor einigen Sendungen schon gesagt, die müssen zu 10.7.3 dann nochmal nachbessern. Sie haben es tatsächlich gemacht, aber auch nicht so riesig an die Glocke gehängt, deswegen ist es an mir vorbei gegangen. Man kann tatsächlich diese einmal als Programm erhaltene Erlaubnis auf einen bestimmten Pfad zuzugreifen, irgendwie hintenrum sich wieder einholen.
Ach, jetzt schon?
Ja, das geht schon. Ist aber ein bisschen kompliziert und ich habe auch nicht so genau verstanden, wie es funktioniert. Das muss ich mir nochmal genau angucken.
Aber der klassische Fall ist ja immer so Texteditoren, die wollen irgendwie überall zugreifen, klar. Eine Datei aufmachen, das geht mit dem Ansatz, den sie haben wunderbar, aber wenn du halt jetzt so komplette Ordner miteinander vergleichen willst, hast ja irgendwie so einen fetten Projektordner mit hunderten von Dateien und du suchst halt danach irgendwas, dann geht das halt einfach nicht mit dem Centrum.
Na im Prinzip könntest du den gesamten Ordner ja auf das Programm starten, aufschmeißen und das Programm bekommt Zugriff auf diesen Ordner und alle seine Unterordner.
Ja, aber es könnte auch sein, dass du halt so ein Project-File aufmachst und in dem Project-File steht drin, was zu diesem Project gehört und dann gab es eben diese explizite Interaktion nicht, sondern das Programm meint nur eine Visur, das stand auch hier in dem Project-File, da will ich da jetzt auch drauf zugreifen und dann geht das halt nicht.
So sieht's aus, das ist das Problem.
Ich frage mich, ob das überhaupt ein lösbares Problem ist für Apple. Also, ob sie da überhaupt durchkommen. Ich meine, zweimal verschoben. Wann wollten sie das ursprünglich starten? Anfang 2011 war, glaube ich, der ursprüngliche Traum, irgendwie so was damit loszuleben. Und das haben sie dann verschoben auf Ende des Jahres.
Sie hatten letztes Jahr bei der WWDC gesagt im Herbst 2011.
Das gab es ja erst zu leihen.
Also auf der WWDC 2011 haben sie gesagt Herbst 2011. Und das wurde dann, ich weiß nicht, ob es erst gleich in den Februar oder noch mal kurz vorher verschoben wurde. Ich weiß es nicht.
Es gab, glaube ich, drei Verschiebungen. Es war noch irgendwas ganz Frühes, aber ich kriege das jetzt auch nicht mehr zusammen, wann sie das angekündigt haben. Tatsache ist, für Apple ist das schon enorme Zeiträume und Wiederholungen. Also üblicherweise, wenn sie eine Ansage machen, dann und dann, dann gab es vielleicht mal eine kleine Verzögerung, aber dann ist irgendwie alles aktiv geworden. Aber ich denke, dass sie jetzt auch eingesehen haben, dass ihr Modell, was sie sich so ausgedacht haben, nicht weit genug greift.
Du kannst mal folgendes machen.
Sie warten nicht nur auf die Entwickler, sondern sie bauen, ich vermute das, sie bauen auch noch irgendwas ein, um einfach noch mehr zu ermöglichen.
Du kannst mal Folgendes machen. Geh mal unter Library, Containers. Es ist nämlich so, dass alle Sandboxed Apps bekommen ihre Daten, die sie vorher im Library Application Support und Library Caches und so weiter und an verschiedenen anderen Stellen hatten, in diesen Container-Ordner rein. Und wenn du da guckst, was da in dem Container-Ordner, wie viele Programme da drin sind.
Also du meinst jetzt Library in meinem Home Directory, ne?
Genau, in meinem Home Directory Library, da gibt es einen Ordner, der heißt Containers. Und da sind alle Container drin von allen Apps, die Sandboxed sind.
Das sind bei mir gerade mal fünf.
Bei mir waren es nicht Apple-Programme, als ich zu Hause geguckt hab, glaube ich, nur eins, das war Outbank. Das finde ich sehr, sehr gut, dass sie das gemacht haben, weil das ist genau diese Art von Programm, da will man, dass das ordentlich gesandboxed ist.
Das andere ist Money Money. Und da gibt es aber noch eins, und zwar dieses Buckel, dieser E-Pub-Rider.
Und weißt du, was das bedeutet? Wenn so wenige Programme, die du tatsächlich benutzt, und ich nehme mal an, du hast auch einige aus dem Mac App Store, wenn der Prozentsatz an Programmen, die echt gesandboxed sind, so niedrig ist, dann weiß natürlich auch Apple, wie die Einreichungen im Mac App Store sind. Welcher Prozentsatz an eingereichten Programmen tatsächlich sandboxed ist. Und ich glaube, so wie die meisten Entwickler, die das derzeit machen, also die meisten Entwickler, die ich kenne, die machen das derzeit, die sagen, wir haben noch bis Ende Februar Zeit, ein Update zu machen, was nicht gesandboxed ist, um noch die letzten Features einzubauen, die unter Sandbox nicht gehen. Und dann packen wir das rein und dann machen wir keine Updates mehr. Und ich glaube, alle Entwickler haben das so gemacht. Alle. Ich glaube, alle haben das so gemacht. Und deswegen gab es auch keine Sandboxed Apps. Wenn Apple das jetzt durchgezogen hätte, dann hätte man ab Anfang März die ersten Sandboxed Apps gesehen. Und vielleicht auch lange keine Updates, keine Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, die Entwickler da draußen, die haben alle durch die Bank keinen Bock auf den Scheiß.
Ein Programm hab ich hier noch gefunden, was auf meinem anderen Rechner auch noch in der Sandbox ist. Also es ist nicht viel.
Aber es gibt ja noch eine Sandbox auszusetzen.
Da haben wir ja gerade schon diskutiert.
Es gibt diverse Dinge, die nicht funktionieren. Es gibt so einen sogenannten iMedia Browser. Das ist so ein Ding, dass dir irgendwie Bilder und anderes Zeug aus den diversen Unterordnern, wo sie hingehören, aber auch so aus Aperture und iPhoto und bla bla bla zusammen sortieren. Sowas geht nicht. Wenn du in deiner App, so wie in Garage Sale, da ist halt so ein iMedia Browser drin für all die Bilder, die du irgendwo auf dem Rechner hast, die du dann vielleicht in deinen Auktionen verwenden willst. Wenn du dann diesen iMedia Browser benutzen willst, dann hast du unter der Sandbox einfach mal Pech gehabt. Gut, es gibt jetzt die Einschränkung, bei der Sandbox kannst du den Bilderordner zum Beispiel nehmen. Du kannst auch sagen, ich werde auf den Filmordner zugreifen. Du kannst sagen, ich werde auf den Downloads-Folder zugreifen. Die drei Ordner sind dann ausgenommen und ich glaube, Desktop kannst du irgendwie auch noch haben. Aber ansonsten, wenn die irgendwo anders liegen, die Bilder, also Spotlight geht zum Beispiel überhaupt gar nicht mehr in der Sandbox. Das kannst du dir komplett abschminken. Die gesamte API für Sandbox ist weg. Also du kannst keine Dateien mehr finden als Programm über Spotlight.
Aber ich meine, dafür ist das Sandbox, das ist ja der Sinn des Sandboxing, dass du das nicht mehr kannst. Also ich meine, aus Anwendersicht ist es doch, also ja, es gibt einige Programme.
Warte mal, das hab ich nicht verstanden. Spotlight geht, wie rum geht was jetzt nicht?
Also Spotlight, für Spotlight gibt's eine API, die kann man benutzen.
Als Programm.
Als Programm, ja. Also ein bisschen krasse Brüste.
Gerade so wie Mail das halt macht, um Mail zu finden.
Für Spotlight gibt's eine API, die kannst du als Programm benutzen. Und die geht halt überhaupt nicht mehr. Und auf der Sandbox. Feierabend.
Weil?
Weil Sandbox, keine Ahnung.
Also du kannst ja auch immer noch in deiner eigenen Sandbox suchen.
Bestimmt.
Also Mail könnte ja auch seine Mail in diese Sandbox legen. Dann wär die Mail da drin.
Also hat ein Kollege von mir behauptet. Ich hab's nicht selber ausprobiert, ob jetzt die API überhaupt nicht mehr geht.
Der Zeuge beruft sich auf Hörensagen.
Ja, aber ich meine genau.
Aber guck doch mal bei OSTen-Line hier in diesen Containern, ob da sich was geändert hat, ob zum Beispiel Mail jetzt auch gesandboxt ist oder so. Okay, jetzt hast du Mail hier noch nicht so richtig aufgesetzt, aber vielleicht ist da generell schon mal mehr zu finden. Das wär ja schon mal ganz interessant zu sehen, ob sie da irgendwelche Fortschritte gemacht haben.
Da gibt's Containers, da gibt's...
Dann ist tatsächlich Mail.
Chess ist drin, Facetime ist drin, Game Center, Mail, Notes, Preview, Reminders und Text-Edit.
Lass mich raten, Chess...
Chess ist in der Setbox! Da können die Russen einpacken! Mac ist number one again! Security Master! Ja, die Security-Branche fällt auseinander. Was haben sie da noch? Game Center?
Das Chess war schon immer deren Ausprobieren, oder? Das war auch das erste, das irgendwie mal so Multicore benutzt und irgendein anderes Feature auf.
Notes, Preview, Reminders und Text-Edit.
Wir wissen, es nutzt eh kein Schwein.
Sie benutzen es ja selber nicht zu einem signifikanten Anteil.
Naja, nutzen sie es jetzt vielleicht erst, obwohl der Adressbuch hast du grad offen. Hoffentlich nutzen sie es auch nicht überall.
Gut, das Adressbuch wiederum benutzt ja das entsprechende Framework.
Aber kann man denn mit dem Desktop Spotlight, das was man so benutzt, auch Daten in einer Sandbox finden?
Ja, muss doch, oder? Also sonst ist ja sinnvoll. Sonst ist ja sinnlos.
Natürlich ist es dann sinnlos, aber das ist halt die große Frage. Aber das beantwortet aber zumindest die Frage. Also deine Aussage kann nicht stimmen. Mail muss ja wohl noch in der Lage sein, seine eigenen Mails zu finden. Und natürlich muss man auch in der Lage sein, in dieser Sandbox die Mails dann noch zu finden. Also das geht schon noch.
Es sei denn, sie haben mal wieder das Format geändert, in dem sie es ablegen. Ist das alles in eine große Datenbankpipen?
Ja, keine Ahnung, was jetzt nicht. Da müsstest du mal dein Mail da aufsetzen.
Ziemlich sicher nicht, weil dann würde ja das Backup auch nicht mehr funktionieren. Darum haben sie die Mailboxen ja gerade aufgebrochen für Time Machine.
Habt ihr denn noch andere Gerüchte gehört, was es angeblich in Mountain Line ein tolles neues geben soll?
Ja, ich hab doch noch schöne Sachen.
Ich kann dir sagen, was es tolles nicht mehr geben soll.
Ja, was? Ja, das wollte ich extra noch explizit ansprechen.
Haben sie rausgeschmissen?
Garbage Collection ist deprecated. Und zwar, ich hab mir schon sowas gedacht.
Warte mal, was sie für Snow leppert?
Das war älter.
Wann haben sie das eingeführt?
Leppert, glaub ich. Nee, es war leppert. Das war leppert.
Nicht schon noch älter?
Nee, in 10,4 gab's das nur für die Leute, die genau wussten, was sie tun, weil nämlich die ganzen Libraries, so Foundation und Abwärtsrichtungssystem, die waren schon garbage collected, aber Coco noch nicht als Ganzes.
Aber leppert es auch schon von wann?
Nein, ich hatte mir schon sowas gedacht, dass sowas passieren würde, weil nämlich... Xcode 3.4 haben sie als eins der großen Features mit angegeben. Wahrscheinlich 4.3. Dass es nicht nur ne Möglichkeit gibt, aus altem Retained Release Code Arc Code zu bauen, sondern auch aus garbage collection code Arc Code zu machen.
Wobei man da ja dann eigentlich nicht viel machen muss, oder? Retained Release gibt's ja da eigentlich nicht. Deswegen ist ja genauso wie bei Arc, wo man halt nichts machen muss. Vielleicht müssen ein paar Strongs und Weaks in den Properties einbauen und fertig.
Nah, Strongs und Weaks hast du vorher auch schon gehabt.
Ja, was ist denn anders zwischen Arc und garbage collection?
Du hast keine Autorelease Pools unter garbage collection, sondern du sagst dem Collector, jetzt collecte mal.
Du musst sie nur nicht releasen, sondern drainen.
Ja, das war der Kompatibilitätsmodus für, wenn du Code geschrieben hast, der unter garbage collection.
Also wenn das beides in beidem laufen soll.
Und unter beidem laufen soll. Sonst hast du immer gesagt, hier garbage collector, collect now oder collect deep oder collect this.
Er fliegt jedenfalls raus.
Fliegt jedenfalls raus. Und ich glaube, unter garbage collection konntest du tatsächlich Coco-Objekte als Pointer in C-Strukturen verwenden. Aber da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher. Und dann hast du natürlich noch unterarktes Problem mit Pointer von Core Foundation. Aber es wird sonst jetzt hier wieder Entwickler-Sendung. Das wollen wir nicht.
Doch, das ist cool. Stehen Leute drauf.
Ja, genau. Garbage Collection ist deprecated.
Dann wartet noch was, ist mir gerade aufgefallen. Ich hatte gerade so ein Tool, was hier Dauer lief, wo ich mal meine Prozessliste gucken musste. Und hab festgestellt nebenbei, dass DistCC bei mir noch läuft, obwohl es ja eigentlich mit Xcode 4.3 gar nicht mehr existiert. Das ist dieses Distributed Compiling. Nee, das haben sie mit Xcode 4.3 wirklich abgeschafft, aber anscheinend haben sie das Launchscript entweder vergessen zu deinstallieren oder sie haben es bei Xcode 4.4 heimlich dauerhaft an, aber das gibt's keine Einstellung dafür und kein Nix. Also ich denke mal, sie haben einfach vergessen, das Launchscript zu löschen. Ich hab hier schon gefragt, ob jemand nur ein Xcode 4.3 installiert hat, aber noch nie was älteres, dann könnte der mal gucken. Aber ich denke mal, sie haben es vergessen.
Also ich hatte das vorher abgeschaltet insofern.
Ja, also wer Xcode 4.3 installiert hat und die DisCCs noch rennen, der hat so einfach das Launchscript in System Library, Launch Steam und dann irgendwas mit DisCC löschen.
Jenseits der Developer-Welt, also gibt es noch irgendwelche Neuigkeiten, die sich jetzt dieser Beta-Version schon abzeichnen?
Ja, ein bisschen, was hab ich noch. Aber lass uns kurz in der Developer-Welt noch bleiben. Wir sollten mehr über Kalender reden.
Hast du gesagt.
Das Kalender-Store-Framework heißt jetzt Event-Kit. Und scheint die Reminders und den Kalender als beides zu vereinen. Von der Developer-Seite aus. Vorher hieß das Kalender-Store-Framework.
Aber da waren noch die To-Do's auch drin?
Nee, die To-Do's, ja, die waren da vorher auch drin. Aber diese To-Do's im Kalender-Ding, die waren ja...
Unbrauchbar.
Mindestens.
Aber was ist dann jetzt so anders? Ich meine, wenn es vorher alles ein war...
Das weiß ich nicht, so genau hab ich es mir noch nicht angeguckt. Ich fand es nur erstaunlich, dass sie jetzt das gesamte Framework umbenennen in Event-Kit.
Aber es verhält sich noch so wie das Alte. Es heißt bloß anders oder ist es alles neu?
Es ist im weitestgehend ähnlich, was ich gesehen hab. Wie gesagt, ich hab es mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt. So, was haben wir hier? Was kann ich euch zeigen? Nee, halt. Zu viel Gramm offen. Die Bildschirmschoner.
Es gibt eine neue?
Endlich. Es gibt nicht direkt neue Bildschirmschoner, aber es gibt schöne Bildchen zum Angucken, wie denn der Bildschirmschoner dann aussieht. Ach so, ja, das sind diese...
Diese Composition-Dinger von deiner iPhoto-Library und so.
Die kannte ich vorher noch nicht, oder?
Ja, die gab es auf dem Apple TV. Das sind diese Bildschirmschoner, die es auf dem Apple TV gibt, scheinen es jetzt hier aufzugeben. Gleitende Flächen.
Also sie haben Previews der Screen Saver.
Nur Hauptmonitor.
Nur Hauptmonitor. Ja, den Button gab es aber vorher schon.
Aber es gibt immer noch keine... Warte mal, jetzt müssen wir kurz nachdenken. Es gibt immer noch keinen Shortcut, mit dem man... Oh, jetzt bin ich wieder auf dünnem Eis. Wie war das mit Ctrl-Shift-Eject?
Da wird der Screen gelockt. Da ist kein Screen Saver an.
Es gibt doch jetzt gar keine Eject-Taste mehr hier.
Ja, wie du das dann machst... Escape, glaube ich. Ist nicht so?
Kein Hammer. Man kann bestimmt irgendwie was einstellen.
Wenn man einfach mal seinen Screen locken würde.
Keine Eject-Taste.
Ich hab das einfach so gemacht, dass ich eine aktive Ecke unten links habe. Und wenn ich die aufnachse, dann geht halt der Bildschirmschoner an.
Tja, wie das ohne Eject-Taste geht, weiß ich nicht. Weil das ist ja auch ein Shortcut, der nicht in den System Preferences auftaucht.
Gut, mag sein. Also, ah! Es gibt Nachrichtigungen.
Ja gut, das hatten wir ja schon.
Guck mal bei Keyboard, Shortcuts. Ja, genau da, ne.
Okay, ist immer noch das gleiche auch.
Das ist auch wirklich so furchtbar. Ah, warte mal, ich hatte was.
Verdammt.
Ah, hier. Hier hab ich noch was. Im Sicherheitspanel kann man jetzt... Panel. Kann man jetzt Ortungsdienste an- und ausschalten, einzeln für Programme?
Konnte man hier auch schon.
Ja, das geht auch schon.
Siehst du, es ist wieder so was, wo ich dachte, das wäre neu für Mountain Lion. Ja, es gibt noch was Schönes. Software-Aktualisierung. Na?
Gibt's nicht mehr.
Raten. Was passiert, wenn ich auf jetzt suchen drücke?
Der App Store startet. Ja, Zeit wird.
Die wollen halt immer in den Store locken.
Naja, macht auch Sinn, dass du dafür nur ein Interface hast.
Und er hatte mir tatsächlich auch irgendwie ein Update angezeigt, irgendeine Firmware-Update, aber das habe ich dann nicht.
SMC-Firmware, nicht SMC, hier.
Hier gibt's sogar ein OSX-Update.
Oh, SMC war doch, oder?
Povotre-Ordinateur.
Thunderbolt-Firmware-Update, aber...
Traust du dich nicht?
Da kann ich gleich einen Rechner aus dem Fenster werfen. Ja, okay, ich wohne im Erdgeschoss, aber trotzdem.
Povotre-Ordinateur, warum ist das in Französisch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung. Also, na ja, das ist halt ein Peter. Das sind viele...
Wir machen halt jetzt die Sprachen so location-based. Also, er hat ja Deutsch eingestellt, aber für den Text gab's nicht Deutsch. Er guckt an eine Location, was ist in der Nähe? Ah, Frankreich, da haben wir eine Übersetzung. Alles klar, zack.
Und eine der wirklich auch unsinnigsten Änderungen...
Ach stimmt, das Dashboard... Das Dashboard.
Wenn ich da einen Dashboard-Vidget hinzufügen will, dann bekomme ich so eine schöne iOS.
Besser als vorher da unten.
Vorher muss man da unten durchscrollen. Jetzt ist das hier so über den ganzen Bildschirm. Da oben hat man sogar eine Suchfunktion.
Ja, ist doch super. Das ist großartig.
Vorher dieses unten hier immer durchscrollen, dann so welche Seite, auf welcher Seite ist das jetzt drauf?
Aber die wickeln ja sogar.
Wie auf dem iPhone. Wer benutzt noch das Dashboard eigentlich?
Ich hab's in letzter Zeit mal öfters wieder benutzt.
Ich nutze es nur für eine einzige Sache, und zwar für meine Wetter-App.
Ich benutze es eigentlich immer nur für Wechselkurse.
Ich hab Wechselkurse, ich hab alles.
Und dann hier Regenradar, finde ich immer ganz praktisch, damit man sieht, wo es gerade regnet. Und wie heißt das?
Dieses...
Delivery-Status, wo man sich seine Amazon-Bestellung angucken kann.
Ist das Premium-Grunde bei Amazon?
Nee, ansonsten hab ich nix mehr. Achso, ja, auf meinem Magmini läuft's nicht. Ich hab den einzigen Magmini, auf dem Snow Leopard läuft, auf dem Lion läuft, auf dem Mountain Lion nicht.
Wolltest du nochmal in dieses Audio-Midi-Setup reingehen, damit ich die Hoffnung begraben kann, dass sich da irgendwas verbessert hat? Geh mal da unten auf dieses Plus oder auf diesen Dings.
Hauptgerät erstellen.
Was ist das denn?
Hauptgerät?
Du solltest mal auf Englisch umschreiben.
Ja, da muss man ein bisschen dieses Thema auf Englisch.
Komm mal klar ey.
So ein deutsch-französischen Mix hier, irgendwie deutsch-französische Freundschaft. Hauptgerät erstellen.
Quelle für Clock?
Mach mal Englisch.
SYNC-Sauce wahrscheinlich, damit es halt in Sync ist.
Mach mal Englisch hier.
So, neu starten von Audio-Mini-Dings. Hauptgerät erstellen.
Meinten sie vielleicht?
Das frag ich mich auch.
Was ist das?
Du hast den neuen Simple-Feinde aktiviert.
Das?
Was ist das denn?
Was war denn das?
Der ganze Bildschirm war schwarz und wir haben nur einen riesigen Folder gesehen.
Das sah so aus, als ob da ein Fullscreen-Quicklooks war.
Fullscreen-Quicklooks.
Das wird immer affiger, dieses System.
Audio-Mini-Setup.
Schick mal da nochmal auf dieses Plus, bitte. Hauptgerät heißt das jetzt? Aber es gibt jetzt ein Airplay-Device.
Create Multi-Output-Device.
Das ist auch nichts Neues.
Das ist nichts Neues?
Nein, das ist nichts Neues. Aber Airplay-Device ist was Neues.
Und das Hauptgerät beziehungsweise Aggregate-Device ist auch nichts Neues?
Soll ich da jetzt wirklich... Möchtest du wirklich...
Wir verweisen dich auf Folge...
Geh mal bitte auf Airplay-Device.
Ja, bin ich.
Achso, dann kommt das da oben?
Ja, nicht. Macht doch mal High-DB-Modus, dann sehen wir alle was. Das wär's doch.
Das ist alles, was man da machen kann. Man kann es anlegen und benennen.
Quartz-Debug musste öffnen.
Kann man noch eine Airplay-Device anlegen.
Achso, oder du hast es schon und dann...
Scheinbar schon, nein, scheinbar nicht.
Man kann genau eins anlegen.
Doch, die Platte war auch wieder in der Weile.
Wieder nichts.
Muss ich da irgendwie... Achso, das Quartz-Debug, das muss ich erst mal...
Kein Erfolg.
Kein Erfolg. Quartz-Debug musst du erst starten, da alles aktivieren. Echt, haben sie beim Mountain Lion also immer noch nicht gemacht. Hast keinen Quartz-Debug.
Das wird nur bei entsprechenden Geräten auftauchen, oder?
Wieso hatte ich da letztes Mal schon getestet? Das geht.
Ja, aber dass das in den Einstellungen, in der Systemeinstellung zu sehen ist. Da brauchst du natürlich ein entsprechendes Display dazu, ansonsten macht das ja nicht viel Sinn.
Ich würde auch da sagen, würde das schon Sinn machen.
Aus der Entfernung auf jeden Fall, ja.
Für mich wäre das jetzt hier super. Für alle.
Kannst du Quartz-Debug jetzt über Xcode...
Ich würde ja am liebsten auf Snow Leopard zurückgehen.
Ja, mach doch, dann haben wir unsere Ruhe.
Kann ich aber nicht.
Wieso nicht? Mach doch einfach.
Weil dieser Computer, den ich hier benutze, nicht mit Snow Leopard läuft. Der wurde mit Line ausgeliefert, nein.
Das kann ich bei eBay anbieten. Extra billig, weil läuft nicht mit Snow Leopard. Ja, genau. Man sollte jetzt sicherheitshalber seine alten Geräte mal aufheben, weil es wird ja nur noch schlechter und man muss eventuell später auf die Alten OS zurückgreifen.
Ich traue echt mal am alten R hinterher. Also das vorletzte R war einfach The Computer TM.
Ciao.
Okay, ich hab noch weitere schlechte Nachrichten, wenn wir jetzt mit dem komischen Puma da durch sind. Ich bin so unexcited. Ich meine, üblicherweise gab es immer irgendwas, worauf man sich so ein bisschen freuen kann. Aber hab ich schon wieder irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen, aber es ist alles irgendwie...
Nein, man weiß halt, seit Lion, wo wir uns auf die 100 Features gefreut haben, wo am Ende halt jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Pricklenes dabei war, ist jetzt die Erwartungshaltung...
Ich wollte noch sagen, mein Mcmini läuft ja jetzt nicht mehr mit Mountain Lion. Hab ich mal im App Store geguckt, was es so gibt. Und die Mcminis da, die haben alle kein Laufwerk mehr. Das ist irgendwie an mir vorbeigegangen. Gut, ist jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig, aber wann ist denn das passiert?
Schon länger her. Ich glaub, als die in die kleinen Alu-Gehäuse gegangen sind?
Nee, da gab es schon noch eine Variante.
Ich glaube, es ist auch noch nicht so lange her, dass sie es weggelassen haben. War es nicht erst beim letzten Silent? Ja, Silent war es nicht, aber beim letzten Update?
So, was sind jetzt noch die schlechten Nachrichten?
Ja, ich habe Neuigkeiten vom Apple Store Berlin.
Das ist gar kein Apple Store.
Doch, doch.
Es gibt doch Rolltreppen. Achso, es gibt Rolltreppen.
Nee, die Rolltreppen sind ja weg. Das habe ich ja letztes Mal schon erzählt. Aber es sieht ganz so aus, als ob das Ding nicht im Juli fertig wird.
Mein Gott!
Sondern es wird wohl mindestens bis Mitte September dauern.
Oh, okay, warum?
Und es gibt Leute aus gewöhnlich gut informierten Kreisen, das zu hören, dass es da wohl Probleme gibt mit den Nachbarn.
Weil die Bauarbeiten so laut sind, oder wie?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber die Umbaumaßnahmen sind wohl auch sehr umfangreich.
Hat irgendwelche Patente gültig gemacht für Wände einreißen.
Also abgesehen davon, dass sie wohl noch irgendwie am Fundament da Verstärkungen einbringen müssen.
Du meinst, die haben irgendwie mal die Statik berechnet und dann haben sie gemerkt, oh Gott, hier sind ja irgendwie mehr als 100 Apple User auf einem Quadratmeter und es halten die Kellerwände nicht aus. Die Decke zum Keller. Keine Ahnung.
Also auf jeden Fall sind sie dann noch mit ganz im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes fundamentalen bautechnischen Maßnahmen. Also es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt schon anfangen würden, da das Glas zu wienern, sondern da ist einfach ganz erheblich noch was zu leisten. Und es sieht wohl so aus, als ob sie in diesem alten Kinosaal auch noch so ein Glasdach oder vielleicht sogar eine Kuppel oder so was.
Ja, schon ein Mini-Reichstag.
Aber mal ehrlich, sollten sich die Nachbarn, also Nachbarn meinst du wirklich die Geschäfte daneben oder welche Nachbarn?
Die haben Angst, dass plötzlich zu viele Kunden da sein könnten.
Die sollten noch froh sein, umso früher der Laden aufmacht, umso mehr ist da was los, weil die müssten auch ordentlich Umsatzerhöhungen haben, wenn da andauernd die Hölle los ist.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich hab da keine Ahnung, was da der eigentliche Grund ist, aber es ist wohl so, dass da generell davon ausgegangen wird, dass schon dieser September-Termin optimistisch ist bei dem aktuellen Baufortschritt.
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Jetzt bei Resolution da irgendwo muss es weiter.
Also wir können froh sein, wenn das Ding nächsten Weihnachten offen ist.
Ja, da irgendwo ist ein Resolution-Ding.
Oder auch nicht, vielleicht ist er mit Apple auch schon eh vorbei.
Leute, nicht immer alles da zusammen quatschen.
Sehen wir mal.
Hörer, die verstehen das nicht. Ja, die versuchen sich zu konzentrieren.
Doch.
Wer konzentriert verliert.
Wir machen das ja alles nur für die Hörer.
Das stimmt. Wir haben die letzten zwei Stunden völlig vergessen. So war es auch. Seid ihr noch da? Hallo.
Hörer, winkt mal hier mit der Nadel. 420 Hörer haben wir hier.
Schon alle abgeschüttelt. Gut, da können wir jetzt vielleicht zu was Leichtem kommen.
Genau, kommen wir zu einem leichten Kost. Hättest ja doch noch gewonnen, wa?
Für Android gab es ja zu dem Zeitpunkt das schon sogar.
Hast du diese Meldung auch mal ein bisschen weiter erklickt? Ich hab das nur so sehr oberflächlich.
Ich hab's mir sogar extra gekauft.
Ach, das gibt's schon?
Really? Ja, hier, Photoshop.
Krass.
Photoshop Touch.
Was hast du da für Streifen?
Hat das Histogramme?
Es hat auf jeden Fall einen schönen Freistellmodus. Also so drüber wischen. Es hat einen Zauberstab, es hat Ebenen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Histogramme hat, da müssen wir nochmal gucken. Aber das kann verdammt viel.
Also ich würde sagen, es hat Ebenen, es ist verfügbar. Max, ich erlasse dir auf jeden Fall die Kiste Mate.
Na danke. Aber was sehr lustig ist...
Aber ich zahl dir auch keine.
Das ist auch mal ein okayer Deal. Ich glaube, das Interface sieht exakt so aus wie für Android. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass sie einen komplett eigenen UI-Layer geschrieben haben. Weil wenn man hier zum Beispiel...
Kein Zweifel. Wahrscheinlich in Flash.
Hier gibt es so... Es wird mich nicht wundern. Es gibt hier diese Listen. Und wenn man die so weit scrollt, das verhält sich so alles so nicht iOS-like. Das ist... Adobe. Das ist Adobe. Also ich finde es ansonsten, es hat schöne Features. Man kann eine Menge mit machen. Das scheint relativ schnell zu sein. Ich habe jetzt vorhin noch per Twitter gemeint, dass ich gar nicht so schnell...
Weil das läuft ja wieder nur auf dem iPad 2. Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich auch Flash. Jee, was ist denn das?
Das ist echt gut so, hier mit dem HiDPI-Modus.
Was ist denn das für eine... Bin ich blöd oder... Hucke, guck dir mal das Fontrendering an.
Ups, jetzt hast du es ausgemacht.
Ich habe leider kein Stylus. Ansonsten hätte ich sicherlich mal... Achso, und das ist natürlich, muss man auch echt sagen...
Das nennst du Fontrendering.
Naja, das meine ich halt. Das sieht doch scheiße aus, oder?
Finger zu bedienen ist leider eine totale Katastrophe. Man sieht natürlich nicht...
Womit denn sonst?
Man will ja mit Photoshop pixelgenau arbeiten. Und man sieht halt nicht so genau, wo man hintippt. Also entweder man müsste sich da für so einen Stift kaufen. Wenn man weit genug rein. Oder wenigstens grob. Also ich wollte was freistellen und habe nicht mal... Also mein Finger war halt zu dick, um wirklich damit vernünftig arbeiten zu können. Da müsste ich noch irgendeine Lupenfunktion einbauen oder so. Also es geht definitiv besser. Aber es hat relativ viele... Was ist? Es hat relativ viele Feature und... Und ist ansonsten vom Rendering her relativ schnell. Das ist wie gesagt eine Katastrophe.
Das sieht ein bisschen merkwürdig aus. Ich frage mich halt auch, ob das wirklich jemand so braucht. Also ob das überhaupt für irgendjemand... Ob das irgendjemand für irgendwas wirklich verwenden kann.
Also ich hab mal, ich weiß gar nicht mehr in welchem Podcast, das war in einem dieser 5x5 Podcasts, da hat einer darüber erzählt, wie er sein iPad nutzt und die entsprechenden Grafikfunktionen. Und der macht offensichtlich auch so ein bisschen professionelle Grafik. Und der meinte, naja es kommt natürlich nicht rein, aber das iPad ist das Gerät, was er immer dabei hat. Und das war irgendwie, war er da über Thanksgiving bei seiner Schwester und hatte versprochen, ihr irgendwie ein Foto zu retuschieren. Und darum hat das mal rasch da gemacht. Und er meinte so, naja wahrscheinlich hätte ich es sonst nie gemacht, weil ansonsten hätte ich das Foto gemacht, hätte das mit nach Hause genommen und weißer Teufel und alles kompliziert. Dann hätte ich drei Wochen später und dann hätte ich einen totalen perfektionistischen Anspruch gehabt. Und so hat er sich mal rasch zwei, eine Stunde hingesetzt, hat das ein bisschen aufretuschiert. Die Schwester war glücklich und alle waren zufrieden. Also ich glaube, das nutzen schon Leute. Und so, um mal unterwegs irgendwie ein Foto nachzuretuschieren. Also die legen schon viel Wert so auf Sharing und Facebook und Twitter und sowas. Und dass man so ein Foto noch mal ein bisschen aufbearbeitet, bevor man es zu Facebook reinstellt, ist doch jetzt gar nicht so, also durchaus naheliegend.
Na ja gut, es hat Lea.
Aber das haben sie alle. Prinzessin Lea vor allen Dingen.
Wie gesagt, ich find das Freistellentool ganz gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwer hat. So, also das ist so, dass man so grob mit dem Finger markieren kann, was möchte man gerne, also man wählt den Hintergrund, malt man mal grob mit dem Finger drüber, dann über den Vordergrund malt man mit dem Finger drüber und dann stellt das schon mal ganz gut frei.
Aber es ist sehr inkonsistent, hier ist User Interface zum Beispiel, diese komischen Filter, die da unten so hochkommen, mal hast du da OK, Cancel, dann hast du irgendwie Apply.
Na vor allen Dingen, du kannst, was ich ja sehr schön finde, du kannst diese, oder was heißt sehr schön, du kannst diese einzelnen Paletten ein- und ausblenden, aber das bringt überhaupt nichts, dann hast du einfach eine leere Fläche hinter der Palette. Also das ist so.
Der macht das Bild nicht größer.
Der macht das Bild nicht größer. Aber das Bild wird nicht größer.
Du hast natürlich weniger Klatter, ne?
Ja, aber.
Save Project, save, don't save. Ah, don't save heißt discard.
Echt. Ich kann nie.
Das heißt, du kannst das dann noch nicht mal canceln. Ist ja auch klug.
Nö, sieht es auch nicht aus.
Aber es gibt's!
Ich hab nie überhaupt, dass es ein gutes Interface haben würde.
Ein Grafikprogramm, was hingegen ein ganz cooles Interface hat, gerade für so Touchgeräte, also auf dem Desktop, wenn man ein Grafiktablett hat, wie als auch auf dem iPad, ist ja dieses Sketchbook Pro von Autodesk heißt die Firma mittlerweile, ne?
Fanny hat mir vorhin noch Filterstorm empfohlen, was wohl ganz... das war so...
Warte mal, nicht alles durcheinander. Jetzt hatten wir Photoshop Touch und jetzt haben wir Sketchbook Pro. Wir reden jetzt von iPad.
Das ist aber mehr so eine Malsoftware, ne?
Genau, das ist halt so Malsoftware und die ist aber auf so Touchgeräten, wie gesagt, also Tablets mit Stift oder eben auch ein iPad mit Touch oder Stift, halt das Interface ziemlich cool optimiert, also so bestimmte Workflows, wie man Tools auswählt, wie man die Brush Size ändert, wie man die Opacity ändert, das ist alles so mit so doch sehr naheliegenden Gesten und die Interfaces sind auch ganz liegen und da hast du halt auch Layers und du kannst es halt auch dann nach Photoshop-Files exportieren und hast dann auch im Photoshop-File deine Layers noch drin und so weiter. Und das gibt es halt für Mac und für iPad und es kostet auch auf dem Mac, also als Desktop-Version glaube ich nur 50 Dollar. Also es ist auch echt erschwinglich. Und so als die Reviews im Netz sagen auch so Painter zum Beispiel, was halt eigentlich so die Mutter aller Mal-Programme in Sachen Komplexität und Feature-Reichtum ist. Also da kommt es jetzt natürlich nicht so ganz ran, aber es ist halt wohl schon... Genau, was es nicht für ein iPad gibt. Aber ja, dieses Sketchbook, genau, es gibt es auch als Gratis-Version und was besonders cool ist, für Studenten gibt es diese Autodesk-Software. Komplett alles gratis. Also Sketchbook Pro als iPad und auch als Mac-Applikation durchaus mal eine Anschauung wert, vor allen Dingen wenn man halt ein Malprogramm oder so ein Sketchprogramm halt sucht. Und auf dem iPad leidet es eigentlich auch, wie ich ja schon damals sagte, hauptsächlich darunter, dass selbst wenn du so ein Bamboo-Sticks-Stift hast, dass es halt nicht wirklich präzise genug ist, um da wirklich schön genau zu malen. Aber für Sketschen reicht's allemal. Und wie gesagt, echt ganz coole Brushes auch dabei. Also man sieht schon, dass das schon ganz schick, was wir gegeben haben.
Ja, also so Sketching, denke ich mal, das ist auch so etwas, das passt einfach extrem zum iPad. Dafür ist es eigentlich das richtige Gerät. Und da werden die Karten wieder komplett neu gemischt. Da kommt auf einmal sogar Autodesk, die ja nun bisher wirklich nur im totalen Highend unterwegs waren und will jetzt irgendwie hier auch wieder mitspielen und hat wohl auch ganz gute Karten. Zumindest gegen Photoshop, Touch, was für mich so ein bisschen nach Windows aussieht. Also nach Windows Phone, muss man ja sagen.
Und ja, da gab es irgendwie noch so ein Programm, das habe ich aber schon wieder vergessen. Also naja, egal, aber so das Pendant zum Photoshop als Malprogramm wäre das dann halt.
Ich habe ja vor ein paar Tagen ein Programm gesucht, mit dem man mal so eine technische Zeichnung machen kann. Und da gibt es im App Store ein Autocut-WS heißt das. Was nichts kostet. Und da dachte ich mir, naja, versuchst du das mal nur um feststellen zu müssen, dass damit kann man Autocut-Dokumente editieren, aber man kann keine neuen Autocut-Dokumente anlegen. Hab dementsprechend irgendwie dann auch nur anderthalb Sterne im Review gehabt.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Autocut-WS. Als Tipp in der Hilfe steht, naja, suchen sie sich doch jemanden, der ein echtes Autocut hat und lassen sie sich von dem ein leeres Dokument speichern.
Hier übrigens kam gerade mal ein Chat rein, die Bestätigung. Ja, es handelt sich tatsächlich bei Photoshop Touch um eine R-Applikation. We'll see if this turns out to be a bad move. Ja, kann ich jetzt schon bestätigen. Da muss ich nur das Front-Rendring anschauen. Ich meine, ich hab dieses Programm nicht mal berührt, sondern nur angeguckt und es sah mir sofort aus wie so ein Fremdkörper.
I didn't even touch it.
Jetzt wissen wir auch, warum es eben nicht auf einem normalen iPad läuft. Das ist doch genauso wie mit diesem anderen R-Game, was eigentlich das Markenarium ist.
Was hast du auf dem iPad?
Ja, auf dem iPad 2. Ich hab ja noch kein iPad 2, deswegen kann ich das alles nicht ausprobieren.
Und habt ihr den neuen hippen Desktop Twitter Client ausprobiert?
Osforia?
Osfuria.
Oder Osfuria, oder wie das nochmal heißt? Ja, hab ich ausprobiert.
Also immerhin das Feature, was wir letztens hier noch mit Fevs versucht haben zu erschlagen, dass er dir immer eine Liste deiner Favoriten, sogar glaube ich so, ist das nicht sogar durchsuchbar irgendwie? Nee, durchsuchbar ist es nicht. Na ja, aber immerhin eine Liste deiner Favoriten bieten sie dir da direkt im User-Interface an. Das fand ich ja doch gleich ganz nett. Ansonsten war der jetzt ja auch nicht so spannend. Ich find das hier ein bisschen billig, diese Animation wieder, dieser Verlauf zwischen den Buttons hin und her wechselt.
Also ich find einige Details echt ein bisschen nervig. Also was ich zum Beispiel, woran ich mich sehr gewöhnt habe bei Tweety, ist, dass wenn ich doppelt klicke auf diese, auf meine Timeline, dass er dann ganz nach oben springt in der Timeline. Das macht er nicht, beziehungsweise mit zweimal Apple 1 drücken macht das auch nicht. Es sind schon ein paar schöne Sachen dabei, aber ein paar Sachen...
Aber braucht noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Der braucht noch. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit, eine neue, also eine neue Person DM zu schicken, finde ich zum Beispiel.
Na okay, ich kann in der Zwischenzeit noch vielleicht, wo wir gerade bei Spiele hier waren mit Machinarium, ich kann noch zwei Spiele vielleicht zum Besten geben.
Aber sie haben sein Hassobjekt, dass nämlich Mi vor DM steht, die man selber geschickt hat in der Übersicht. Guck, da steht ja so ein kleines Mi davor. Na damit man auch sieht, dass man selber diese Nachricht geschickt hat und nicht die andere Person. Achso, jetzt muss man wieder ein bisschen näher an Tims Augen ranhalten.
Mi, mi, mi. Mi, mi, mi. Also wenn Tim das Mi sich anguckt, also für Freunde der gepflegten Desktop-Tower-Defense-Spiele. Also auf dem iPad als auch auf dem Browser gibt es eins, das ist echt ganz cool, das heißt Kingdom Rush. Also das ist auch so ein Spiel wahrscheinlich, weiß nicht, ob es nur auf dem iPad 2 läuft, aber das ist echt ein schönes Desktop-Tower-Defense, kann man wie gesagt eben auch im Browser spielen. Und dann, nachdem ich Kingdom Rush durchgezockt hab, hat mir dann auf Twitter gleich jemand das nächste empfohlen und das ist richtig geil gemacht. Also das ist so ein Vorzeigespiel, wie man irgendwie so eine simple Idee, wie so ein Tower-Defense in Anführungszeichen, eine simple Idee mal richtig cool mit Story und so umsetzen. Und das ist Unstoppable Gorg. Das ist, also auf dem iPad, das macht richtig Laune. Also die haben sich da so ein cooles Spielkonzept. Also du verteidigst im Prinzip die Erde gegen Aliens, im Weltraum. Gorg, G-O-R-M-G. Und das sind echt saugeile Videos. Also es ist halt so... Also die haben sich halt richtig Mühe gegeben, so alte schwarz-weiß Science-Fiction-Movie-Geschichten drum herum zu wickeln und die Aliens kommen und irgendwie alles so in News-Shows eingebaut. Und es ist halt 3D, und du kannst halt auch so in diese Planeten-Formation so reinzoomen. Und so ist es richtig cool gemacht. Also es ist schwer, es wird relativ schnell schwer. Da beschweren sich auch einige in den Reviews drüber, aber es ist wirklich verdammt cool gemacht.
Aber so Tower-Defense mal sozusagen auf planetare Dimensionen.
Genau, das heißt...
Da macht das ja auch mal Sinn.
Ja, die kommen halt, die Aliens kommen halt so in komischen Bahnen sozusagen der Erde näher und du musst dann so deine Satelliten in Umlaufbahnen da so hin rotieren, dass die dann...
Rotieren die denn, die Satelliten? Also rotieren die richtig, während die Aliens kommen?
Naja, nee, du machst die sozusagen statt... Also auf diesen Bahnen kannst du sie halt bewegen. Du siehst ja da so ne runden Spots hier, also zumindest, ne? Und da kannst du deine Tower raufsetzen und dann kannst du die rotieren, je nachdem wie die Umlaufbahnen der Aliens gerade oder die Einflugschneise der Aliens gerade ist. Also die bewegen sich jetzt nicht permanent, sondern musst du schon dahin bewegen, aber es ist ganz cool, vor allen Dingen, weil du musst sie dann halt so auf den unterschiedlichen Umlaufbahnen positionieren und dann so ineinander schieben, dass es halt gerade passt für den jeweiligen Gegner und so. Es ist schwer, aber es ist wirklich von der Story und der ganzen Aufmachung und...
Drama.
Das ist großartig. Also so müssen iPad-Spiele sein.
Dann nehmen sie auch gleich erstmal 3,90 Euro für.
Ja, aber ich finde, das haben sie auf jeden Fall verdient. Da hätte ich auch noch mehr für bezahlt.
3,99 ist ja wohl kein Preis.
Eine ganze Schachtel Zigaretten-Alter.
Für so einen Nichts-Raucher schon.
Ja, mit dem Unterschied, dass du diese Zigaretten-Schachtel immer wieder und immer wieder rauchen kannst.
Ja, also und vor allen Dingen bist du da bis Level 40 oder so. Also ich hab's jetzt gerade glaube ich bis Level 9 oder so geschafft und dann war schon ordentlich schwer.
Gab schon ordentlich Stress im Weltall.
Die größte Fehler überhaupt, Spiele schwer zu machen, oder? Ja, ich hab da gestern, meine Kumpel spielen jetzt Diamond Dash. Und da, wenn man nicht mehr weiter spielen kann, dann werden ganz heimlich die Farben getauscht, damit es weitergeht. Ihr Schweine.
Das ist ja das Spiel, was so meine, also die Firma, wo ich gerade arbeite, total abrockt im App Store in der Spiele-Kategorie. Na, ich hab das Backend dafür quasi, also den Server, wo der ganze Scheiß dann gespeichert wird und so weiter, gehackt, aber das Spiel selber natürlich andere gehackt.
Erlang?
Nee, das ist Ruhig.
Achso, kannst du meinem Kumpel nochmal eine Million Gold aufs Konto packen?
Warum ist das kostenlos?
Weil du Gold brauchst zum Zocken.
Nee, du brauchst das nicht. Das Konzept ist halt so, du machst das Spiel auf und hast fünf Leben mehr, dann kannst du fünf mal spielen. Und dann hast du erstmal kein Leben mehr und dann dauert es acht Minuten, bis du dein nächstes Leben kriegst oder du bezahlst halt mal irgendwie, ja, was weiß ich, ein bisschen Geld.
Okay, also jetzt für die kleinen Kinder sozusagen die Kohle aus der Tasche.
Nee, den Mama ist von den kleinen Kindern. Das funktioniert auch erstaunlich gut. Also ich kann nur empfehlen, wenn jemand mal Geld verdienen will im App Store, so geht das, ja.
Okay, aber falls dir jemand irgendwie einen ethischen Job vermitteln möchte, gibt's da vielleicht auch noch wirklich Zeit.
Man kann ja auch kostenlos spielen. Oder man kann auch RUT auf der Datenbank haben.
Kommen wir zu weiteren seriösen Softwareangeboten.
Reckless Racing 2.
Das hab ich mir schon installiert, aber noch nicht gespielt.
Das gab's neulich für 79 Cent, darum hast du es wahrscheinlich auch installiert. Ich hab ja normalerweise für solche Spiele nicht viel übrig. Und wahrscheinlich wird das jetzt jeden, der davon ein bisschen Ahnung hat, sagen, oh Gott, oh Gott, dann fass ich es gar nicht an. Dann habt ihr vermutlich recht. Aber mir macht das echt Spaß. Also so schönes, kleines, immer im Kreisfahrspiel, macht ein bisschen Laune, ist sehr einfach, um es jetzt mal so zu sagen. Also beim zweiten Fahren bin ich direkt Erster geworden, was jetzt nicht so ein gutes Zeichen ist. Aber ja, ist so lustiges im Kreisfahrspiel.
Das finde ich auch immer total verdächtig. Spiele, wo ich gleich gut bin am Anfang.
Spiele, wo ich gut bin, das ist generell...
Das kann nichts taugen, das geht mir ganz genauso. Spiele, wo ich gut bin, solltet ihr nicht kaufen.
Genauso wie ich niemals bei einem Club-Mitglied werden würde, der mich als Mitglied aufnimmt.
Du meinst so wie ein Podcast zum Beispiel?
Das kann nichts taugen.
Keine Podcasts, wo Max dabei ist.
Das kann nichts sein.
Mein scheiß iPhone hat sich schon wieder ausgeschaltet.
Du solltest das mal einschenken.
Ach so, allein installiert jetzt?
Ja, ich wollte es ja hier in Apple Store Berlin tragen. Die entziehen sich ja des Zugriffs hier.
Eine Sache müsst ihr mir noch erklären. Jetzt kam irgendwie vor einer Woche die Meldung rum, dass Samsung sein LCD-Display-Business auslagert. Gleichzeitig haben sie sich gerühmt, dass sie irgendwie, es stand meistens auch in der gleichen Meldung drin, dass sie vor Apple mit ihrem Apple TV als richtigen Fernseher irgendwie keine Angst haben, weil sie angeblich die besten Displays der Welt bauen würden. Und sowieso keiner bessere Fernseher bauen kann, weil sie ja sowieso die besten Displays haben. So, zusammengenommen ergibt es doch keinen Sinn. Also entweder bauen sie die besten Displays und dann räumen sie über den Markt auf und dann müssen sie ihr Display-Business nicht verkaufen.
Aber Displays und Fernseher ist doch ein Unterschied. Sie haben gesagt, sie bauen die besten Fernseher und nicht die besten Displays.
Da ist die Frage, was sie darunter verstehen. Die besten.
Also sie haben sich auf den Interpolations-Modus bezogen, den sie haben, um Bilder hochzurechnen. Ich bezweifle, dass das extrem weit regt.
Die Samsung ist ja jetzt schon die Bude, die vor ein paar Jahren mit diesen super, mega flachen Designs ganz weit vorne war. Ich glaube, da macht denen auch immer noch so recht keiner was vor.
Die Samsung ist krass immer noch.
Also wenn man das jetzt als Kriterium heranzieht.
Was ich mich frage, ist, ob aus dieser ganzen Auslagerei jetzt vielleicht Apple dahinter steckt, wo sie sagen, Display ist das Einzige, was sie Apple noch wirklich in Stückzahlen anbieten können. Und jetzt müssen sie aber die Display-Firma ausgliedern, damit Apple ihnen noch Displays abnimmt, weil der Patentteil von Samsung zu viel Ärger macht.
Also wie kommst du jetzt darauf, dass dieses Ausgliedern, was mit Apple zu tun hat? Das habe ich nicht so ganz verstanden.
Weil es ansonsten auch keinen Sinn macht. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht überinterpretiere ich das auch.
Das kann gut sein. Ich meine, das ist eine Business-Entscheidung. Muss eh keinen Sinn machen. Also gerade wenn es um Ausgliederung und Merger und so weiter geht, das ist ja nicht unbedingt immer ganz nachvollziehbar.
Im gleichen Zug wird ja irgendwie über Samsung geredet. Das wäre so ein Familienunternehmensglomerat, was so erfolgreich ist, weil sie alle irgendwie zusammenhalten. Also keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist diese Display-Abteilung auch...
Ausgliedern heißt ja nicht verkaufen. Das heißt ja nur, dass die businessmäßig eigenständiger sind als in welche konkrete Struktur sie sich jetzt auch immer gewählt haben. Jetzt sind sie wahrscheinlich eine Abteilung von Samsung Tralala Division. Und wenn sie die jetzt halt ausgliedern und ihre eigenen Management-Entscheidungen fällen lassen, gehört es ihnen immer noch. Aber sie hören dann nicht direkt auf die Weisung irgendeiner Division, sondern machen ihre eigenen Entscheidungen.
Sie kommen nur noch vorbei, um die Kohle einzukassieren.
Also das ist halt einfach dann nur noch Ownership und nicht mehr Teil der Kommandostruktur. So interpretiere ich das. Und ich würde das jetzt nicht zwingend auf Apple zurückführen. Vielleicht spielt das eine Rolle, keine Ahnung. Das kann durchaus sein, aber erklären könnte ich das jetzt nicht. Das finde ich jetzt auch nicht so bemerkenswert. Ich meine, wir wollen sich quasi ihre Kunden und ihre Strategie, wie sie diese Kunden bedienen, selber aussuchen wahrscheinlich, weil sie sich einfach in einer Konkurrenzsituation befinden mit anderen Unternehmen wie Sharp. Keine Ahnung.
Die ja angeblich das Display für iPad 3 bauen.
Ja, gut, ich meine, insofern kann es vielleicht auch was damit zu tun haben, dass sie irgendeinen Auftrag nicht bekommen haben, mit dem sie fest gerechnet haben, wie zum Beispiel das. Wobei ich das noch überhaupt nicht als gesichert ansehe, dass es jetzt wirklich so ist. Kann sein, keine Ahnung. Oder gibt es da irgendwelche ganz konkreten...
Also wenn der Apple TV bis zum 7 März...
Dieses iPad 3 Display ist tatsächlich aufgetaucht.
Ich würde sagen, das...
Da gab es wieder irgendwelche...
Das können wir als gegeben haben nehmen.
Ich hab irgendwo gelesen, dass das von Sharp kommt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es von Sharp kommt, aber iFixit hat es in der Hand hatte.
iFixit hat ein Video damit gemacht mit dem Ding.
Ja.
Und die haben das bei sich auch... Sie haben es probiert, ein altes iPad, also ein iPad 2 einzubauen, was nicht ging.
Und sie waren sich sicher, dass das von Sharp ist?
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sicher waren, dass das von Sharp ist. Also sie waren sich relativ... Also da hab ich ehrlich gesagt nicht drauf geachtet, wer der Hersteller von einem Ding war.
Das mit dem Sharp ist eine etwas ältere Meldung gewesen, wo ich es auch nicht so genau wüsste, wo die herkommt. Aber...
Setzen wir mal wieder in den Chat schauen, die wissen wahrscheinlich schon wieder alles besser.
Aber ich würde sagen, da sprach einiges dafür, dass das das iPad 3 Display ist. Also sie haben es ja unter dem Mikroskop gelegt. Haben sie ja damals beim iPhone auch gemacht, beim iPhone 4. Und haben es ja auch deutlich gesehen, dass sie die doppelte Auflösung hatten. Jetzt haben sie das gleiche Spiel nochmal.
Ja, also.
Können wir uns alle auf neue iPads freuen.
Okay, der Chat spricht ja noch was anderes, stand tatsächlich in diesem Bericht auch dabei. Das ist irgendwie nur das LCD-Business, nicht das Display-Business, was sie da ausgelagert haben.
Na, vielleicht wollen sie es langsam abstoßen.
Ja, weil sie irgendwie wohl der Meinung sind, es würde auf Amoled hinauslaufen. Wobei das höre ich schon so lange, dass irgendwelche Dinge auf Amoled hinauslaufen.
Alle außerhalb des Bildbildes nutzen das auch schon massenhaft. Also im Telefon ist das ja nur wirklich massenhaft drinne. Also im jeden besseren.
Ja, aber bei Computerbildschirme ist das überhaupt nirgendswo.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach eine Herstellung ein bisschen teuer, das auf Fläche zu produzieren. Aber dass man ja jetzt schon sagt, okay, das wird es jetzt in den nächsten zwei Jahren werden und wir machen mal eine langfristige Entscheidung.
Gut, das kann sein.
Kein Fehler im Zweifelsfall. Falls es so kommt, natürlich. Sonst macht es einen großer Fehler und wir lachen sie alle aus.
Das können wir eh am besten.
Es ist kein Fehler im Zweifelsfall, außer es ist ein Fehler. Genau.
Ach, über HP kann man ja ein bisschen lachen. Wie doof, dass die nicht ihre PC-Sparte abgestoßen haben.
Wäre es jetzt doch wieder eine gute Entscheidung gewesen?
Ja, ja, die haben weniger Umsatz gemacht als Apple allein mit iPads. Jaja. Also mit komplett ihrer ganzen PC und Workstation, Laptop und alles Abteilung. Und Dale hat sich vorhin gerade, es hat grober jetzt ausgebuddelt, Dale hat vorhin gesagt, dass sie keine PC-Company mehr sind. Sondern? IT-Company.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, die sind auf jeden Fall dick im Education-Bereich und so Server und so. Ja, schon. Die haben ganz viele Rahmenverträge mit vielen Unis. Und also zum Beispiel die UDK. Darf man das jetzt so sagen eigentlich? Warum nicht?
Kommt drauf an, wie dein Vertrag da ist.
Ich hab kein NDA unterschrieben. Also sie haben ja Rahmenverträge mit vielen, ja. Und einer davon ist auf jeden Fall auch mit Dale. Und das haben die mit ganz vielen Unis. Und ich hab jetzt auch zum Beispiel schon das öfteren Dale-Server gekauft da über die Uni und ist auch einwandfrei. Und das machen auch ganz viele andere. Desktops kauft glaube ich vielleicht höchstens, obwohl Desktops werden bestimmt auch noch gekauft, in großen Firmen und so, die jetzt noch nicht so auf den Abfüll gekommen sind. Die kommen bestimmt einfach auch ihre Einrichtungen immer noch bei Dale. Aber...
Bezweifelt ja keiner, dass Desktops noch eine Weile verkauft werden, aber es ist definitiv kein wachsender Markt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich... Also ich würd sagen, Dale ist jetzt auf jeden Fall noch weiter von entfernt oder weiter davon entfernt begraben zu werden als AB vielleicht oder so. Keine Ahnung, aber... Also mir kommt es so vor, als würden die schon noch ganz gut dabei sein. Die machen ja auch coole Displays.
Okay, ein Jahr haben sie noch.
Also die sind jetzt nicht total daneben, so ganz von der Spur runter, sag ich mal.
Ja, aber Dale ist einfach auf keinem einzigen Wachstumsmarkt irgendwie präsent.
Die haben den Trend mit den 5 Zoll-Telefonen haben sie begründet.
Und damals ist sie noch ausgelacht worden dafür.
Und jetzt braucht die plötzlich jeder.
Ich versteh das nicht.
Also ich mein, wie gesagt, ich sag ja nicht, dass es nicht back up geht, aber ich würd denen noch ein bisschen Zeit geben, bevor man sie zu Graben trägt. Also bevor wir hier den 2-Wöchentlichen...
Die schätzt die Geschwindigkeit, mit der es back up geht, nicht ganz so einen wie wir, sondern das ist etwas langsamer.
Es ist noch nicht die Zeit reif, um unseren 2-Wöchentlichen regelmäßigen Dell-Abgesang einzustimmen. Also ich würd vielleicht so auf einmal im Monat bis alle 2 Monate gehen.
Aber sag Tim rechtzeitig Bescheid. Aber jetzt musst du sagen, wir sind keine PC-Company mehr. Da kann man das schon nochmal sagen.
Ja, aber was sind sie denn dann?
IT-Company. Wahrscheinlich wollen sie jetzt ein bisschen in Richtung Services. Woher kommt uns das bekannt vor? Aber sie müssen keine, sie müssen nicht ihr eigenes Tablet-Betriebssystem zugraben tragen. Das ist ja schon mal ein Vorteil.
Gucken wir doch mal, wie es hier Dell so geht hier mit ihren Aktienkursen.
Laufen die schon an die Börse, ja?
Ich glaube, die sind schon ein bisschen länger dabei.
Das ist jetzt nicht besonders exciting hier, was da in den letzten Jahren so passiert ist bei Dell. Das ist im Wesentlichen gefallen. Kennt ihr eigentlich eine gute Quelle, wo man die Quartalsergebnisse aller Firmen nachschlagen kann?
Okay, jetzt hatten wir hier gerade noch...
Ich sehe immer die... Warte mal, hier Financials...
Income Statement Quarterly Balance Sheet Quarterly. Bei Wolfram Alpha kannst du das immer sehr schön gucken. Da kannst du auch Firmen gegeneinander halten.
Wenn ich sagen würde, du hast ein schönes Körper, würdest du es gegen mich halten?
Welcher Film?
Lass mich kurz überlegen, nein.
Sorry, ist der Film.
So schlicht sieht doch der Aktienkurs jetzt noch nicht aus.
Ich möchte diese Schallplatte nicht kaufen, sie ist sehr kratzt.
Ja, also so schlecht.
Mein Luftgießentfahrzeug ist voller Rolle. Aber so schlecht ist der Sketch, das war auch in einem Film.
Also so schlecht ist der Dell Aktienkurs nicht. Also über 5 Jahre haben sie schon verloren, aber es ist in den letzten Jahren doch stabil. Ist stabil jetzt die letzten paar Jahre gewesen.
Stimmt, seit Mitte 2009 hat sich nichts getan.
Das lieben Aktionäre.
Naja, es ist besser als so manch andere Firma.
Aber es ist auch nicht runtergegangen.
Und ihre Quarterly Results und Balance Sheets, die sehen jetzt gar nicht so schlecht aus. Naja, also wie gesagt, so alle zwei Monate können wir jetzt mal Dell auf unseren Radar packen. Und dann mal gucken, was macht eigentlich Dell?
Ich lese ja hin und her, wie man ganz gerne kennt, die OS News. Wenn man Gruber als die eine Balance im Apple-Universum wahrnimmt, dann ist OS News die genaue gegenteilige Seite. Die halten alles hoch, was nicht Apple ist. Und jeder, der da Apple positiv erwähnt, wird gnadenlos niedergebrüllt. Und die freuen sich jetzt ganz furchtbar, weil ein osnews.com Wie, aber dann.com und domain, ja? Und die haben da ausgebildet und haben sich ganz furchtbar gefreut. Also eigentlich ist es ganz lustig, weil man erfährt da so auch was über so total abwegige Betriebssysteme, über die man normalerweise gar nichts mitkriegt, dass die jetzt auch einen Netzwerkstack drin haben in ihrem kleinen Hobby-OS und weiß ja teufel was. Und die haben irgendwo ausgebildet, aber jetzt scheint der Artikel schon wieder weg zu sein, dass irgendein RIM-führender Mitarbeiter ihn mitgeteilt hätte, dass RIM ja drüber nachdenkt, Teile seiner Software Open Source zu machen und wie man da eine Open Source-Strategie fahren könnte. Ja, und da hab ich mir gedacht, ach RIM.
Früher gab's irgendwie, früher war irgendwie mehr Konfetti. Da hatte man irgendwie mehr so Firmen, die alle irgendwie zumindest den Eindruck machen, dass sie irgendwie an der Exciting-Sachen arbeiten. Das fehlt mir irgendwie. Aber ich kann euch mal was ganz Überraschendes... Wann denn?
Wann war das denn?
Na so in den 80ern irgendwie.
In den 80ern, ja ok.
Da war aber auch noch alles exciting.
Guck mal, Großbuch, Kleinbuchstaben.
Guck mal, 64 Kilobyte.
Ok, ich will jetzt hier nicht in alten Sachen... Kann euch noch was anderes...
Guck mal, Kalender, der ewig weit scrollt.
Ja, ich will einen richtigen Computer haben.
Der Tarnet hat mir jetzt noch Laminar empfohlen, hier so als ein Fotobearbeitungsapp auf dem iPad. Das kostet heute nur 79 Cent. Das soll wohl ganz dufte sein.
Ich möchte mal jetzt an diesem Zeitpunkt bekannt geben, dass jede Hoffnung auf strukturierte Kapitelmarken in dieser Folge vollkommen zerstört sind.
Wieso das denn?
Weil ich einfach mit unserer Gesprächskultur passt es nicht zusammen.
Welche Kultur?
Letztes Mal war alles so schön strukturiert, dass es irgendwie funktioniert.
Es war auch eine furchtbar langweilige Sendung. Letztes Mal gab es ja nichts anderes als ZFS.
Ja, aber die war zumindest strukturiert.
Du kannst nur das eine oder das andere haben.
Nee, ich will beides.
Das ist wie das Kapp-Theorien. Für diese neue SPL-Datenmarken.
Das ist das Pot-Theorien.
Genau, das Pot-Theorien. Du kannst nur eins von beiden haben.
Den widerspreche ich. Wenn es nicht geht, ist es einfach ein Mangel an richtigen Werkzeugen.
Es ist tatsächlich auch eine Dreifaltigkeit, weil es hängt auch noch mit der Teilnehmeranzahl zusammen. Wenn du mit Holgi sprichst und durcheinander, dann seid es immer noch nur ihr zwei, die durcheinander sprechen. Dann ist es relativ einfach, dann noch eine sequenzielle...
Vollkommen unmöglich.
Aber Holgi macht doch an Chaos uns vier wett.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Punkt. Ich glaube, es ist immer noch sequenziell abbildbar auf so einem Zeitstrahl, aber... Wenn hier alle drei...
In wievieldimensionalen Raum bitte?
Ja, ich sag nur, aber... Aber vielleicht könnte man das diesmal so ein bisschen so progressiver machen. Jeder, der die Sendung dann hört und irgendwie einen substanziellen Kapitelanfang gefunden hat und den in den Kommentaren postet, so nach dem Motto, ich bin mir sicher, dass an der Stelle was Neues angefangen hat, trage ich das ein, zwei Wochen lang.
Kann man nicht so Links setzen, vor und zurück?
Sieh mich, ich mach das irgendwann alles für uns.
Ich würde ja sagen, so auf Soundcloud hochspielen, die Leute sollen kommentieren an bestimmten Stellen, wo sie finden, was toll ist, und dann kann man das irgendwie, muss man sich da in die AP ranhängen.
Genau, nächstes Jahr wird die Folge dann veröffentlicht.
Dann kann man das dann irgendwie nach und nach wieder reinhauen.
Es geht auch ohne Soundcloud.
Ja, aber da ist es fertig und man braucht nichts mehr zu machen.
Diese Wolken, das ist ein Irrweg sag ich euch.
Die ist fertig und muss nichts mehr zu machen. Da muss ich das immer noch wieder eintragen.
Dieser Wolkenirrweg.
Dann kannst du ja bestimmt, garantiert kann man da die Kommentare irgendwie als Jason sich ziehen und mit dem Nippel durch die Lasche ziehen.
Ich brauch einfach nur Zeit, Titel, fertig. Ganz einfach.
Was ist denn die Postcloud-Ära?
Da mach ich irgendwie Copy-Paste und dann ist es dran. Postcloud.
Lass uns die Postcloud-Ära einläuten.
Ich will endlich wieder einen tollen Computer haben. Ich will endlich wieder einen Computer haben, der mich einfach begeistert und der mich umhaut.
Der dich stolz macht. Mit dem du vor anderen Leuten posen kannst. Wo es nicht peinlich ist, wenn dann plötzlich wieder das nicht funktioniert.
Genau.
Der einfach den Peinlichkeitslevel gegen Null tendieren lässt. Und wie heißt dieser Koeffizient, der einen sexy und attraktiv erscheinen lässt?
George Clooney Koeffizient?
Nicht den Koeffizienten.
So einen Koeffizienten gibt es?
Bettina, du hast zu zucken mit den Schultern.
Intelligenzquotient, das ist mal eine schöne Antwort.
Aber du, ich glaub mit Apple ist es genauso wie mit Antibiotika. Die werden jetzt zu stark eingesetzt und dadurch sind sie verbrannt und helfen nicht mehr.
Du meinst, die sind gegen sich selbst resistent geworden?
Also das heißt, eigentlich muss jetzt Kapitelmarke Ausweg aus der Apple-Krise. Was sind unsere Alternativen?
Genau, wir müssen jetzt Apple beraten. Was können wir tun? Was fehlt?
Nicht auf diese Runde hören!
Da wär ich mir mal nicht so sicher.
Davor hätte ich Angst. Wenn so ein Rechner nach deinen Vorstellungen gebaut wird. Das ist so wie bei Homer, wie bei Simpsons, dieses Auto, das er da enthofft hat.
Also ich meine in gewisser Hinsicht stellvertretend für die gesamte Szene, also ich meine, wenn irgendwas relevant ist, dann sind es doch bitte die Leute, die das am Ende auch benutzen. Weil ich finde, dass jetzt die Ziele von Apple, was so ihre Kontrolle und ihre sonstigen Produkte betrifft, die sind nicht immer hilfreich.
Wenn Tim aufhört zu meckern, das ist ein schlechtes Zeichen, dann seid ihr bald tot.
Du bist doch jetzt nur polemisch und sehst einfach bei Default ab.
Welche Software, die du regelmäßig nutzt, findest du rundweg gut?
Also du bist total zufrieden und findest Mountain Line, wie es sich jetzt am Horizont abzeichnet. Das erfüllt dich einfach mit Wonne.
Ich finde, da sind verdammt viele gute Sachen dabei. Es ist nicht so, dass ich mir nicht mehr vorstellen könnte. Aber ich finde Notifications super. Ich finde dieses Airplay-Mirroring geil. Ich mag Messages schon jetzt. Also dieses einfach jederzeit hin- und herschalten zu können. Da ist noch ein bisschen was optimierungsfähig. Aber ich finde das schon jetzt gut. Obwohl ich vorher gesagt hätte, Messages auf dem Desktop will ich nicht. Jetzt will ich es doch haben. Ich fand da echt sehr viel Gutes dran.
Aber ich fand halt, dieses Snow Leopard, wo sie gesagt haben, hier Scheiß auf den Eyecandy und wir schrubben jetzt mal durch und machen das mal alles schön.
Das war ein Statement.
Das hat mich viel mehr begeistert.
Das Ergebnis war auch top. Also Snow Leopard war einfach poliert und einfach geil. Das hat mich einfach auf nahezu jeder Ebene vollständig glücklich gemacht. Hängt euch doch jetzt nicht immer an den scheiß Kalender. Das langweilt doch genauso, als ob ich da jetzt die ganze Zeit drauf rumreite.
Nein, nein, höchste 5 Sendung.
Allerdings langweilt das mit den Kalendern.
Ich könnte jetzt auch mit anderen Themen kommen, wo ihr genauso hinterher seid. Da sag ich ja auch nichts gegen. Ja, ist gut jetzt.
Wir sind so post Nokia, glaubst du gar nicht.
Ja, ich hab das auch für alles längst ausgeschwitzt.
Also ich finde Mountain Lion jetzt keine signifikante Verschlimmbesserung.
Keine.
Ja, ich meine...
Man hat ja das Gefühl, das sind nur Apps, die sich ändern.
Also ich frage mich ernsthaft, was ist eigentlich anders? Außer, dass es anders heißt, ein paar Sachen so gesplittet sind. Was ist eigentlich anders? Ok, du hast jetzt Game Center. Aber ansonsten mal ehrlich, fällt dir jetzt irgendwas ein? Du gehst so in dich so, ah, ich hab das jetzt alles stundenlang diskutiert. Was ist eigentlich anders? Äh, nichts.
Notification Center?
Ok, aber was macht das anders? Ich hatte vorher Growl, da waren auch Bubbles, ok, schieben sie sich von oben rein und gehen nach rechts, aber was ist anders?
Growl war erträglich, aber Growl war immer schlimm und Growl ist die ganze Zeit über immer schlimmer geworden. Die sind nicht besser geworden, die haben nie ein vernünftiges Interface gemacht.
Warte mal, bis Notification Center kommt.
Die haben sich die letzten drei Jahre nicht bewegt.
Die haben jetzt diese Liste, die aufgeht, wenn du es länger nicht aufmachst.
Die ist schlecht implementiert.
Die ist furchtbar schlecht. Das Feature an sich ist ja durchaus sinnvoll, aber es ist in der, so wie sie es umgesetzt haben, es ist eine fordante Katastrophe.
Wo ist Performance? Lion ist langsamer. Das kann ich einfach bestätigen. Das ist nicht schneller geworden, dieses OS. Jedes OS-Release bis dahin war schneller. Ein bisschen schneller, manchmal deutlich schneller.
Das Persistent Desktop-Zeug war mehr ein Versprechen als eine Einlösung.
Das hat eine Menge Probleme gebracht. Und da wird irgendwie nicht dran gearbeitet. Dieser Fullscreen-Modus, der ist einfach eine Katastrophe. Das ist okay auf einem Bildschirm.
Mountain Lion oder über Lion?
Mountain Lion, wo ist der Unterschied?
Ich sehe halt keinen. Das Fenster wieder aufgeben, da wo sie vorher waren, finde ich großartig.
Machen sie aber nicht.
Guck mal, ob es einen Shortcut für Duplicate gibt.
Aber machen sie den nicht. Sie gehen ja nicht auf dem Desktop auf, wo du sie hinterlassen hast, sondern kommen ja die Fenster zum Beispiel alle auf dem gleichen Desktop.
Ich arbeite nur mit einem Desktop, insofern ist mir das tatsächlich wurscht.
Aber diese Checkbox, die sie jetzt eingeführt haben beim Ausloggen, wo du sagen kannst, alter öffne bloß nicht wieder die Fenster, die war gut.
Genau das will ich haben. Ich will das haben, dass die aufgeben.
War da ein Shortcut drauf? Haben sie die Abfüllschrift S gemacht?
Sag mal, hättest du jetzt nicht bei Lion einfach selber einbauen können? Hättest du jetzt nicht bei Lion einfach selber einbauen können?
Was? Nein, das kann man ja. Das ist ja auch so ein Elend. Diese Shortcuts, da habe ich auch kein Verständnis dafür. Du weißt, wie das funktioniert?
Ja, man gibt den Namen des Menübefehls ein und sagt, welchen Shortcut man haben will.
Und welchen Namen des Menüs gibst du dann ein? Den auf Englisch, den auf Deutsch, Spanisch, Französisch?
Na den, der da steht.
Ja, wenn mal das eine, mal das andere da steht.
Wieso soll es mal das eine oder das andere sein?
Weil das eine Programm auf Deutsch kommt, das andere nicht?
Ich mache das sowieso immer nur für ein Programm, weil ich meine Shortcuts gerne in jedem Programm einzeln kontrolliere.
Genau, aber dann möchtest du halt für Duplicate einen haben und das heißt duplizieren in dem einen und Duplicate in dem anderen. Und dann ändert sich das später mal. In dem anderen Programm ist es irgendwie anders. Ich meine, wie bekloppt kann man nur sein, überhaupt nur auf die Idee zu kommen, den lokalisierten Namen als ID zu nehmen für die Zuweisung eines Shortcuts?
Der User muss doch eine Chance haben, ihn einzutippen.
Apple schafft es ja noch nicht mal zu begreifen. Wobei, ich mach hier mal gleich eine Fußnote, weil ich erinnere mich gerade nicht dran, wo ich es gesehen habe, aber ich weiß, dass da sich irgendwas geändert hat. Aber grundsätzlich besteht dieses Problem seit Jahren. Dass ein Shortcut sich nach der eingestellten Sprache richtet. Aber nicht danach, was du für eine Tastatur hast. Wenn du eine deutsche Tastatur hast, da gibt es einfach keinen Kontroll-Eckige-Klammer zu. Gibt's nicht. Aber du siehst die ganzen Tag Programme, wo das da im Menü drin steht. Er weiß, was da für eine Tastatur dran ist. Aber du kannst nicht ein Tastaturshortcut über die Tastatur definieren, sondern du definierst es über die eingestellte Sprache. Sag mal...
Was? Erlauben?
Was? Ja, ich meine, da geh ich einfach nicht mit. Ich meine, das ist doch das Erste... Das ist doch das... da setzt man sich hin, bei Apple, zwei Programmierer, du lass uns doch mal Tastatur-Shortcuts einbauen.
Ja klar, wie machen wir denn das?
Na, dann würd ich doch mal sagen, wir gucken mal, was für ne Tastatur da ist, und dann macht man so nen Shortcut. lichterlich!
Was ich noch viel schlimmer finde, ist, du steckst ne Tastatur an, und das Betriebssystem weiß nicht, welche Sprache diese Tastatur hat, und stellt dir nicht die richtige Tastaturbelegung für die gerade angesteckte Tastatur ein.
Aber die fragen mich doch am Anfang, drück doch mal die Tastatur.
Das kann er doch wohl selber wissen! Ich meine, da ist ein Tasten drauf.
Gut, es hat wahrscheinlich Intel verbockt, als sie den USB-Standard gemacht haben.
Jeder Computer hat eine Serie, da wird das Teil doch nochmal wissen, was es für Tasten hat, als ob das so ein totales Zufallsding wäre. Schlimm!
Displays wissen ja auch nicht, wie groß sie sind.
Doch, Displays wissen das mittlerweile.
Nicht wie physikalisch groß sie sind.
Achso, haben die das nicht irgendwo gespeichert?
Ich glaube, diese Information könnte es geben.
Ja, könnte es geben, weil sie wird irgendwo benutzt.
Welche Sprache die hat.
Du musst da halt Tasten drücken.
Wenn du die Taste drückst, das ist was, wenn die Tastatur keine Information darüber hat, welches die Aussie hat, dann kriegen sie darüber, ob du jetzt so eine amerikanische oder europäische oder wie auch immer Tastatur hast. Das machen sie über diesen Trick. Das macht der Belgier auch. Das hab ich gerade gestern wieder gehabt. Irgendwie so eine Tastatur, so eine No-Name-Tastatur.
Drücken sie die dritte Taste rechts von der Taste, wo so ein komischer leerer Pfeil drauf ist, das wird so sein, das sind irgendwelche Tastatur-Controller.
Wahrscheinlich weiß die Tastatur selber nicht, also es wäre ihr nicht beizubringen, welche Tasten da oben drauf gemalt sind.
Das ist einfach lächerlich.
Also, welche Linux-Distribution nehmen wir denn jetzt? Da auch voll dich eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit hinaus.
Ich freu mich schon, wenn Tim hier nächstes Mal Ubuntu auf seinem Mac Pro hat.
Nee, Ubuntu ist auch schon wieder viel zu bloated. Die haben nämlich sich an Apple orientiert.
Da machen sie ja alle, das ist ja voll schlimm.
Und dann sind sie halt auch diesen Irrweg in die Berge mitgeritten und jetzt Ubuntu ist schon auch schon viel zu bloated und behäbig und langsam.
Dieser komische neue Desktop von denen ist schon sehr strange. Das hat mich lange Zeit gebraucht, bis ich das erste Programm gestartet hatte. Obwohl das alles damit irgendwie einfacher gehen soll.
Heißt das irgendwie?
Das heißt, ja das heißt irgendwie.
Gnomen 3, glaube ich.
Nee, das heißt nicht Gnomen 3, das heißt Eigen.
Das ist doch der Standard Gnomen 3?
Das ist doch der Standard Gnomen?
Nein, nein, das ist nicht der Standard Gnomen.
Nee, das heißt doch jetzt Unity oder so, ne?
Unity, so war's. Die haben sich ihren eigenen Desktop gebaut, der Unity heißt und der ist gelinde gesagt strange. Oh, da, Unity, Unity, Unity. Der Chat weiß Bescheid.
Ja, da fluchen selbst die eingeschworensten Ubuntu-User über diesen Desktop.
Was ist jetzt an dem so schlimm?
Der ist sehr aufgeräumt, man findet nix.
Ich sag mal so, der sieht ein bisschen so aus, als hätte irgendwie Microsoft versucht, ihr komisches Metro auf Android zu portieren. Und dabei war aber kein Geld für ein Designer da.
Also sieht's aus wie ein typisches Microsoft-Produkt.
Also du hast irgendwie, hast du links so kacheln und in der Mitte...
Nennen wir es das Dock?
Ja, so ein Dock, aber es ist dockt nicht so richtig.
Sieht aus wie dieses, wie hieß es früher in Classic Mac OS, dieses Ding mit dieser Quick Launcher, wo du diese großen Kacheln auch hattest.
Ja genau, oder wie unter Next Step das Dock. So ungefähr sieht das aus. Und in der Mitte hast du dann irgendwie so ein Fenster von dem Programm, was gerade da ist. Und wenn da noch ein zweites Fenster ist, stell dir vor, du hast so Fullscreen, wie beim Mac Fullscreen und dann hast du aber, wenn dann noch ein zweites Fenster offen ist, hast du das vor deinem Fullscreen-Fenster, als wäre das alles irgendwie ganz strange. Also ich hab's...
Oh, nicht so richtig verstanden meinst du? Also ich schau mir gerade so Screenshots an, die sind sehr...
Ja genau, dann haben sie die Apps irgendwie in komische Kategorien gestopft. Und dann suchst du erstmal drei Kategorien ab, bis du deine App gefunden hast und so. Also das ist alles irgendwie so...
Nee, also Ubuntu, ich glaube auch, wenn ich jetzt mal mir einen Linux installieren müsste, weil Apple wirklich zu schlimm geworden ist, dann Ubuntu wär's glaub ich nicht.
Also ich war lange Zeit großer Fan von Ubuntu, vielleicht auch ein bisschen, weil ein Freund von mir bei den Canonical-Jungs arbeitet. Und da hat man natürlich ein freundschaftliches Verhältnis zu dem Laden. Aber dieser neue Desktop, der geht halt einfach nicht.
Tja, und dann gab's ja hier noch so, das gab letztens, da hab ich mir wieder nicht gebookmarked. Es gibt jetzt ja so ein paar neue Linux-Distributionen, die alle mal versuchen, das User-Interface nochmal richtig und wir machen's mal schön. Hab ich aber schon wieder vergessen leider. Wahrscheinlich müssen wir alle zurückgehen, ins Terminal kriechen.
Aber ich meine, mit Gnome war doch irgendwann mal so der Punkt gekommen, wo der Desktop irgendwo angekommen ist, wo man gesagt hat, ja, das kann man auch einfach benutzen, so wie es ist. Da muss man jetzt nicht mehr groß. Und dann ist eine Weile lang nichts passiert, was aber auch nicht schlimm sein muss. Sieht man ja bei Windows, muss ja nicht schlimm sein, dass nichts passiert. Man hat sich halt dran gewöhnt, wie es ist und dann kann man auch damit arbeiten.
Windows wird immer besser.
Und dann kam irgendwie Unity und plötzlich dachtest du so, also ja, ist alles anders, aber nichts besser. Was soll das?
Die sind sozusagen schon weiter als Apple. Bei Apple ist nur ein bisschen was anders, aber nichts besser. Und bei Unity ist alles anders, aber nichts besser. Auch keine Lösung. Tja, was machen wir denn da? Also Windows will ich nicht benutzen, da gibt es kein ordentliches Terminal und so.
Diese Putti geht gar nicht.
Solaris.
Aber soll ich jetzt mal sagen, Solaris hat immerhin noch den Gnome.
Um mal die Brücke zu schlagen.
Ja, vielleicht doch Solaris.
Aber ich erinnere mich irgendwie dran, dass Gnome 3 diese Desktop-Metapher übernommen hat oder eine verdammt ähnliche.
Was, von Unity?
Ja gut, vielleicht.
Lass uns nicht über Linux-User-Interfaces reden.
Das müssen wir in der Zukunft noch oft genug tun.
Lass uns doch mal ganz konkret dieses, man muss ja auch, also meckern ist ja okay, kann man ja mal machen, aber man muss ja auch was besseres vorschlagen können. Schlag vor. Und das ist schwierig. Weiß nicht, es scheint ja wunschfrei zu sein. Ihr nehmt das einfach alles so hin, wie es kommt und so, oh ja, du hast jetzt ein i weniger und so, geil. 29 Euro kauf ich.
Nein, ich kauf das nicht.
Was soll ich sagen, bei mir läuft ja das Leihern.
Du machst deinen Computer an und startest dein Chatprogramm mit deinem Terminal. Fertig.
Also ich brauch halt 50% von diesem Kiki-Fax brauch ich ja auch überhaupt gar nicht. Also zum Beispiel dieses Launch-Mission... Was ist das? Mission-Controller. Never ever used. Ich auch nicht. iCloud hab ich mich nicht einmal eingeloggt.
Schon diese Bewegung, um das Launchpad hinzukriegen, krieg ich schon nicht hin. Weil man dafür Finger ohne Finger-Negel haben muss. So wie Tim.
Ich will halt, was ich vorhin gesagt hab, so ein Basic Mac OS, wo ich bestimmte Clicky-Buntie-Features einfach in den System-Preferences noch dazuklicken kann, wenn ich sie haben will, wie iCloud. Aber per default einfach lasst das weg. Und dann, ja, weiß nicht, die Sachen, die es schon gab, seit Snow Leopard, gerne halt einfach noch weiter verbessern. Also Time Machine ist noch lange nicht perfekt. File Vault könnten sie auch noch beliebig wahrscheinlich weiter tun. Dann hier Filesystem können sie schöner machen.
Also was ich wirklich nach wie vor ganz gut finde, ist diese Art, dass man Programme, wenn einfach beenden kann, und behalten ihren Inhalt, weil sie irgendwie autosafen. Also zumindest bei den Programmen, die es jetzt schon implementiert haben. Also so wie das bei Text-Edit funktioniert, hätte ich jetzt gerne noch in, sagen wir mal, ein halbes, halben Dutzend anderen Programmen, die ich so benutze und die das eben nicht haben.
Ja, mir fallen Programme auch schon sehr unangenehm auf, die das nicht unterstützen.
Die alte Text-Mate-Version.
Da hat man sich verdammt schnell dran gewöhnt.
Sind das bei der neuen Text-Mate-Version anders?
Ja, da geht das automatisch alles wieder auf. Ich find autosaf auch super.
Ja, ich bin eigentlich immer ein großer Freund der Idee des Persistent Desktop gewesen. Und ich finde das auch nicht so schlecht, wie sie es gemacht haben. Es ist halt stellenweise etwas verwirrend. Ja, wenn du dir halt nicht mehr so richtig... Also was ich sehr wichtig finde, ist, wenn man mit Dokumenten arbeitet, ist, dass man einfach ein Gefühl dafür hat, was ist jetzt wirklich der Stand der Dinge. Und autosaf ist natürlich, an der Stelle kann es eine große Hilfe sein, aber es kann eben auch potenziell tödlich sein. Und der knifflige Moment hier ist, eben dieses Öffnen von Dokumenten, wo du dann mal so ein bisschen drin rumfuhrwerkst, aber du eigentlich gar nichts ändern wolltest. Und wenn du das heutzutage safe hinkriegen willst, dann bist du eigentlich gezwungen, sofort nach dem Öffnen diesen Duplicate-Modus zu machen. Ich hab mir jetzt dadurch geholfen, und ich war mir nicht so sicher, ob ich dabei bleibe, aber tatsächlich ist das, und komischerweise muss ich das in diesem Time Machine Setting ändern, dass ich diesen Unlock-Modus auf eine Stunde oder so runter gesetzt habe. Ich muss jetzt noch mal gucken, auf was ich es eigentlich für dich gesetzt habe. Weißt du, wovon ich rede, Roddy?
Wenn das Dokument als gelockt markiert wird.
Genau, und du hast das nämlich in den Time Machine Optionen drin. Warum auch immer.
Also was es da zu suchen hat, das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Du kannst es halt auf ein Jahr setzen oder auf einen Tag. Und ich glaube, bei Default ist es auf einer Woche oder so.
Zwei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen? Genau. Und das habe ich jetzt auf einen Tag gesetzt. Und das hat den Effekt, dass wenn ich eben so Dokumente, an die ich schon immer mal wieder beigehe, was weiß ich, so ein Spreadsheet, wo ich immer mal wieder was eintrage. Das ist bei mir so der typische Fall. So Listen, die ich mitführe, Buchhaltungsklimpen, dieses und jenes. Da kommt so Numbers regelmäßig zum Einsatz. Auch wenn Numbers... Wir müssen aber nochmal eine Sendung nur über iWork machen.
Ja, das ist Katastrophe.
Das ist so langsam.
Das ist mein Lieblings-Anti-Feature von Numbers, muss ich kurz sagen.
Lass mich kurz diese Anlog-Geschichte zu Ende bringen, dann können wir gleich darauf eingehen. Also, ich setze es auf einen Tag. Und jetzt ist es einfach in der Regel so, dass wenn ich diese Dokumente immer öffne, deren Inhalt für mich auch wichtig ist, wo ich mich nicht mal vertun will, wo ich nicht mal eine Spalte überschreiben will bei Accident, jetzt öffne ich die Dinger und in dem Moment, wo ich was reintippen will, kommt erstmal Dialog. Bist du dir sicher, dass du da jetzt reinschreiben willst? Weil es halt automatisch lockt. Und das hilft mir, das zu managen. Und ich würde es fast noch auf eine Stunde runtersitzen, wenn es diese Option gäbe.
Ich finde das ja alles irgendwie tatsächlich eher verwirrend als hilfreich. Also zum Beispiel in OmniGraphel mache ich irgendwie ein Dokument auf und jedes Mal, wenn ich dann nur in diesem Dokument etwas editieren will, dann entsteht da gleich ein Duplicate Version und dann habe ich irgendwie mehrere Versions und dann finde ich nicht mehr die eigentliche, die ich ursprünglich, also ich speicher, also weißt du was, ich mach dann eigentlich zu und will gar nicht speichern, aber ich habe dann trotzdem schon die Duplicate Versions irgendwie rumliegen und dann öffne ich das nächste Mal und kriege jetzt die, die ich eigentlich nicht mehr speichern wollte. Wie hättest du es lieber? Nee, also in dem Fall war der Use-Case, ich wollte eine Datei aufmachen, ein bisschen drin rum scribbeln, aber es nicht speichern. Und es ging halt nicht, also ich konnte nicht drin was machen, weil er sagte mir irgendwie, ja wenn du jetzt was machen willst, musst du dir eine Duplicate machen oder keine Ahnung, oder es sein lassen. Und dann hab ich auf Duplicate geklickt, aber wollte es halt nicht speichern, dann war es aber schon gespeichert und so. So ne Sachen. Also irgendwie hab ich, immer wenn ich so Programme mit diesem Autosave und Versions in der Hand hab, war ich immer in diesem Moment so, was?
Das ist genau der Grund, warum ich dieses Ding auf einen Tag runtergesetzt hab. Weil in dem Moment, wo ich das erste Mal was eintrage, muss ich mich in dem Moment entscheiden. Entweder Unlock, dann ist es so explizit dieses ich will genau diese Datei jetzt verändern und ich habe ein Interesse daran, dass diese Änderung auch erhalten bleibt. Oder eben, was auch der Default ist in dem Moment, Duplicate. Ich will jetzt in einer Kopie davon rum machen, weil das beschützt mich in gewisser Hinsicht auch von dem alten Modell, wo man eben mal so verträumt, rumskribbelt und dann immer so diesen automatischen Safe button macht.
Aber kann er da nicht einfach eine automatische Version davon machen?
Aber ganz ehrlich, ja, wäre auch eine Idee.
Warum muss ich das dann Duplicate oder Unlocken? Mach doch einfach eine Version.
Aber dann muss es auch sehr sichtbar sein, dass das so eine Version ist. Also ich hätte auch gerne mehr so ein, hier hast du Änderungen gemacht, aber die letzte Version, die du explizit gesichert hast, ist anders. Und das wird nicht kommuniziert.
Oder einfach in jedem scheiß Programm hast du so einen Time Slider, wo du dann einfach spontan schnick schnack schnuck zwischen den ganzen Versions mal hin und her springen kannst. Wenn du halt siehst, oh scheiße, das ist jetzt gespeichert, Moment, was war die letzte?
Ja gut, das hast du halt nicht als Slider, sondern in diesem komischen Time Machine, wir fliegen durchs Weltall.
Ja, genau.
Was ich auch schon, das war für mich das erste User Interface, wo ich so gedacht habe, Apple, what the fuck, seid ihr euch sicher, dass ihr das wirklich machen wollt?
Ich dachte auch zuerst, naja, sie machen jetzt ein großes bombastisches User Interface, damit sie was für O und A und Screenshots haben.
Und dann beschweren sich alle und dann kommt es im Release nicht.
Und irgendwann nehmen sie es dann wieder zurück und machen es zu einer arbeitsfähigen Version, aber leider ist dieses Zurücknehmen und zu einer arbeitsfähigen Version machen nie passiert.
Genau, das ist nämlich, das scheint mir auch so ein bisschen das Symptom zu sein.
Und zum Beispiel hier dieses Tool, kennt ihr noch, dieses Kaleidoskop-Tool, womit man auch Bilder-Diffs machen konnte und so weiter, so ein richtig cooler Diff-Viewer auch. Also der gibt es ja immer noch, nicht nur coolen Text-Diffs, sondern auch Bilder.
Wie jetzt im US?
Nee, es ist eine USX-Applikation, Kaleidoskop heißt die, die halt Diffs von verschiedensten Dokumenten machen kann. Und sowas hätte ich halt zum Beispiel auch total gerne in diesem Time Machine Versions-Ding irgendwie, wo du halt irgendwie einfach auch viel besser sehen kannst, was sich da alles geändert hat. Und nicht einfach nur dieses komische Durchskippen von irgendwelchen Snapshots, wo man halt auch nicht genau weiß, was sich jetzt alles geändert hat.
Naja, ich muss sagen, bei so ganz wichtigen Dokumenten, die halte ich dann aber auch tatsächlich in einem Git. Also da weißt du dann explizit, ich habe jetzt das und das geändert, das checke ich dann ein und dann pushe ich das auf den Server und gut ist.
Meinst du, man sollte überhaupt so diese ganze Denke von dem Developer Äh Änderungen so mit Benennung von Versionen und so weiter durchziehen?
Naja, es gab ja irgendwann mal dieses komisches Sparkle Share, was irgendwie so eine Art Dropbox mit Big Git Backend sein sollte. Gibt's immer noch, es ging eine Weile, funktioniert das ganz gut, irgendwann hört das auf zu funktionieren, aber da hatte ich dann das Git Repository für meine Backups schon. Also für meine, hab ich auf verschiedenen Rechnern so wie Dropbox und hab das dann einfach ganz normal unter Git weiterverwendet. Und das macht sich schon ganz gut auch irgendwie. Vor allen Dingen, weil du immer bewusst sagst, ich hab jetzt die und die Änderungen eingefügt, um das und das zu tun. Und lege das bewusst als Revision irgendwo ab und kann das dann auch auf irgendeinen Server pushen und so. Also das finde ich jetzt nicht zu blöd. Das Diffen funktioniert natürlich nur bei Textdateien ordentlich.
Ja, oder du hast halt so ein Kaleidoskop noch da drüber, da kannst du ja dann auch Binary, also die Bilder zumindest diffen. Was auch nicht so viel mit Bildern. Gibt es ja auch bei Github jetzt. Bei Github haben sie jetzt auch das Bilder-Diff.
Echt?
kaleidoskopapp.com Nutzt du die tatsächlich auch, oder? Nee, ich sag nur, dass man halt auch so für dieses Versions, also statt diesem Flug da durch irgendwelche Fenster im Space, könnte man halt, also es gibt halt schon Konzepte auch für irgendwie ein bisschen sinnvollere Document-Diffs, also auch für...
Das müsste ja jeder Developer, der ein document-driven Applikation baut, müsste ja dann auch eine Diff-App für seine App mitbauen, um dann von Betriebssystem gelieferte zwei Dokumente miteinander diffen zu können. Also ich meine, es wäre schön und es wäre ein gutes Konzept. Und ich würde es auch super gern haben, aber ich denke mal, won't happen. Zumindest nicht solange Apple nicht sagt, wir machen das jetzt für iWork, sodass es funktioniert und es richtig geil ist und dass keiner mehr dran vorbei kommt.
Na ja, kann man das denn... Ich meine, wie viele Leute, wie viele Apps unterstützen QuickView und wie viele Programme...
QuickLook, ja ich denke auch, mit QuickLook müsste das auch eigentlich gehen. Weil du kannst ja ein Preview von beiden Versionen machen und dann machst du einfach so einen Slider, so ein Links, Rechts.
Aber wenn du wirklich einen Diff machen willst...
Du hast einfach einen generischen, so einen User-Interface, mit dem du halt Transparenz zwischen den beiden Versionen machen kannst oder halt so einen Scheibenwischer.
Wenn du...
Bei Text geht das nicht.
Was macht man bei Tönen?
Nee, klar, bei Text geht das nicht.
Bei Text geht das nicht.
Und dann hat man Videos oder Musik.
Wie machst du das für Garage Band? Oder für Logic? Naja, aber weißt du, so generell musst du ja denken oder du hast ein CAD-Programm. Du hast zwei Zeichnungen. Willst du natürlich auch wissen, der Teil der Zeichnung ist verschwunden, der Teil ist dazugekommen in Rot und Grün, oder weiß ich nicht. Also es gibt halt keine generelle Art und Weise, wie mache ich das für ein Dokument. Trotzdem wäre es meiner Meinung nach sinnvoll, sowas mal zu machen, weil letzten Endes ist auch ein Workflow über viele Leute verteilen. Egal mit welcher Art von Dokument ich arbeite, will ich eigentlich immer sowas wie eine Versionskontrolle, sowas wie ein Git haben und eine Versionskontrolle funktioniert, aber nur, wenn ich vernünftig in der Lage bin zu diffen. Und aber auch zwei...
Ich werde gerade in der Jungfreiheit zitiert.
Ich sag mal, disparate Versionen auch merging kann. Also wenn ich an CAD-Programm denke, der eine Architekt hat am Bad was geändert und der andere Architekt am Balkon was, dann sind das zwei disparate Änderungen, die ich auch merging können würde, wenn es Software-Gapen darin...
Stimmt dir ja total zu, dass das schwierig ist. Vielleicht noch eine kleine andere Problematik, die irgendwie immer wieder so übersehen wird. Und wenn sich da mal was ändern würde, würden alle jubeln und so, merkt das immer keiner. Funktionstasten. Hat irgendjemand begriffen, worauf Apple eigentlich hinaus will? Also nicht nur, dass sich das Tastatur-Layout von Funktionstasten gefühlt in den letzten fünf Jahren 50-mal verändert hat.
Ja, mit jedem neuen Rechner, oder?
Ja, jedes Mal ist wieder irgendwas anderes. Früher waren das einfach Funktionstasten, die hat keiner benutzt. Dann haben sie gedacht, das benutzt sowieso keiner, dann können wir da mal ein paar irgendwie belegen. Dann kann man so Sachen wie Mirroring einschalten, was es mittlerweile nicht mehr gibt, was ich aber irgendwie total vermisse. Nicht die anderen Sachen, die da drauf sind, abgesehen von lauter und leiser und heller und dunkler, selten genug benutze. Dann haben sie jetzt dieses Exposé, hat sich dann mal wieder gefunden, dann ist alles nach links und rechts gehobst, aber was mich am meisten stört, ist einfach diese Tatsache, dass du, da steht zwar F1 bis F12 drauf, aber ich hab mittlerweile keine Ahnung mehr, wie ich F1 bis F12 definiert auslöse. Weil irgendwie alle Ebenen sind irgendwie belegt. Drückst du so drauf, passiert irgendwas? Ja, aber auch dann passiert teilweise irgendwas.
Ja.
Also, müssen wir jetzt gleich nochmal durchprobieren.
Kommt drauf an, wie du es eingestellt hast.
Na ja, F5 zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt auf F5 so drücke, dann geht bei mir die Tastaturbeleuchtung wird irgendwie geringer. Ja. Drücke ich mit Function F5 da drauf, kommt dieses bekloppte, wie heißt das überhaupt? Launchpad hoch. Naja, wenn die ist. F6, nichts. F7, nichts. F8. F9 ist wiederum dieses, wie heißt das?
Mission Control.
Mission Control. Ich kann aber auch F3 ohne drücken. Kommt auch Mission Control.
F8 startet iTunes.
Ach so, ja das ist Play Pause. Aber ich meine, wieso ist Mission Control zweimal drauf? Ich drücke F3 und ich drücke Function F9. Was heißt denn das jetzt? Heißt es, dass F9 belegt ist? Warum ist F9 belegt?
Dann kannst du doch ändern. Ich will es nichts ändern.
Ja, aber was ist denn jetzt bitte was? Warum ist F9 serienmäßig belegt, wenn dieser Computer mit einer Taste kommt, die sogar draufgemalt hat, was das bedeuten soll?
Geh mal in deine Keyboard Shortcuts und drück mal Restore Default.
F10 macht auch was? F11 macht auch was?
Tim, geh mal in deine Keyboard Shortcuts und drück mal den Taster Restore Default.
F9 Fast Forward macht...
Du hast da eine Doppelbelegung, weil da eventuell noch alte Sachen aufwachen.
Darf ich dir widersprechen?
Also ich hab das gerade gemacht, weil ich hatte Doppelbelegung, jetzt hat er aufgeräumt.
Ich hab hier noch nichts geändert und kann trotzdem mit F9 und F3 die entsprechenden Funktionen auslösen.
Bei mir geht's jetzt mit F9 nicht mehr, nachdem ich einmal aufgeräumt habe.
Was kannst du machen?
Ja, ich kann hier F3 und FN, F9.
Nachdem du Restore Defaults gemacht hast?
Nein, das ist so.
Ja, mach mal Restore Defaults da auf diesem Keyboard. Das hat nämlich bei mir jetzt auch eine Änderung gebracht.
Und jetzt hab ich mit FN, F9 nichts und mit F3...
Na, doch noch was.
Also Jungs, alle mal Restore Defaults drücken und dann kann man frisch sauber anfangen und wenn es dann nicht geht, dann kann man auch noch...
Jetzt schlürzt bestimmt dein Mac auch nicht mehr ab.
Aber...
Wenn's mal so wäre. Also, wenn ich jetzt F12 drücke, dann ist bei mir lauter und wenn ich FN, F12 drücke, kommt dieses bekloppte Dashboard.
Ja, dann schaltet es das auch aus.
FN, F12? Ja, das kommt bei mir auch noch. Und auf F4 aber auch. Ja, das ist bei mir auch noch doppelt belegt.
Also, ich mein...
Kann man aber ausschalten, hier ist es ja auch noch in dem... Ja, die Defaults sind scheiße, diese...
Ja, aber dann muss man es auch... Also, das ist das, was ich meine. Wo ist die Logik? Meiner Meinung nach sollten einfach die Funktionstasten... Also, das Einzige, was ich eigentlich hier umschalten will, ist, drücke ich auf diese Taste, und das war auch irgendwann mal so, ja, wenn ich auf so eine F1-Taste drücke, kommt das, was da so ein Bildchen mir sagt, oder ist das eine F1-Taste? Und wenn das eine F1-Taste ist, dann hat da einfach gar nichts drauf zu sein.
Na, so wie ich das mal verstanden hab, ist das...
Weil das eine Funktionstaste ist. Eine Funktionstaste ist etwas, was ich belege und nicht das Betriebssystem.
Ja, aber Apple hat es ja mal eingeführt, dass halt zuerst das kommt, was die da an Bildchen raufmachen und man das aber einstellen kann, ob man das jetzt über diese Funktion-Taste erst haben will oder nicht.
Dann schalt doch die Funktion-Taste einfach ab und dann macht die die F-Tasten direkt und dann legst du alle einmal frei und dann hast du deine frei belegbaren F-Tasten.
Du hast sozusagen ein umkehrendes Feature.
Eine Tastatureinstellung.
Das gibt es doch da. Oder gab es zumindest mal.
Vielleicht gibt es sie dann nicht mehr.
Das ist neu mit diesem Mountainline. Oder wie hieß? 10.2 gekommen?
Das gibt es schon ganz ewig.
Ich glaube, das gibt es schon seit...
Naja, nicht ganz so lange. Die Funktion-Taste kamen erst ein bisschen später.
Nein, freut euch mal nicht zu früh. Das ist nämlich jetzt gar nicht so...
Diese Doppelbelegung haben wir trotzdem. Das ist schon ein Problem.
Immer noch alles scheiße.
Aber jetzt ist es andersrum, wenn du es andersrum haben möchtest.
Ja, aber jetzt ist F12, passiert nix mehr. Es kommt kein Dashboard. Aber bei F10, und dann muss ich das jetzt auch noch ausschalten.
Schalt das jetzt einfach in den Keyboard-Shortcuts aus, dann ist es gut.
Also da muss Apple auf jeden Fall nochmal nachbessern.
Ja, das kann so nicht weitergehen.
Filesystem besser machen.
Mit Control-Cursor-Down kann man jetzt endlich...
Das ist cool. Local Time Machine Snapshots und dieser ganze Krampel, den sie sich da irgendwie auf dem HFS Plus noch dazu gestrickt haben.
Ich wollte noch sagen, mein Lieblings-Numbers-Unfeature ist folgendes. Wenn man Numbers auf Deutsch benutzt, dann hat man ja als Decimal-Separator das Komma. Was dazu führt, dass man keine CSV-Dateien mehr importieren kann, weil er denkt, das Komma wäre der Decimal-Obseparator bei einer CSV-Datei.
Okay, ich hab's tatsächlich geschafft. Ich dachte, das geht schon gar nicht mehr. Man kann tatsächlich alles ausschalten.
Hier muss man ja auch nur die anderen einschalten, da gibt's noch mehr. Die muss man auch alle restoren. Man muss einmal links durch die Leiste durchgehen, mal überall Restore drücken.
Aber ich hab mir die eigentlich bewusst so ausgerichtet.
Dann soll man die auch so lassen. Aber wenn man erstmal hier mit einem sauberen Default anfangen will...
Ich finde gerade diese Shortcuts, die finde ich eigentlich wirklich gut, weil da kann man wirklich jeden Scheißdreck anpassen. Und so Sachen wie Command-Shift-3, da könnte man mal erzählen, wie es zu Apfel-Shift-3 kam überhaupt. Das waren nämlich mal die F-Keys. Das waren die F-Keys auf dem klassischen Mac OS. Und zwar, da gab es so kleine Erweiterungen, die man sich schreiben konnte in Pascal oder in C. Und die konnte man dann kompilieren in so ein Resource-Format. Und dann hat man das in das System geschmissen und jeweils welche ID es hatte. Also, das Shortcut hat es dann. Apfel Shift 1 bis 0 konnte man dann frei belegen. Und da gab es nämlich ein F-Key für Apfel Shift 3. Das war Bildschirmfoto. Und so ist das passiert. Warum ist Apfel Shift 3 Bildschirmfoto?
Also dieses Ding ist aber auch voll im Arsch. Wenn ich hier in bestimmten, bei Services, zum Beispiel Restore default drücke, dann geht mein System-Preferenz erst mal auf 100% für 10 Sekunden. Und dann dauert es eine Weile.
Da muss er aber auch bei allen Programmen nachfragen, ne?
Kann sein, ja. Also er ist wirklich dann hier, legt dann wirklich los. Keine Ahnung, was der da macht.
Na ja, guck mal, hier sind doch verschiedene Programme, die da angezeigt werden. Wahrscheinlich fragt er bei denen allen nach, welches.
Ja, aber die laufen ja nicht. Da muss er doch wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Dateien durchschreiben.
Na ja, Ressourcen auspacken und gucken, wo das Ding steht.
Gibt es eigentlich noch dieses Keyboard-Programm? Fällt mir jetzt gerade ein. Ihr wisst schon, dieses Programm, was wir anzeigen.
Ja, das ist oben in der… Heute, wir entdecken alte Features.
Man muss irgendwie seinen Computer auch alle paar Jahre wieder mal neu entdecken.
Also du kannst das hier bei Keyboard, Show Keyboard in Character Views in Menubar und dann kannst du es von der Menubar aus wieder…
Ach, da hat es sich versteckt, genau.
Aber dafür ja, genau. Und dann hast du da dieses komische Dingsbums und dann kannst du den Show Keyboard Viewer machen, der jetzt auch mittlerweile angepasst ist an das neue Apple-Tastaturdesign und extrem scheiße aussieht.
Der sieht aber wirklich mal… Aber das Ding sah schon immer scheiße aus, oder?
Dann hast du da plötzlich so ein Kästchen mit so einem…
Okay, alles klar.
Dieser Character Viewer ist auch… Oh, nee, den haben sie ja neu gemacht.
Naja, der hat eine Suchfunktion und alles. Da war ich auch sehr überrascht.
Alle meine Funktionstasten sind jetzt…
So, bei mir ist es jetzt…
Du wolltest ihm gerade noch zu Windows umsteigen. Das sieht erstmal scheiße aus.
Bei mir ist es jetzt weg, dass mein Exposer hier doppelt kommt, weil ich jetzt alle Einzelnen aufgeräumt habe. Also, man muss nochmal ein bisschen Spring Cleaning machen und dann geht das.
Okay, aber jetzt erklärt mir nochmal folgendes.
Wie schalte ich den Computer eigentlich aus?
Das sind einfach die Sachen, die gehen einem dann schnell mal verloren. Also jetzt hab ich diesen Keyboard Viewer, der unfassbar klein ist.
Gibt's den noch?
Ja, den kann man aber auch nicht größer machen.
Da ist er größer, wenn man auf HDPE-Mode.
Diese HDPE-Mode, ich find den voll super. Ich kann da drüben jetzt alles drücken.
Man kann ihn tatsächlich gesize-en. Okay, jetzt ist er auch noch groß. Langsam kommen wir hier dahin. Jetzt kann ich den auch drücken. Aber...
Die Tastatur erforschen mit Tim.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht... Ich mecke gern. Noch lieber entdecke ich, dass ich daneben lag. Das finde ich noch viel toller. Aber jetzt erklärt mir nochmal, warum kann man an diesem Keyboard... Also er visualisiert jetzt mir mein Keyboard. Aber gibt es jetzt auch noch eine Möglichkeit, dass ich sage, sag mir nochmal, was diese Taste jetzt tut. Also ich meine, F6, ich weiß, dass ich jetzt zwar drücken kann, aber...
Was dann alles so passieren könnte, meinst du?
Ja genau, er weiß doch... Ich kann ja überall einstellen. Es wird immer die Frage, wo? Wenn ich jetzt hier Funktion drücke und dann hab ich dieses F6, warum kann er mir an dieser Stelle dann nicht sagen, was dann passiert und noch besser, wo das eingestellt wird? Weil ich hab auch sehr häufig, dass dann so Programme daherkommen.
Weil Apple Evil ist.
Mit ihren Services, das ist überhaupt das Beste, installierst du so ein komisches, düsseliges Programm, was weiß ich, so Omni-Greffel. Und dann belegen die erst mal so irgendwelche Keyboard-Shortcuts. Die schnappen sich dann F2 oder so, oder F5 oder...
Oder Alt-L, das liebe ich ja besonders.
Oder Alt-L oder Command-Alt-Control-Shift-Eject.
Nichts gegen das gute Control-Shift-Eject hier da.
Je olde Control-Shift-Eject.
Aber ihr wisst, was ich meine, ne?
Programme kommen einfach daher und installiert dann über diese Services. Da muss ich nämlich jetzt auch noch mal Spring-Klinik machen hier. Wo war das? Services, da hat sich doch noch nicht auch irgendwas verbessert. Ja, da hat sich irgendwas verbessert. Wir sind der Sache jetzt mal auf der Spur. Du bist der Sache. Ich bin der Sache auf der Spur.
Wir kennen dich schon lange.
Wir packen schon zusammen.
Official Keyboard Investigator Tim Pritlove is looking for clues. Wo war denn das hier? Services, das ist auch mein Feind. Haben wir überhaupt noch Zuhörer? Ist das jetzt auch in die Keyboard rein?
Schalten Sie auch das nächste Mal da ein.
Wenn Tim lernt, mit der Maus umzugehen.
Ah, diesen kleinen Pfeil kann ich auch bewegen.
Hier ist zum Beispiel ein Command-Shift-L ist hier belegt. Das heißt Search with Google.
Ich glaube, das ist von Safari. Ich glaube schon.
Das steht hier aber nicht.
Im Safari kommt die Reader-List bei Command-Shift.
Ja, da steht Search with Google. Das steht da drin. Aber er sagt mir nicht, wer der Meinung ist. Also wer reagiert da drauf? Warum ist das gesetzt? Warum ist das markiert? Warum? Make New Sticky Note.
Was erlaube Shortcut.
Ja hier. Option Shift Command. Und dann irgendwie auch noch mehrere gleich. Ja, also das Betriebssystem verhindert auch nicht, dass eine Taste mehrfach belegt ist.
Die sagen einem hier drin im Services-Menü auch nicht, woher dieses, von welchem Programm die Kürzel jetzt kommen. Ich hab hier einst zum Beispiel, das heißt SMS senden. Keine Ahnung, wer auf meinem Rechen SMS senden will. Oder ich kann Complete Char 1 machen, so what?
Ja, Services auch so eine Ecke, da könnten sie sich austoben.
Die einfach mal absterben lassen, weil, also ich meine, benutzt es jemand?
Das macht nur Ärger.
Ich fände, da sollten sie mal...
Bei mir schallt die regelmäßig komplett ab.
Du warst doch jahrelang großer Freund von dem Services-Menü.
Ich wär davon freuen, wenn es da coole Sachen für geben würde, aber irgendwie ist es alles nur so halbherzig.
Ich soll ein großer Freund von den Services sein, ich hab die Services gehast schon immer.
Kannst du mir den Podcast raussuchen, als Tim dieses Services gelobt hat?
Du wirst nur die Dinger finden, wo ich dieses Tool, was das erste Mal geistige Sanität hergestellt hat, mit dem man diese ganzen Services abschalten konnte, was dann irgendwann wieder nach einem Betriebssystem-Update nicht lief und dann haben sie dieses Kontroll-Panel überhaupt erst nachgeliefert. Lange Zeit konntest du dieses Services noch nicht mal ändern.
Das wurde auch bei MobileMax besprochen.
Ich weiß noch, dass Tim auf jeden Fall noch groß gejammert hat, als die Apps angefangen plötzlich signiert waren und es dann nicht mehr funktionierte.
Ich hab einen Trick gefunden zum Beispiel. Man kann im Services-Menü per Kontrollklick oder auch Kontextklick draufklicken, dann steht da Show & Finder und dann sieht man immerhin das Programm, was diesen Eintrag im Services-Menü gemacht hat. Weil Completure 1 ist nämlich von Git X zum Beispiel.
Dann kann ich gleich mal gucken, was Search with Google ist. Was?
Das hat's bei mir auch nicht gemacht.
Kontroll, was?
Warte, hier, da. So, da.
Was, wie?
Auf dem Text muss man machen, da hinten geht's nicht. Nur auf dem Text. So, und dann Show & Finder und dann geht das Programm auf im Finder, was den Eintrag gemacht hat.
Das geht aber nicht mit allen Einträgen.
Das geht bei mir aber auch nicht.
Nee, bei mir geht das nicht.
Also bei Search with Google gibt's auf jeden Fall nicht.
Confir, Convert, Select, das. Also bei dem geht's jetzt gerade. Ich geh mal auf ein anderes.
Darf ich Tim noch ein bisschen Nahrung geben?
Doch, hier.
Unter Mountain Lion geht's nicht mehr.
Geht was nicht? Das geht hier auch gerade nicht.
Bei mir geht es aber.
Das geht nur bei manchen.
Erstmal anklicken. Man kann es ja auch erstmal anklicken. Und dann? Nee, hier geht's auch nicht. Okay, es geht nicht bei allen. Wahrscheinlich nur da, wo es im Feinden auch was gibt, ne? Das ist furchtbar.
Also ich find die Services prinzipiell ganz großartig, wenn sie mal vernünftig ins System eingelassen werden. Und genau das könnt ihr ja eigentlich mit Sharing dann kommen, mit diesem Sharing-Panel.
Ja, und die SMS will Skype versenden, alles klar. Das geht nur mit Programmen, die man auch hat. Also mit OS-Services geht das nicht.
Das ist Dreck. Ich meine, das ist kein User-Interface. Das ist auch nicht benutzerfreundlich. Das ist einfach Verachtung und Erniedrigung des Benutzers. Sowas. Oder? Amen. Da möchte ich eigentlich, dass Phil Schiller Occupy Mac OS. Ja, der hat einfach, das nächste Mal hier im Podcast aufzutauchen und sich zu entschuldigen. Für sowas, finde ich. Oder hier gleich der Koch.
Bertrand Serlé, der ist ja von uns gegangen. Unter dem war Mac OS noch Mac OS. Wer macht denn das jetzt eigentlich? Wer ist denn jetzt gerade Chief Operating System Dude bei Apple?
Ist das nicht der gleiche, der jetzt auch iOS macht? Den Namen ich schon mal vergesse.
Der hat das eingegliedert bekommen.
Deswegen sieht das jetzt auch alles so aus.
Scott ist glaube ich eine Pfeife eigentlich. Der ist ganz cool.
Der war doch früher auch schon für Mac OS X zuständig bei Next. Der ist doch schon immer von Anfang an dabei gewesen. Der ist von Anfang an bei Next dabei gewesen.
Aber der ist doch Rock'n'Roll der Typ.
Ich finde den alles andere als Rock'n'Roll.
Ich weiß auch nicht immer bei dem Typen, was ich von dem halten soll.
Mit dem würde ich nicht in den Bar gehen einheben.
Der sieht auch so ein bisschen creepy aus.
Nee, mit Bertrand Solet hätte ich das wohl gemacht.
Scott Forstel sieht immer so aus, als ob er da oben so... So ein Rotkäppchen-Revival-Horror-Movie aus Hollywood. Springt er auf einmal so aus dem Wald raus.
Also ich würde schon mit Scott Forstel einen trinken gehen, aber ich würde sehr gut auf meinen Drink aufpassen.
Nee, Bertrand Solé, der war der Chief Pimp auf Execution.
Für Mountain-Dinks oder was?
Hier, dem Miss-Ageur-Logiciel existent pour votre ordinateur.
Drei Sprachen, ein Update.
Neustart erforderlich.
Ich möchte gerne noch mal eine App empfehlen, die ich ganz großartig fand.
Ich möchte gerne noch mal meine Mami grüßen.
Die gibt es fürs iPhone, fürs iPad und haltet euch fest fürs Blackberry Playbook. Nee, das ist echt großartig. Das ist total billig und man braucht es nicht, aber das ist so, wenn man bei irgendwelchen Spielen irgendwelche Zahlen haben will. Und irgendwelche Werte sich merken. Aber das ist echt so grandios gemacht. Das ist was, wenn ich eine neue Person anlege. Jetzt hört man das wahrscheinlich nicht. Dann geht hier so eine Tastatur auf und dann kann ich so eine Farbe auswählen. Jede Farbe hat ein Geräusch. Man hat ja auch so ein kleines Keyboard drin, mit dem man spielen kann. Und das macht einfach Spaß.
Hast du schon erklärt, worzu es gut ist?
Ja, habe ich doch gesagt, um Spielstände sich zu merken.
Spielstände merken. Und dann machst du ein Foto von dem Brett?
Man tippt an, wie viele Punkte jeder hat. Ist jetzt auch nicht so kompliziert.
Welche Spiele spiele ich nicht?
Meine Spiele sind mit der iCloud. Du benutzt das nicht?
Nee, mach ich aber nicht. Ich hab am Wochenende nur drauf rumgeklickt, weil jeder Scheißdreck ist animiert, alles hat wirklich schöne Sounds. Wenn ich hier einen Ton abschalte, hat das eine kleine Animation, die dazu passt.
Was muss man animieren?
Das ist, wenn du was anderes spielst. Du kannst dir einfach nur deine Spielstände merken.
Leute, versetzt euch doch mal in die Lage des Hörers.
Der Armageddon! Simon's Cat ist ja mein Lieblings-Abar.
Unser User-Interface ist nicht mehr gut.
Das hingegen ist sehr lieblos gemacht.
Das ist Simon's Podcast. Das ist ein Dali-Gemälde geworden. Die Uhren zerfließen und Kamelen stehen in der Wüste und fragen, wann die Bar wieder aufmacht.
Weil da Warnung weggeführt ist.
Sind alle verrückt geworden hier?
Alle außer dir, Tim. Ich auch nicht.
Da kommen lauter Geisterfahrer entgegen.
Aber ich sag mal so...
Im Podcast, mobile Macs, Gopi, verschiedene Moderatoren, schräg entgegen.
Bitte fahren Sie auf die Seite, laden Sie Ihre Abrunder und halten Sie sich ruhig.
Was haben die denn in die Joey's-Pitze heute getan? Ich hatte keine. Bei Simon's Cat ist halt die Sache, die Comics sind ja ganz lustig, die YouTube-Videos. Simon's Cat kennt ja alle. Ich hab mir die Abwehr gekauft, um ein bisschen zu supporten.
Die kennen das wahrscheinlich nicht alle. Einmal verlinken bitte auf den Schirm.
Simon's Cat, also sorry, wer Simon's Cat nicht kennt. Raus!
Wozu machen wir denn hier die Sendung?
Meine Showmats sind im Arsch. Ich kann nur hoffen, dass die Hörer wieder gut dabei waren.
Die anderen sind schon schneller.
Ja, ich sehe schon. Ich dachte, wir hören uns erst viel später, die Scheißer.
Ja, die waren trotzdem schneller.
Gibt's eigentlich Vorteile, wenn ich hier herkomme?
Gibt's ein Hörer-Pad? Gibt's ein Hörer-Pad?
Ohne Hörer-Pad-Chat geh ich nicht ins Bett. Sag ich mal so, um mal fettes Brot kurzfristig zu schützieren.
Wir sind einfach die Besten. Wir recherchieren am härtesten. Wir kennen unsere Systeme am besten, am Vollplan. Wir blicken auch immer die gesamte historischen Kontext total.
Wir fräsen uns einfach durch jeden Teil der Tastaturbelegung.
Wir fräsen uns einfach durch alles gnadenlos durch. Diamanten, der Kopf.
Hoffentlich ist es zumindest unterhaltsam.
Warum zeigt der bei dem Kolo die Uhrzeit mit PM an? Das ist ein Scheiß.
Oh, was hat denn... E-Pirat hat hier so schön mit so einer... Ist das die Zeit, die die Sendung schon läuft, die hier oben drin steht?
Na, das ist es nicht.
Da hätte er so ein Link eingebaut. Nee, nee, das ist auch schon bei mir.
Das scheint wohl die Laufzeit zu sein.
Seitdem das Pad erstellt wurde, nicht bei dir, sondern insgesamt.
Ich vermute mal, seitdem die Sendung läuft. Kann man hier irgendwie eine Zeit einbauen? Kann man die aktuelle Zeit so ins Dokument reinklicken lassen?
Ja, wird da gesagt. Im Chat.
Über welchen Button denn? Also wenn ihr da jetzt hier funktionierende Kapitelmarken daraus macht, dann finde ich euch cool. Also ich finde euch eh cool, aber...
Ihr seid dann noch viel coolerer.
Ja, aber jetzt die letzten Stunden scheint es ein bisschen konfus geworden zu sein. Simon's Cat ist da. Funktionstesten gibt es schon Kapitel 1 bis 3. Nee, 1 bis 2.
Aber das Ding hier mit diesem iWork, da müssen wir wirklich mal, also das wirklich auch...
iWork, wollen wir nochmal ein bisschen über iWork abranken? Arbeitest du auch mit Numbers? Wer benutzt Numbers von euch überhaupt? Regelmäßig?
Naja, ich bin nicht so der Tabellen-Kalkulationstyp, aber wenn ich mal eine Tabelle mache, dann mit Numbers.
Weil Schweine langsam kann ich mich nicht erinnern, als ich mal so Stats haben brauchte.
Langsam ist nicht das richtige Wort. Da müssen wir was Neues erfinden. Also ich würde sagen, in schon angedickten Beton zu laufen, entspricht etwa dem Gefühl, dass du hast, wenn deine Tabelle mehr als 2000 Zahlen hat.
2000 hatte ich längst. Ich hatte 50, da ging es schon los. Das ging schon voll in die Knie.
Ja, aber dann bist du so auf Beton-Speed. Bei 2000, da bist du dann sozusagen Beton in Zeitlupe.
Beton in Zeitlupe.
Leicht angedickter Beton in Zeitlupe, das ist Numbers. Ich verstehe nicht, wie die das überhaupt hinbekommen haben, diese Software so langsam zu machen. Also da müssen sie irgendeine neue Technologie erfunden haben. Wahrscheinlich ist das so ein Framework, was noch keiner kennt. Tar Pit Kit. Bei Tar Kit kannst du dann immer, bei jeder Operation, wenn du irgendwie meinst, du kannst jetzt auch eigentlich was Sinnvolles machen, rufst du so...
Na, das ist bei Mountain Lion nicht gesehen, das heißt Slow Core.
Also irgendwie so was müssen wir ja aufrufen, weil es ist einfach unfassbar. Also sogar das Auswählen einer Zelle, bis die Bereitschaft kommt, also bis der Cursor anfängt zu blinken, um dir zu indizieren, dass du jetzt vielleicht etwas eingeben könntest, das dauert dann schon mehrere Sekunden.
Du meinst, die haben das in Flash gemacht?
Darf ich dir kurz was zeigen?
Oder Java ist das noch, alte Java-Scheiße? Das kann doch gar kein Cocoa sein, oder?
Ich muss kurz ausholen. Und zwar in dem Chor, in dem ich singe, wurde, das ist der von der Uni, da wurde ein neuer Leiter, Dirigent musikalischer Leiter gesucht im letzten Semester, weil der alte irgendwie in Ruhe stand gegangen ist. Und dann wurde, das wurde öffentlich ausgeschrieben und da haben sich 280 Leute beworben. Und weil ich da in einem Gremium war, die sich das angeguckt haben, Was ist das für ein Chor?
Hardchor! Okay, go on!
Egal, sei es so, wie der Chor heißt.
280 Bewerber, du hast sie in einer Liste.
Ich hab alle 280 Bewerbungen gelesen. Also wenn ihr Bewerbungstipps braucht.
Für ein Chor?
Egal für was, ich kenn jetzt alle Fehler. Welche Fotos reinlegen und so. Und ich hab eine Liste über alle 280 Bewerber gemacht. In Numbers?
Auf dem iPad.
Du hast dir ein Sternchen gegeben.
Ja, ich hab Sternchen gegeben. Und hab natürlich dann auch gewichtete Noten verteilt.
Noten? So mit kleinen? Naja, so Sternchen von 1-5.
Und wie war die Experience?
Bei nem Chor.
Okay, war besser als mit Stift und Zettel.
Ich hab ja eben auch nur über Numbers geredet, wenn man's normal benutzt. Aber es gibt noch eine extra Entschleunigungsfunktion. Also wenn ja sozusagen die Zeitlupen-Modus im schon angedickten Beton immer noch zu schnell ist.
Also so Trommeln in der Toskana-mäßig. Ja, so Entschleunigen halt.
Ach so, ja genau. Also falls du da einfach das Gefühl hast, dass da auch noch zu viel Energie ist, also zu viel Elektronenbewegung, wenn du das Ganze nochmal so auf 0 Kelvin runterbringen möchtest.
Da wird der Prozess aber schneller, nicht kälter. Äh, egal.
Du weißt schon, was ich meine. Dann hat Apple auch noch in iWork die großartige Funktion Kategorien eingeführt. Die an sich total toll ist. Und wenn ich ehrlich sein soll, der Grund ist, warum ich überhaupt Numbers generell gerne benutze, weil das einfach cool ist. Wenn du so einen Spreadsheet voll hast, dann kannst du halt so dynamisch das Ding neu sortieren nach Kategorien mit Subkategorien. Also sagen wir mal, du hast so eine lange Liste und in jeder Zeile steht irgendwie ein Datum. Dann kannst du halt sagen, okay, sortier mir jetzt mal diese Liste dynamisch nach diesem Datum und zwar in mehreren Kategorie-Ebenen. Und die oberste Kategorie ist dieses Datumsfeld, aber nimm nur das Jahr und dann darunter dann der Monat und so. Und dann kannst du halt so richtig schön mit Disclosure Triangles das irgendwie aufklappen und hast quasi so eine dynamische...
Ich will eben zeigen, aber das hat Axel seit Mitte der 90er.
Ist das genauso bei Axel auch mittlerweile?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es genauso ist, aber ich weiß...
Aber es geht dir dann in die Zellen rein und schreibt dir dann was anderes da rein.
Nein, nein, das sortiert dynamisch. Du sagst oben, mach da jetzt mal hier so eine Zelle draus, dass das alles sortiert ist und filterbar und so. Dann kannst du ja noch filtern und sortieren.
Ich würde sogar behaupten, dass Axel tatsächlich Numbers in jeder Hinsicht, in jeder, überlegen ist.
Naja, außer was das Frontrendering angeht.
Ja, aber ansonsten alles. Also keiner, der ernsthafte Tabellenkalkulation benutzt...
Und Axel ist schnell. Axel ist echt scheiße schnell.
Also ich kann nicht behaupten, mich mit Axel besonders gut auseinandergesetzt zu haben. Ich hab da auch mal mit gearbeitet, aber sowas wie diese Kategorien habe ich da nie gesehen.
Also an Axel kannst du wahrscheinlich... Es ist schwer das zu finden.
Ich kann dir sagen, wie stark Axel genutzt wird. Ich kenn einen, der ist bei Siemens und die nutzen Axel, um die Rentenberechnung von den Siemens-Mitarbeitern zu machen. Also diese Pensionsberechnung oder Rentenberechnung.
Ja klar, bei Funktionen.
Also die programmieren dann Axel und machen alles für alle Mitarbeiter.
Das kann ich toppen. Bei Cargolift, da gab's einen, der in Axel eine Aerodynamikberechnung gemacht hat.
Geschenkt, ich weiß, dass im Bereich von Funktionen und Berechnungen taugt Numbers nichts.
Ich hab schon SQL-Statements in Axel gebaut.
Inakkurat, mega langsam und hat keinen nennenswerten Funktionsvorrat. Das ist gar nicht das Ding. Ich benutze das eigentlich nur, weil ich es so vom User-Interface her und mit diesen Kategorien cool finde. Ich mag das, dass du ein Spreadsheet, das ich sagen kann, das hat jetzt auch nur 5 Zeilen. Und das es nicht immer so in die Unendlichkeit durchscrollt. Und überall kann irgendwo was stehen. Du kannst halt diesem Spreadsheet einfach sagen, du bist jetzt einfach mal genau 3 Spalten breit und irgendwie 5 Rows lang.
Ich bin auch schon 3 Spalten breit.
Mehr Dimension hast du nicht. Das finde ich gut und ich mag diese Kategorien. Wären sie bloß nicht so furchtbar langsam. Also der Geschwindigkeitseinbruch, wenn du große Dokumente, wo schon das normale Einfügen von neuen Informationen, einfach mehrere Sekunden dauert pro Feld. Also nur die Bereitschaft, dass ich was eingeben kann. Wenn du dann was eingegeben hast, dauert es natürlich auch nochmal. Und das auch auf so einem 16-Core-Mac Pro.
Also das macht auch keinen Unterschied.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch iWork. Aber dann kommen diese Kategorien dazu. Und du schaltest sie irgendwie ein auf so ein 2000-Zahlen-Dokument. Und dann dauert es mehrere Minuten. Mehrere Minuten, bis er das dann so anzeigt. Und wenn du das dann so anzeigt, wo du dann gedacht hast, ah, wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht einschalten, glaubt man nicht, dass du das irgendwie unterbrechen könntest oder sonst irgendwas. Nee, dann nimmst du es wieder raus. Und es dauert dann auch mehrere Minuten, diese Ansicht wieder zu verlassen. Also einfach nur die Zeilen so anzuzeigen, wie sie sowieso in dem Dokument sind. Unfassbar. Also dieses Slow-Target, das ist etwas, das müssten sie eigentlich in Mountain-Lighten bringen. Das wäre eine Revolution. Das macht ihnen keiner nach. Das schafft noch nicht mal Microsoft.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja auch iWork 09. Wir gucken nochmal kurz auf den Kalender. Schauen wir nochmal kurz aufs Datum. Und stellen fest, es hat sich auch drei Jahre schon nichts mehr an diesem iWork getan. Das sieht man ihm auch an, einfach in jeder Ecke.
Doch, wir haben iCloud nachgerissen.
Normalerweise werden doch Programme, an denen niemand was tut, schneller, weil die Rechner schneller werden.
Ja, das ist aber auch nicht der Fall.
Nein, weil da haben sie echt visionär gearbeitet und haben einfach mit diesem Target dafür gesorgt, dass auch alle Chores einfach saturiert werden, egal...
Nee, da wirkt es gar nicht. Da wird nur gewartet.
Achso, da wird nur gewartet.
Dann hättest du ja noch das Gefühl, es würde irgendwas sinnvolles getan werden, aber es ist ja auch wichtig, dass der Frustrationspegel des Users dabei auch permanent mit angehoben wird. Und ich glaube auch, dass sie die Jahreszahl einfach immer mit draufrechnen. Also wenn du das in 2014 benutzt, die selbe Software, ist sie einfach nochmal langsamer, weil sie einfach alles nochmal mit dem Faktor der Jahreszahl verlangsamen.
Irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, als ich jetzt mal wieder so iWork geklickt hab, dass ich das auch genauso scheiße klickt wie Klarisworks damals auf Mac OS Classic. Das war so in etwa mittlerweile auch das gleiche, man will auch gar nicht so richtig, auch dieses Kustomisierung, mal ein Template machen, ein Keynote oder ein Pages und so, das ist alles auch so.
Pages ist da ganz schlimm. Numbers finde ich okay-isch.
Pages geht gar nicht.
Ich wüsste nicht, wofür ich Pages benutzen soll.
Ich wüsste wofür, aber ich weiß, dass es fast für alles vollkommen unbenutzbar ist. Und zwar, weil sie ein paar ganz elementare, generelle Fehler machen. Und manches ist so schlecht, dass ich gar nicht drüber nachdenken will.
Was es peinlich ist, dass da ein Abbild noch drauf ist.
Ich schreib meine Texte in meinen Text-Edit.
Ich bin ein bisschen auf IR. Writer gekommen, das könnte man auch nochmal empfehlen.
Alles ist besser als Pages in jedem Fall. Aber das finde ich auch echt erstaunlich, dass sie das jetzt schon so lange vor sich hingammeln lassen. Es ist ja auch nicht so, als wären die anderen Programme so tausendmal besser und es lohnt sich jetzt gar nicht dagegen anzurennen. Sondern eigentlich hofft man ja die ganze Zeit darauf, dass Apple das in die Hand nimmt und jetzt mal ordentlich macht. Aber sie machen es halt.
Vor allem der Typing-Speed bei Textverarbeitungsprogrammen ist bei mir der effektive Typing-Speed. Die Geschwindigkeit, in der du real deinen Text in ein Word-Processing-Programm eingeben kannst, mit der ganzen Reaktionszeit des Betriebssystems und all dem, ist gefühlt seit meiner ersten Software, nämlich VisaWrite auf dem C64, seitdem nur langsamer geworden. Also erst kam VisaWrite, das war relativ zügig. Dann habe ich lange Zeit mit Framemaker gearbeitet. Das war langsamer. Allerdings war das für mich persönlich der Höhepunkt des Word-Processing in meinem gesamten Leben. Das ist seitdem nur noch schlechter geworden. Und zwar kontinuierlich. Und seitdem geht es einfach nur noch bergab. Und Pages ist die Speerspitze. Auf einem Computer, der 10.000 Mal so schnell ist, dauert es einfach noch mal 5 Mal so lange, den Text einzugeben.
Mein Höhepunkt im Word-Processing war eindeutig irgendwie PDF-Latech mit Ultra-Edit auf Windows damals. Das ging wirklich flott.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Höhepunkte des Word-Processing. Da ging aber auch dieses jetzt mal Dokument einmal durchwursten und Anzeigen irgendwie schneller als ein Wort tippen unter Word.
Dabei hat man seine Texte noch kompiliert.
Ja, eben.
Und das fehlt auch. Aber die ganze Logik bei Pages ist vollkommen bekloppt. Also allein schon diese Entscheidung, diese Formatierungsvorlagen in ihrer eigenen Formatierung anzuzeigen, dafür möchte ich eigentlich schon zum Serienmörder werden. Und zwar in Cupertino. Weil das geht einfach gar nicht. Das sieht also scheiße aus. Und du verfängst dich einfach die ganze Zeit. Die ganze Zeit hast du Ablenkungen. Die ganze Zeit nimmt die ganze Konzentration von deinem Text weg. Aber was halt noch viel schlimmer ist, ist, dass du einfach gar keine Logik hast in diesem ganzen Ding. Du legst da irgendwelche Vorlagen an, aber du hast keine korrekte Vererbung in diesem ganzen Scheiß. Vererbung ist einfach die Kernfunktionalität eines guten Textverarbeitungsprogramms und das wird einfach durchgehend missachtet. Fast überall.
Also ich hab ja tatsächlich auch jetzt so mein Textworkflow im Jahre 2012. Das ist ja Texteditor. Entweder hier sowas wie ER Writer oder sonst was, wo richtig alles plain weg ist, damit man sich auf den Text fokussiert. Und dann nehme ich den und pastee den nach InDesign, wo ich dann so das Layout so fein granuliert mir aus Klamüsern kann, immerhin mit Klick-Oberfläche statt, mit Kompilat. Und dann habe ich das halt so einmal auch nicht gesetzt. Da gibt es halt auch eben diese ganzen Typesetting und Formatierungs- und Vererbungsfeatures. Aber das ist so gerade mein Workflow, mit dem ich persönlich jetzt auch nicht super glücklich bin. Aber das ist zumindest das, wo man noch so am ehesten zu dem kommt, was man dann am Ende auch raushaben will. Vor allen Dingen, wo man halt auch tatsächlich die volle Kontrolle darüber hat, wie es dann am Ende aussieht. Weil bei Pages geht das halt.
Aber da versteht man auch, warum dieser Gruber sich dieses Markdown ausgedacht hat. Weil das ist eigentlich auch total geil.
Das heb ich recht gut, muss ich auch sagen.
Du tippst deinen Text runter und dann hast du irgendwie noch drei, vier Zeichen für eine Überschrift und irgendwie einen Blogquote und fertig ist die Laube.
Das geht für diesen IR-Writer echt super, weil der rückt auch den Text ein. Und wenn du eine Überschrift machst, dann sieht das auch alles vernünftig aus. Nicht zu übertrieben, sieht nicht irgendwie formatiert aus, sondern ist noch sehr, sehr einfach. Man erkennt es alles sofort wieder, man wird nicht abgelenkt.
Hat aber keinen Outliner. Du legst dich halt immer auf deine Hierarchien fest. Und wenn du nachträglich was erinnern willst, musst du es halt überall erinnern.
Aber ist ja ein Textprogramm.
Naja, es ist ein Textprogramm. Also was einigermaßen schön ist...
Ich hab früher ganz viele Dokumentationen geschrieben. Ich hab mich eine Zeit lang im Wesentlichen davon ernährt, Dokumentationen zu schreiben. Ja, und gute Dokumentationen. Also ich sag nicht, ich hab die besten Dokumentationen geschrieben. Das hab ich bestimmt nicht gemacht, weil ich war eigentlich noch relativ frisch, aber ich hab mich zumindest bemüht.
Vielleicht hat ja einer der Hörer, kann das nochmal ausbuddeln.
Nee, das war immer so vor Ort. Software wurde geschrieben und ich hab dann parallel mit meinem Mac daneben gesessen und hab irgendwie quasi in Realtime, während die Software entwickelt wurde, die Doku dazu gemacht. Also ich hab irgendwie, gab ne Änderung, zack bumm, gleich Screenshot gemacht, zack bumm, rein, irgendwie mit Trainmaker. Genau. Ja und das war die Traumkonstellation. Ich bin mit dem Macintosh 2Ci und mit so nem QMS PS410 laserbreit da durch die Gegend gezogen. Das passt da irgendwie locker in ein Auto. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das so ein Laptop-Feeling war oder so.
Das war doch der kompakte Mensch.
Ich konnte mich aber relativ mobil damit bewegen, hab irgendwie das Ding hingestellt, hatte ein komplettes Desktop-Publishing-System am Start. Und das halt Anfang der 90er Jahre. Das war, die Leute, die das gesehen haben, wussten nicht, wo sie waren. Das war Visivic mit Drag und Drop und Copy und Paste.
Drag und Drop!
Trachen und Drop.
Naja, aber das hat damals wirklich funktioniert und FrameMaker ist einfach eine hervorragende Software für technische Dokumentation. Weil sie einfach komplett logisch ist und weil du damit Dinge machen konntest, die ich einfach heute noch in anderen Programmen vermisse. Und es war vor allem schnell. Also auf so einem 68.020er...
Der CI hat den 30er.
Richtig, 68.030 mit... Was hat der da? 16 MHz?
Entweder am 20er Bereich oder 32.
Also hier wird dir gerade empfohlen, du solltest dir mal dieses Skrivina angucken.
Hier guck mal, es gibt eine Windows Version. Das kann Tim doch nicht gefallen.
Nee, sieht nicht gut aus.
Aber es ist 25 MHz.
Genau, 25 MHz, 68.030 Büchse. Und ich hatte eine 100-seitige Dokumentation in diesem Teil mit Bildern, also so mit Screenshots, die da irgendwie im Text verankert waren. Und Travel-Time von Seite 1 bis Seite 100 unter einer Sekunde. Das kenne ich gar nicht von heutigen Systemen. Das ist einfach... Du musst immer den Speed übersetzen im Kopf von diesem System. Wie viel schneller die Computer heutzutage sind. Also ich meine hier so ein Vierfach Xeon, was habe ich hier, 8-Core, virtuelle 16-Core, Xeon, mit hast du nicht gesehen, wie viel Gigabyte. Dieses Gerät ist doch technisch betrachtet tausendmal so schnell wie dieser Computer.
Aber sowas wie, wenn du einen Text-Editor nimmst, sowas wie Sublime Text oder MacWim oder was auch immer, die sind ja schon sehr schnell.
Ich rede aber nicht von einem Text-Editor, ich rede von einem Word-Prozessor, der Bilder hat, der Inhaltsverzeichnisse, Fußnoten.
Hatte der andere dieses alte Ding auch Bilder und so? Also, was du da in den 90ern benutzt hast?
Jaja, FrameMaker war Visivic-Editor. Also es war jetzt nicht so genau das exakt so. Es war halt noch mit Quickdraw versus Postscript und so weiter. Und da gab es auch immer mal ein paar kleinere Glitches, aber die bewegten sich wirklich im Bereich, wo es überhaupt gar kein Problem war. Und die Software war schnell, die Software war zuverlässig, da stürzte irgendwie nichts ab, es war akkurat, es konnte rumlauten.
Ich glaube, du musstest nochmal ransetzen an so ein Ding. Du hast jetzt noch in Erinnerung, dass es halt damals schnell war. Wenn du jetzt da dransitzt, dann merkst du schon, dass das alles ganz schön scheiße langsam ist. Das war schnell.
Nein, ich weiß, dass es schnell war.
Nein, ich glaub dir das nicht. Klar, damals kam das schnell vor und damals war das schnell. Wenn du das jetzt anguckst, ist das nicht mehr schnell.
Nein, das ist heute langsamer.
Man bringe Tim einen alten Mac mit FrameMaker und dann wird hier nachgeklickt.
Heute in der MacDönen-Wocheshow.
Du musst das mal machen, glaub mir das.
Okay, da mag noch ein bisschen Geschichtsreibung drin geblieben sein. Aber es ist nicht schneller geworden. Auf jeden Fall nicht so viel schneller, wie diese Computerschneller geworden sind. Also das ist schon ein Armutszeugnis. Und so richtig sehr viel mehr tun sie auch nicht. Die Logik hab ich so noch nicht wiedergefunden. Inhaltsverzeichniserstellung mit Pages, da wirst du bekloppt. Also das ist...
Ja, also kann sein, dass das einfach scheiße ist, aber ich würde sagen, insgesamt sind Rechner verdammt viel schneller geworden. Ich brauch nur schon meinen alten Rechner mit Platte benutzen, um zu merken, dass der tausendmal langsamer ist als jetzt der hier mit SSD.
Ja, aber ich könnte diesen Auftrag so nicht machen, irgendwie heutzutage.
Ich hab mir so ein schönes Video gestern angeguckt, wo einer auf einem alten, auf dem ersten Mac, MacPaint erklärt und das so ein bisschen vorführt und wie MacPaint funktioniert hat, die ganzen Zeichenwerkzeuge und was man davon bis heute kennt. Und es ist echt liebevoll gemacht, so mit HD-Kamera und allem Pipapo. Und es ist auch schön, das nochmal alles zu sehen. Aber es ist echt unglaublich, wie langsam MacPaint damals auf dem Rechner war. Also ich weiß noch, dass es schon auf dem 6820er war, es doppelklickte und es war da einfach.
Ja, aber wir müssen uns darüber im Klaren sein. Es gab immer wieder Software, die war ihrerzeit dermaßen weit voraus, dass du das heutzutage einfach nicht hast. Ich sag mal ein kleines Beispiel von diesem Framemaker. Framemaker, konntest du ein Dokument in einer neueren Version sichern und in einer alten öffnen. Und zwar bei Design, weil sie das vorgesehen haben in diesem Dokumentenformat, dass die Dinge, die neu sind, irgendwie auch als solche markiert waren. Und du hattest irgendwie Maker Interchange Format, du konntest das Ganze irgendwie in ASCII repräsentieren mit seinem kompletten Visivic Climbim und das war irgendwie passbar und lesbar und ging auch noch mit alten Versionen auf und war irgendwie Cross-Plattform und jeder Scheiß. Das lief irgendwie auf Sun, das lief dann später auf Windows, das lief auf Mac, das war einfach geil. Das war geile Software und ist natürlich dann von Adobe gekauft worden und Krümel so vor sich hin gibt es halt jetzt noch irgendwie auf Windows, aber...
Wie hieß es denn vorher? War das hier Aldos oder...?
Haben sie das nicht in R neu geschrieben? Das ist auf Unix gestartet, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Ja, seitdem InDesign jetzt auch diese Adobe Flash GUI überall hat, wie die anderen Adobe Apps, ist das halt auch so eine Slug geworden, so ein sluggish-schleimiges Klick-Ding. Früher war das auch mal ein bisschen snappier.
Das ist unglaublich.
Adobe ist mit ihrem R, da sind sie jetzt in Full Denial der Realität betreten, oder? Jetzt helfen sie es irgendwie all ihren Programmen über, weil es sonst niemand mehr interessiert.
Ich wollte neulich mal wieder eine Demo-Version von Adobe ausprobieren, weil ich dachte, dass vielleicht deren Sound-Editor was taugt. Und als ich dann den Downloader installiert hatte, und der eher nachladen wollte, ohne Scheiß, das war nur das Programm, was nur runterladen sollte, und der sich dann irgendwie über meine 50 MBit-Leitung, das in 90 Kilobyte pro Sekunde runterloth, da bin ich dann irgendwann wieder zur Besinnung gekommen. Aber das war wirklich so. Ich werd nie erfahren, was das Programm kann, aber das war wirklich schmerzhaft.
Hm, ja, ne, das ist wirklich, also die Software- und Computerwelt, das ist wirklich ein Trauerspiel, was wir hier konsternieren. Konsternieren, sagt man das so? Attestieren.
Konstatieren. Aber wir sind auch konsterniert.
Nee, PageMaker ist aber was anderes als FrameMaker.
Definitiv.
Es geht einfach mit der Computerindustrie back ab, ja.
Aber du magst doch gar keine Frames.
Wer soll uns retten? Wer ist der neue Messias?
FrameMaker war schon wirklich outstanding, aber es ist dann leider auch total kaputtgemanaged worden, das muss man auch sagen. Also sie hatten dann auch nicht so richtig den Mumm, das Ding voranzutreiben und modern zu machen und hingen dann immer an ihren Bestandskunden fest. Und nein, wir können unser sinnloses, also die Shortcuts waren dann auch irgendwann echt dubios durcheinander, da hätte man mal wirklich mal aufräumen müssen. Dafür haben sie natürlich nie die Kraft gehabt, das alte Lied, unsere Kunden kennen das so und so und deswegen ändern wir das nicht. Und dann fehlt da halt irgendwann dann auch die Innovationskraft.
Freehand war früher auch so geil.
Hauptproblem war, dass Alores nicht weiterentwickelt hat und nicht weiterentwickelt hat.
Ich hab's nicht benutzt, aber wie viele Leute Express benutzt haben.
Das erinnert mich an diese komische Switcher-Story. Es gab doch irgendwie für das ganz alte Mac OS, gab's doch irgendwann mal dieses Programm, was so ein Typ geschrieben hat, wo man mehrere Programme switchen konnte, bevor Mac OS das tatsächlich selber konnte.
Das haben sie dann aufgekauft und haben das Multifinder genannt.
Genau und der Typ, der das gemacht hatte, der hatte irgendeinen komischen Keyboard-Shortcut für dieses Switchen der Programme gemacht. Und als sie es dann aufgekauft hatten bei Apple, merkten sie dann irgendwie das Word von Microsoft, aber diesen Keyboard-Shortcut auch belegt hat. Dann haben die gesagt, ja, Microsoft, dann sag mal, welcher Keyboard-Shortcut frei ist. Und dann dauerte es eine Runde und dann kam von Microsoft nur zurück, ja, ist schon okay, behaltet den Keyboard-Shortcut, wir legen unseren irgendwie um, wir können euch auch nicht sagen, was frei ist.
Das hat sich auch bis heute nicht geändert, offensichtlich. Oder? Also, ich meine, sie wissen nicht, was frei ist. Die können mir noch nicht mal was anbieten.
Das ist irgendwie so in diesem...
Switcher hieß das Ding.
Damals war auch die Software besser.
Ja, so viel aus der Abteilung. Früher war alles besser. Und wir sind alte, eingesessene Leute, die sich mit ihrem aktuellen Betriebssystem gar nicht so gut auskennen, dass sie live...
Gefremdeln ein bisschen.
Gefremdeln, genau. Wir haben Angst vor der Zukunft. Und wir prangern alles an.
Wenn wir schon über Linux reden.
Ja, wir sind alt. Macht euch das klar. Wie können wir uns verjüngen? Wem müssen wir zuhören? Wer bringt uns das Licht?
Wer ist dein neuer Steve?
Mark Zuckerberg.
Wer bringt uns? Wer zieht uns mit? Wer zeigt uns den Weg?
Hast du schon den Button gemacht? Dann los, mach den.
Dennis, was ist mit dir? Zeigst du uns den Weg?
Ab Mittwoch 6 Uhr kann man Raspberries Pies bespülen.
Jedes Mal wieder dieses Teil.
Kauft euch das bis dahin.
Und dann reden wir dann nochmal drüber.
Ja, es gibt halt keinen, sonst wär's ja einfach. Sonst könnte man ja mit dem Finger drauf zeigen und sagen, ja bitte. Entweder machen wir selber oder wir verbringen einfach die nächste Zeit hier mit diesem Podcast und Prangern weiter.
Aber wir wollen nicht selber auf der Bühne stehen, ne? Wir sitzen da oben wie Waldo von Statler und machen unsere Witze. So, wollen wir uns und alle anderen erlösen? Von dieser Sendung?
Lassen sie mich frei, ich bin durch.
Tim rantet auch schon auf dem letzten Loch.
Ich blicke hier schon mit Bewunderung auf die Show Notes und da machen wir dann einen schick Kapitel draus und dann wird wieder alles gut. Jetzt sagen wir...
Ich hätte noch ein Video, hätte ich ja noch. Warte, warte. Ja, warte, warte, zum Abschluss. Das passt sich nur im Chat.
Hoffentlich haben wir da bald mal hier. Erbflay auf diesem Komwendungsteil.
Titelvorschläge bitte.
Das ist doch das Gute an Snow.
Wir können das hier auf dem Beamer auch High-DP machen. Das würde viel cooler kommen, glaube ich.
Zu diesem Thema, früher war alles besser und so weiter. Das kannst du auch noch mal in die Show-Notes zum früher war alles besser tun. Guck mal, das ist schön. So, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Jetzt können wir raus.
Du musst aber erst dieses Quarz-Debug haben. Sonst geht das nicht. Soll ich dir das schnell mal rüberschieben?
Da stürzt doch nur deine Aufnahmesoftware ab, wenn nur drinnen die DPI auflöst.
Ach so. So, was war wie was, Volvo?
Da dieser Link da, dieser YouTube-Link, den öffne ich noch mal mit in die Show-Notes zum Thema Früher war alles besser und dann jetzt nicht abspielen.
Das ist Wurstbrot von meinem Heimat. Das ist sehr schön, ja.
Das ist sehr schön, aber jetzt nicht.
Das ist dann sozusagen nachdem wir Tschüss gesagt haben.
Genau, das ist so noch zum Verdauen für alle anderen Kunden dran.
Okay, das wir ja auch noch unsere Urheberrechtsverletzung noch unterbekommen haben.
Ah, ich merke in ihm brodelt was.
Es gärt, es muss raus.
Das ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Ich hole Herrn Priol dann, stoßen wir zusammen an. Ich glaube, das Wind auf dem Blut. Zeit zu Zeit sehe ich den alten Gern und wüte mich mit ihm für recht. Aber es war jetzt der Moment. Ich wusste, ich wusste ihn, er war kurz davor, diesen einen Satz zu sagen. Der Satz, der mich in den Irrsinn treibt, der mich hier reingebracht hat, der mich meine ganze Jugend überverfolgt hat, den sie alle kennen. Sie können ihn alle mitbeten. Sie kennen ihn alle. Der Satz lautet natürlich, früher war alles besser. Jawohl, das ist heiße. Nichts war früher besser. Das stimmt nicht. Das ist ein Quadratunsinn. Nichts war früher besser. Früher war vieles früher. Das ist richtig. Ja, der September war auch schon im April. Das macht sich doch kein Mensch mehr klar. Aber früher war nichts besser. Aber es gab Sachen, die waren früher gut. Und sie wären es auch heute noch, wenn man die Finger davon gelassen hätte. Beispiel. Das Wurstbrot. Da wo ich herkomme, ist das Zerwallat. Vorne mit Cent hinten ohne Brot. Verstehst du einfach? Zerwallat. Man kann auch sagen Salami-Brot, Wurstbrot, Dauerwurstbrot, Block-Wurstbrot, Egyvius-Block, das ist erfunden hat. Das Wurstbrot. Wie geht ein Wurstbrot? Fangen wir unten an für die Unkundigen im Süden. Da ist eine Scheibe Graubrot. Graues Brot. Mit einer richtigen Kruste. Daran die Zähne gut knackens haben, würde der völlig zu Unrecht verstorben sein, als die da höchst sagen, Männer noch lebte. Richtiges Brot. Aus echten Körnern. Mit Mehl. Graus. Mit einem eigenen Geschmack. Die Älteren werden sich erinnern. Genau. Nein! Grau-Sport! Da drauf. Daumendick.
Und Goldgelb.
Gute Butter heißt das. Gute Butter ist ein Wort. Gute Butter. Genau wie klar war es da. Goldgelbe, gute Butter. Und das Brot schmeckt von oben, dann die Butter ran. Und die Butter schmeckt von oben runter auf das Brot. Und dann lernen sie sich kennen. Und dann tun sie sich zusammen. Denn sie wissen, da gibt es doch richtig was aufs Dach. Und dann, das ist jetzt ganz wichtig, die Zettelrausstifte gleich mitschreiben. Das ist ganz wichtig. Drei. Der Kumpel. Vorbei, drei Scheiben Zervalatos! Die müssen wie die Dachschilder übereinander liegen und Brot und Butter schmeckt von unten an die Wurst und die Wurst schmeckt von oben runter und Brot und Butter! Und dann gibt es zusammen eine Geschmacksdetonation, dass dann die Zähne aus dem Hals bläst, wenn sie nicht anständig verschraubt sind. Das ist eine Kulturkonstante. Bis zu diesem furchtbaren Tag, an dem irgendeine mental verrottete Bäckerschmortel da Mayonnaise draufgepackt hat und ein Salat, Tomaten und gekochtes Ei. Du hast das Gefühl, du beißt in einen Komposthaufen. Das gibt es doch gar nicht. Ich bin für den Einsatz des Militärs im eigenen Land. Die Soldaten müssen in Bahnhöfen unter vorgehaltener Waffe die Bäcker zwingen, ihre verdammte Erlebnisvitrine leer zu fressen. Ein Bäcker soll um drei Uhr aufstehen, Backenfresser um acht in Bettli. Ist das denn so schwer? Das mache ich jeden Abend. Können Sie sich das vorstellen? Dass ich das gesundheitlich überhaupt mitmache. Auf der anderen Seite finde ich, dass gerade so eine durchaus verkopfte Veranstaltung wie diese seinen Hauchemotion durchaus verträgt. Auf der anderen Seite sehe ich jedoch etliche sehr spärlich möblierte Gesichter. Meine ganz einfache Frage zacht von hinten an die Glasmurmelklopf, die die Augen darstellen. Und die Frage lautet natürlich, mein Gott, was hat der Mann? Rechtschrater!